No.
Restart. Oh, wait a minute.
Good.
Yeah.
3.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm what they call trouble. Yeah, right.
Move around the program. Yeah, yeah,
I've been doing it.
Sometimes I'm trouble with that.
I know what I'm talking about.
I'm treating like that.
But yeah,
I've been working here since 2018,
so actually five days later than my
seven-year anniversary.
Well, seven day anniversary. Yeah. Hey,
that's very something. Yeah, you do. So.
Yeah, I was done.
I was an assistant project coordinator
and we were working in task role and then
I became the project coordinator and then
I became lead project coordinator.
Now I'm a shop project engineer, so cool.
And Jeremy, that's for sure.
I feel like I've almost been in every
single office on the property.
I'd rather do anything than get anywhere
near project management. Yeah,
that's my main thing.
Well,
it's kind of looking like they're going
to turn me into the tech,
so it looks like it it should be.
I'll be implementing that. So yeah, so.
Good morning. Good morning.
Uh.
Hit the ground running this morning.
Got my worm 3:30 and I've got my copy and
I'm ready to go. Yep, I'm update.
Now I'm just doing a Microsoft update
just to make sure my computer isn't.
Isn't the issue in between.
So would you have a try and see if you
can crash again? I tried. Yeah, I've been.
I've been in the office since 12:00 this
morning and we haven't kept the hell on.
It's been there really nothing but love
that, so.
Move the speed and move it.
That's all right. Today she feels smaller.
Update went good.
We got the new database for the
electrical, so we need that set up and.
Are there people who come here?
So I think Jarrod's going to be in.
He's going to be in.
So they'll guess also I just had to take
you back and then take you down with it
so.
My guess is once we get at least the
baseline,
what they're expecting established,
I'll work from home once or twice next
week and sit in my home office and plug
the air for, yeah.
OK, I don't wanna have to work.
It'll be interesting, yeah,
but depends on what their expectations
are.
Hopefully they're reasonable expectations
on ones that are outside of the yeah,
the available of what we can do. Yeah,
but but I manage it's probably something
similar to what I've been doing and
requisitions for.
For nesting wire,
I'm gonna have us add wire sizes and
gauges in there and and we'll just keep
those in the same where your metric is is
the round bar.
5 minutes. That's where it'll get.
Interesting. You'll have to put it in.
The wire is what like however many feet
that you actually buy in the school or
whatever it is, yeah.
It's even even like we can buy all the
way up to 30,000 foot schools. Yeah, but.
Yeah,
we'll see what see what it comes to when
we get to that. And then yeah,
Alan's gonna kick up shot packages this
morning.
So he's just gonna listen from in there
until until we get back in here and then
looks like for our agenda today.
This integration found everything
blasting and then electrical.
And then I think that's.
There's some white topics that that we
can burn through really quick.
So we can take a look at the production
and we'll look at our routes,
see if there's any adjustment they should
make,
make sure that they have the rest of the
route set up, the coding's added and then.
I think we can still drop the road back
till you run.
I don't, I don't feel, I mean,
you tell me what you think.
I don't feel good at all about the
estimating time,
estimating labor and maybe the total
labor is coming out right. I don't know,
but it seems like that's what is being
used, but the.
I don't know if that's maybe that's
something we we could always give back to
or like, OK, yeah,
we need something else to do that's.
There is focus. I'm here for it. Honestly,
I do know that they're going to keep
pushing for us to have a higher
percentage,
even though everything's been adjusted
for 75%. We've never really tweaked that.
We're going to change the settings,
but on the default estimates started.
98% and then the estimator can adjust
down or up. Yeah, and then uh,
kind of tweak our numbers so that they're.
That we can, we can ask what people feel,
but.
Are we going in the schedule at all?
Mark didn't want us to touch screen until
he could be in here. OK,
it's the last day ended on it. Yeah,
so tomorrow will be in here full and is
there anyone that at least.
I feel like I've got a comfortable grasp
on everything. So yeah,
not much benefit on my side,
but for him and doing future production
planning. Mm-hmm.
I know he's gonna wanna in there and try
to forecast some things. OK, so that was.
And I haven't really touched any of the
future forecasting.
So that'll be definitely a little bit of
a refresher for me just reading what they
have and I released them somewhere now.
So but you're using the project schedule.
Yeah.
Are you talking about using it in the
production plan? Yeah,
the production planner and the.
So I've used the work packages and added
work packages into our production planner.
Yep, done that. We haven't really.
Full scale,
not really like using the production
binder. Yeah, essentially.
So steps to using the production binder
in its most efficient way so that we can.
Between me and Alan,
if he's gonna keep releasing the packages
and he is the shop project engineer, yeah,
I should at least be scheduling them out
so that we have some idea of what we have
to release work. Yeah, yeah,
I know we'll keep our own Microsoft
project schedule on the side and need to
forecast everything.
Multiple different platforms,
but I know that our channel goal is to be
there. So,
so if we can get it there and we can
justify that, it's just insufficient. Yep,
Yep, so.
But so just in kind of like Nathan,
thank you for that in the spirit business.
Said it might be 80 degrees today.
Almost 15 degrees above normal.
Now I'm sweating. Gotta go to Lincoln.
I have a gym bag in my car and then I'm
switching a new T-shirt.
There's like the story going on, you know,
by 2050, Phoenix would be.
It could be so hot, right?
I don't want that temperature.
It's the hottest. I mean, I remember 123,
I think.
I remember it was once said a couple
years ago.
And that's revenue down here.
So I have summers on record now as being
the one that is great once in downtown
Phoenix. It was proven.
I've been there for eight years, so.
Yeah, yeah. In summary it's hard,
especially with our iPads and stuff,
like crazy.
When do the guys paint?
I mean the paint just flash that. Yeah,
it depends.
We probably have to keep it in ice
buckets when they try and paint and shade.
They use that internal area quite a bit
and then once things dry out to.
And then they move things out and then a
lot double handling,
trying to start slow down so that they
can,
they can get all their stuff down the
universe as much as possible.
Yeah,
my goal is to live in Durango in the
summers.
It needs to be honorable by the time my
house is paid out.
I think I have to do something eventually
about water. Yeah, oh,
that was already making me regret having
to use water.
That was, uh,
this has been my favorite part of being a
new homeowner.
They charge me more for water treatment
than we have for water.
But that's a joy to living out in the
sticks.
I can help me on the Internet too.
Where you live? Oh, OK,
so who else take me to get here?
Depends on what time.
This one only took me about 40 minutes to
get in because there wasn't anybody the
crickets on the road, but.
He said it's about 15 minutes in the
morning,
an hour to an hour and 10 minutes at
night.
Left at 6:00 last night to be about an
hour and 5 minutes. So about 30 miles,
but it's all about cross streets the
whole way. Yeah, I looked up to.
Apartments out there,
it's definitely a little cheaper,
but yeah,
I just bought a new build out there and
the the builder was buying down rates,
so I got 3.7% of my house, so.
So couldn't pass that on.
Hello.
So just like in my.
Thank you.
Look at that latest release version 2035
by SP2. I just noticed that. No,
I wasn't that early this morning when I
was logged in and said I'm assuming that.
That patch is all edited,
but so that's what. Yeah, yeah,
Keith sent out an e-mail this morning and
it is SP1 patch dates.
Yes, yeah.
But I haven't had any issues that may
have been running, um, inspection test.
I'm looking forward. Bam. Beautiful. Yeah.
And to that, we will see looking forward.
All right. Well,
what's what's kind of weird about all
that is if at a different shop every week,
right. So, yeah,
what's so weird is I'm in one place that
you run just very like last week we were
running the toy group on the highest of
York. And then we'll go to the next place.
So weird.
We've seen that worse luck when it comes
to hygiene stuff.
It is the uphill battle every time,
but that's right. Eventually,
it sounds like they're going to be doing
a whole new service stacks and they're
paying the company to.
Completely redo our servers. Oh wow.
And this Keith is our original IT guy.
He built everything that's gone on around
here. Yeah,
and that whole service stack himself.
And then now he's like, all right.
Y'all this. Yeah.
We're long grown now and we have so many
different companies that you're trying to
tie together. Yeah.
You need to pay somebody who knows how to
tie these together. Yeah.
So is it gonna be?
On Premise server, OK, yeah,
we'll have the the server on on premise.
It'll be the same area in the main office
where the current one is. Yeah,
it'll just be a whole lot more beefy or
the server.
Something that wasn't Frankenstein
together over five years,
then that's gonna be looking at it for
sure or something like, you know,
off site that those can be fun to dial in
and get this work itself.
It's it's always slow when we first get
that route.
Yeah.
OK,
so Vista integration discussion actually
is here to do this quick to and then well
we talked about this the a couple of
times is it?
Orth integrating,
I guess is the right question. Yeah,
that's the main thing.
Really.
The the hardware is really gonna listen
to what I say. Awesome. Yeah.
So that's.
I guess this will do this.
I mean to like create a meeting.
Yeah.
I mean,
I imagine there's a lot of companies that
just run a check to and that's it.
They run the whole business off of it.
That's, yeah,
they'll have different software for
accounting, obviously,
because this isn't an accounting software,
but.
They don't feed it, but yeah,
this is my software feed.
Part of it last time,
but I'm trying to question the reporting.
They wouldn't want to give me some.
All right, so yeah,
I guess the main thing would be.
Which I can take notes here.
This is integration wise.
And I know we talked about it last time
and we read quite vividly whatever
management wanted was not what we can do
regardless of the version problem.
So they essentially wanted all of our
labor codes.
To be from estimate pushed into
production and then have our labor
exported in the time tracking way that we
do in those time tracking reports with
the labor codes associated pushed back
into this.
So yeah,
because you're basically not doing the
diamond in here anyways, so well,
and we do all of our time tracking in
Tekla, everything that we export to Vista,
we.
Export out of here in an Excel sheet that
has each employee's information,
employee number,
and then whenever we set up a project,
each sequence and block is actually your
face code.
So 39, one thousand.
So we end up filtering our tabs down and
kind of setting it out and remapping the
the sheet so that it can be.
But into Vista with this OK and Vista
pulls the 39,
000 in the employee number and the hours
associated and imports that I guess.
So actually and then you're having to do
that on your project or it's just
automatic, it's set up.
We do that for every project and the
whole weekly supports and it's a week and
adjust the Excel sheet and snip that took
them.
So so this that you look at it in best
case scenario.
It's a big buy. Yeah,
essentially like all of our favorable.
We're we have that when we so
everything's slightly behind.
So we have two different.
Two different contracting systems.
We have the face recognition system
that's completely external entity of all
of it.
Each employee clocks in with their face
recognition so they're understandable
when they come in and then when they're
working on projects with you,
they're also duplicating those hours.
Into Tekla so that this one will go to
our project schedule.
You can see that's where the hours come
back in here. Yeah,
hours come back against the project.
And you know percent complete versus
hours used as we're going along.
This is what we reviewed in our Thursday
meetings updating the engine and
production. So we'll see if we have.
You know about production stations or
trying to talk about production stations
or the contracting.
Need to start running tracking one. OK,
cool. Is there a daily labor report?
Um.
Yes and no.
I don't know if there's a specific report
that you can pull across all projects
because it's project management side and
project management side doesn't have
reports that pull across every single
project management job, but each day.
I get an e-mail from the shop lead that
is basically a recap from the previous
day of hours used. What increased?
What increased if we're a negative trend?
With hours versus percent completes and
so on and so forth.
So I get this report daily me and Mark
get it so that we can start getting ahead
of it.
And then this is this is our weekly sheet
that we review.
And go around Fridays,
which is essentially the snapshots of the
production schedules that are in each
project sequence and associated just to
review what's been used,
where where our percentages are at. Yeah,
I get that when you're evaluating
projects, but.
On the accounting side, you've always,
I've always used to being able to look at
daily labor period. Forget which job.
Yeah, I mean,
I can go into the time track in module 35
or during over hours and we can fold.
Well, I wasn't interviewed each day,
I guess. So being that probably is,
I know what you're talking about.
Do you track productive labour versus
unproductive labour?
With direct versus indirect,
I guess is a better way to say it like
yes,
we do have an indirect project to be here
where guys can apply their times that are
on indirect which would be our 1200.
This is all anything entered towards this
project.
Project it was the indirect costs,
but most of the time the solution saw the
rest if we were using this.
So most of the time all of our times
allocated the projects.
So on you.
Time tracking summary I can pull.
Sure.
Yesterday it stayed.
And this will give me a summary of.
All the labor that was entered yesterday.
So there's a couple of guys.
I think this one needs to be adjusted.
There's no way in hell somebody yesterday
did 37.25 dollars on.
Project 21 day.
So this would be where Ramon or TJ goes
in and goes, excuse me,
what employee versus this and why in the
world is this displaying? Productive.
Good. So yeah.
But yeah, this is,
this is probably the best,
best area for this.
So and then and what you're telling me is
each line item is a person or it's really
the summation of multiple people in that
job.
This is our entire shots yesterday, right?
So, so yesterday somebody,
some group of people wanted.
You know,
charge 37 hours to indirect job 1200 year.
Yes,
and we end up going to here and they
worked in the shipping receiving
department. Uh,
this does not you should be receiving.
So why they?
Why are they wanting to the handling?
Because shipping and receiving does not
handle our material for us.
They often trust. That's it.
If it requires to be moved around the
shop or pulled out of the shop or station
in the front because it's completed or
needs to go from the station to Weld
station, all of that is.
Handling by a shot of police. Yeah,
so we essentially.
The majority of our projects have.
Well handling the cuts on burn each of
these burn cuts on fit up and well all
types of station.
So those give percent complete mark offs
as they go through the.
Mark up to piece tracking and uh and fit
up some types of inspections that's uh is
tied to our cut list.
Bird is tied to the cut list as well and
then well it is a.
Well, inspection shot, so.
That's that's what we got there.
But.
No.
Well,
that exports out of using that payroll as
well. Yeah, cool. So working. Yeah.
What do you like? What do you don't like?
I guess the biggest thing that they
they're they're trying to automate
everything.
I think that that was their intentional
goal with the Vista integration is to not
have us pulling Excel sheets,
modifying them so that they can be
affordable and and then having that extra
step.
But I'm pretty sure from what the Vista
integration is,
is the invoice out from a purchase orders
standpoint all on the purchasing side
there.
So and that I mean for purchasing
stealing here.
And that's pretty much the extent of it
with the exception of a few sub
fabrication EOS that I put together.
And so,
so with that I I don't really see because
I'm sure with the Vista with purchasing
that.
Module.
There's money associated with that,
but it's not going to eliminate us time
to do double work.
So we're gonna spend money instantly,
the double work. So it just doesn't.
It doesn't seem like a good investment.
Yeah, so.
Yeah, that's I I'll say this.
I don't see them ever.
Pulling the contracting and automatic and
the only reason I say is because so many
do not be the contracting so.
Their thought was probably my last.
Um, all the times that are spent. So yeah,
I wouldn't count.
So why do people not try to care time?
The interface is a little clunky on the
for the.
The contract and so things and a lot of
people are using a a payroll software to
their their contract in order to do that
rather than any. So yeah,
which definitely makes sense because I
would definitely agree with that
statement. I mean if we go into.
For time tracking and you do the time
tracking input like if we go in here and
it's easier to see on the EPM go,
but like the notes section,
there's so many random notes in there and
you can't hardly believe them.
It just stayed in there.
And it's it's and usually it's one letter,
enter back into it, one letter,
enter back into one letter.
So it takes you 5 to 10 minutes to put an
entry in.
So a lot of the guys will track it on the
sheet, give it to her, Nolan,
they'll enter it in about 5 minutes here
and it's done. So,
so many people want really good time
tracking in here.
And this this is functional,
so it's not there. Yeah,
and we're definitely using it,
but I've actually considered like like my
my son has a master's in data science and
so I'm actually considered.
Paying him to do a better interface with
with some more controls and stuff around.
So if I were able to get there,
I'd experiment you since you're new to it.
Yeah,
that would be that would be pretty
awesome, so.
So what system of time captured in
currently times captured in here tracking
is production exported out and and then
verified against our facial recognition
system that we have in the shop we
compare.
The numbers to the numbers to make sure
that they all match and then and then we
submitted the actual Excel sheet from
this from tech blog to EW.
So our facial recognition was installed
when we used to have QuickBooks and it
was using the same.
We would just clock in with their face
and clock out with their face and then
we'll just send it.
But that way you give us the project
breaking up and what they're working on.
This gives us the ability to know what
project they're working on,
detailed environment with the final
projects that day.
And the time is actually divided up
between 5:00 versus.
That's why you use both.
I mean there's one to figure out which
projects they worked on during the day
and the other one just to try. Yep,
pretty much.
One's the in and out and one's the.
Because the guy puts in his face, phone,
whatever you want to do it.
Job X workstate, you know, workstation Y.
And he may work five jobs a day,
but it's all system.
It seems probably that it's very, well,
this one,
and this one actually do it all in one,
like he wanted the.
I'm trying to correct me if I'm wrong,
but the facial thing that that was the
thing from.
Yeah, right.
Make sure some people were actually
working. Yeah,
the same people were actually working.
It does auto-temp checks and but even
then it was a.
Making sure you're coming in at the right
time and then documenting with somebody's
over 5 minutes late kind of thing cause
in here you can go in there and say you
started at 4:00 in the morning and if you
know he was there to verify that.
But if you have to put your face in front
of the monitor and it takes a picture of
you and you get in,
then then you're held more accountable.
So yeah,
it goes together with the way it's like
where they do what it's like and they're
only talking to the phone. Yeah, so, so.
And that's the other side of us using
this.
And that in the morning they walk by,
catches their pace,
they can go off to the floor,
start working and then they have their
iPads on their cell phones and they can
instantly right there update on this next
project. I'm talking on this one,
this one.
So I'll tell you what,
I would want to try to automate for the
the reporting. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's something I also look into as
well.
Well.
And setting it up for for just Monday's
each week.
The problem I ran into that would be I'm
getting a call from the shop manager. Hey,
I am coming to your time for Friday. Yes,
I need you to hold off on it and then I
got a report exported out to five people
on like.
Hold on this. Yeah,
this needs to be addressed for if
somebody decided to put 36 in there
instead of three or six. Yeah,
so and but I think that that could be.
And I say automated reformat it so you
don't have to change it once you crap
your format the the spreadsheet or to get
it in. Oh yeah,
there'd be there'd be a way to get an
album the right format that you need it
to.
Custom export that would be that would be
definitely the the other beneficial side
is not going to pull a bunch of columns
out there not to what we need if you want
to look into that I've got.
I'll give you names of some people that
can do that. OK.
Doesn't look like first reports kind of
the rules. Yeah.
How much time does that take you?
Doing the time for us, right? 5 minutes.
Per day on Monday, one day a week,
one day a week. Yeah, that's all. Yeah.
So that's that's been the biggest thing
is we haven't done too many like custom
reports in here because Crystal reports
gonna get.
They can get spending.
You got a lot of different things that
you want.
Maybe you want to get changed and
adjusted around.
So are you the only one that does it or
reserve when you're on vacation?
Somebody else does it. No,
there's other people that can do it.
You shop.
One of the shop leads remote because the
time tracking emails that he sends out,
he can do the exports.
Mark can do the exports as well.
You can just do the the fab guy or
somebody else does the paint guys.
Paint guys don't use this system
whatsoever.
They are.
They've been very anti system for a long
time and now we are pushing heavily for
them to use it and with Moe being the the
leader of buildings at this point,
he's very on board with it, so.
Um,
we're taking full advantage of having an
advocate on the side. So they say both.
Yeah. Yeah, it's definitely, uh.
This definitely came a long way, me and.
OK.
So I guess if this was talk through
business integration,
what we can do as well integration
basically, let me see if we can find.
So this is what she got.
So I am trying to add a heat member and
obviously attach and be document to it
like an MTR. Oh also didn't heat.
All directors understand.
This is something that needs that there
you can set that globally.
This is something about how it came over.
It's like you got to get this globally.
Finally got it this year,
so you need to set that up locally.
So we can see the preset matrix.
You can set that up right there and it
just goes out everybody rather than the
individual setting.
There's there's no reason it should be an
individual setting.
So yeah,
as long as everybody has a hard drive map
map, you know, Yeah, now.
Pretty much everybody should have on our
map that's in temporary.
Do you not have any customer reports?
Because right now there's no place for
customer reports. OK, I like the log, Sir.
We may talk about this last time.
Reason I like that is because when you
when you do an import.
Everybody knows exactly where to go to
see the law.
So like even project managers were like,
OK, something happened on the job,
on the import. What was it?
Or was it regissions that I needed to go
change or they could actually go to the
log and pull it up?
Without having to get your computer full
on your log apparently. But yeah,
you said that it added at the bottom,
but then it's everybody used to say by
default everybody's going to have the
check box set for default up there.
OK,
so now I'm gonna try and see if see if it
also lets me do that.
Yeah,
I'm definitely not opposed to putting all
of that on the server.
Yeah, I'll get the key.
Would anybody else here ever be be
wanting to buy or customize the report
beside you?
Because they'll be able to customize it.
They'll just be customizing the the end
report and next time you get an update,
they'll override it.
Probably not. Probably. If anything,
I'll get the request and then I'll do it.
So we try to do some modifications for
our shop traveler,
but that's using fully Indian Go,
moving with paper documentation anyways,
so.
Not at this point, yeah,
but if you didn't just set that.
Get a fold roll so we can set that.
That makes it. Yep. Cool.
I think I've been looking for that for a
long, not a meeting with you,
but finally last year I called them up
and I'm like, we're having a meeting,
like I'm sure if I fight this because
everywhere I have been, people are like,
well,
I've looked at the journal and I'm going
to see the journal.
Yeah,
I've had a few times that I've had
whenever a new union start. Yeah,
they reach out and send me something
who's not right here. Mm-hmm.
Just check over here,
send him a screenshot of this.
Make sure it's that you got it next still.
No, it's definitely useful. Yeah,
but that's that.
I'll make the adjustments so that
everything's on the server,
'cause that would be that would be like
better. So yeah, OK.
That's what I was looking for base code.
So this is their new massive governing
base code guide.
What's most important we have is.
39 all the way.
So.
This is kind of a structure that they
want us to use for these buildings.
So we located 39 rejection this time will
be 391000.
Which is a typical,
it's longer than 39 and for company 40.
So Company 40,
Division 39 and then the activity levels
is where they break it out for.
So each so 39 is fab. Yeah,
39 is anything we do with the structural
production. Got it.
So and then.
Or electrical civil.
Each one has their own has their own
thing,
so so everybody is 40 then beyond that
base codes associated with each trade and
area of work.
Or what?
So if this fit goes all the way through
low, yeah.
So if you were to look at company,
whatever,
you would see very same consistency for
the shop and Bloomfield. Yeah, yeah,
I think the same thing, to be honest,
not sure much of.
No, I I get it. I don't either.
But I'm just curious if everything is the
same. Yeah, this is the laundry,
the standard fees,
the long gross supply and the so.
Following with your other shops,
if you're reintegrating there or or
implementing this,
they are document crap out.
The the best multi shop facilities I've
seen are the ones that.
Document and they want to pull in here
and everybody's moving the exact same way.
Don't allow them to do it differently.
Document it. Here's the procedure.
Here's what we're going about.
Everybody's doing it.
Don't make it an option.
Yeah, otherwise it's mass chaos.
I just see it. No, you have to have it.
And I think one of the things here is
flow charts and descriptions for
everything. I mean, heck,
when you do an ERP upgrade if you don't
have it.
People think they know what it is,
but they have no idea what it is. Yeah,
yeah,
I learned that one hard way last year.
So if you're if if you're using those 39
codes.
I don't see an issue like I was thinking
that we were talking about the the codes
would be.
A beam might be one too,
depending on how it's it's used,
how what type of product it's going into,
and it might be a different one.
For another type of sampling, yeah,
but I don't see those cadence here.
I just see fabricated steel.
So this one's,
this one's most of the time are typical,
are typical face coat for labor and when
I get.
Multiple sequences or multiple areas of
work. It'll be 391000.01.
That's just labor. What about material?
Material is 083 thousand is usually the
one that we initiate into them.
So we usually take playing angles,
channels, beams, everything.
I'll get slumped up into that one phase.
So, so you're telling me that, OK,
if I have a.
Piece of pipe that I use in a structural
project, it would be that 0830.
But if I use a piece of pipe on a rail,
it's still it's still going to be 0830.
Yeah,
it's most of the time they don't end up
getting into the material hammer or
breaking everything on that thoroughly.
They they usually keep everything into a
structural steel bucket.
The only time you will see that number
differ is if we have multiple material
buckets for areas of work on the project.
OK, so that we can make.
So we can have one of the estimates
automatically give you the.
That's easy to do.
What I was understanding was you might
have one code which is structural,
a different code which is miscellaneous,
a different code if it's something that's
right.
If that locates, that's more difficult.
Now you're basically going to have to say
every single line item,
what that thing's going to be for that
material.
But if all materials are going to say
things good, that's easy.
We can set it up to the estimate.
Just at the end of the estimate,
here's all, here's all the things.
Which would be associated across.
So that's that that would be simple to do
on the back end and you can put the you
would get it on the POS as well.
So it would it would be a nearly
automatic.
Now your labor.
Yeah. Yeah. And then, I mean,
even if we were,
even if we put in the whole materials,
that's only 3000 and we did have one is.
Most of the time it's going to be that
plus whatever connotation is going to
differentiate it in the area of work if
the project's at large. Outside of that,
then it's then it's basically that'll be
our governing code for material.
So a lot of times,
depending upon the the project engineer
and team team I'm working with for the
field project, yeah,
it'll be sometimes I get that same phase
code is that I've written all the
procedures for.
PC forms, project release forms,
how we do the technical side of things,
how we expect projects to come in and
everything and so on that.
Where's that information where you've
written all those procedures?
Where's that?
I have to see where it's located in the R
drive at this point or in the J drive.
But I have a.
Will you send me a link next week or
something? Yeah, I'd like to read that.
Yeah,
I've got procedures for any procedure or
form I've created for anything that we
have in the shop.
Checklists and associated.
So this is the form I created for when
somebody released the project to us using
project number, need dates, onsite date,
requirements, manager, project manager,
engineer, customer.
Client information, shipping address,
delivery site, who's handling it,
coding specs,
whether or not the PE ordered any of the
bio items or hardware.
Any specific project notes that we need
if the engineer pre-ordered any of the
materials and the PO is associated.
And a lot of times we don't get a
breakdown.
So they'll send us the face code from
what they had.
So this is the change order.
So they ended up making 39,
000 change order #9 and they had 63 hours
estimated.
So at this point we would then look at it.
And try and do our own breakdown just
based upon reviewing the prints.
And then as soon as what's what I would
do before you. Yeah,
and I'm pretty certain this is not
estimated in that book. This was.
And I think 63 hours is what we need for
that and that was just pushed through.
So that is something that you know I'm
I'm curious about.
So the estimate does give you that break
in,
but it seems like they take the total and
they do their own work.
Regardless of what I said,
does he have anything you want?
So a lot of it is because I'll I'll even
modify it sometimes even on my own just
because like the burn time.
It'll give us however many hours and then
I'll take those hours to look at the burn
time and I'll pull up my pro nest and
I'll take the physical laser run time and
then I'll assume we have an hour per
shoot, 15 minutes for load,
15 minutes for unload,
depending upon the scale of the.
Bars that are on there and so burns one
that we see a lot of adjustment on from
what Tesla has for doing the perimeter
burn for the time calculated in here
versus what my laser time is saying plus
me factoring in loading, unloading.
We need to fix that.
I mean that's that's a very simple thing
to do.
So if you're constantly adjusting it and
you know what you want to adjust it to,
that's easy to fix.
I was going to fix it is what I would do
so that that everybody's going to have to
re-estimate afterwards estimates,
you know, and having.
Right.
Would be another question about that,
you know,
so that's that was one of the issues what
one day was, OK, we're starting to see it,
OK,
how do we know what we're we need to get
this to there were really.
That was pretty perfect coming from shots.
So that was we established it when they
wanted that place though.
It's because what happens is they they go
through the hours and they use under the
hours.
They have guys that they want to keep as
the place because they're in place.
So they just tell them, oh, go ahead.
We have extra time on this job,
so close to that and would be still at
that time. That's what they're doing.
That's quite an hour. Yeah. So yeah,
we can fix that.
So people are having to manipulate all
this stuff.
Yeah, so you can.
We can definitely fix that.
Who estimates this change order?
This one would probably Richard and this
one. Does he have access exactly?
There's not. Well,
they're not really estimating,
but they're estimating off the field in
some little spreadsheet, right? I'm sure.
I'm sure too.
So that's why it's not in tech. Ideally,
in a lot it would be nice if everybody
use tech.
That's the end goal and and so unless one
of these BOT members reached out to Karam
Hawk or myself and Gaylus is still the
work he has put this into the system and
estimated.
More than likely,
this one was not estimated in Tekla.
Are you used to that document from the
field that was that they're actually
having access to Tekla in the field?
I have not seen that.
I don't see it in the shop. Sure.
They do it if they have field access to
it, then the guys know how to use it.
If they have a room,
there's another there's another
fabricator here in Phoenix that's going
on.
They've got a field for development
groups access all the girls in here.
They record.
Here's some material showed up on site.
Here's some material right there.
So yeah, is that happening here?
You know, there's probably.
Maybe 10 people that access that and of
this giant list of estimators.
This is Alan in there and he's done a few
test projects.
I estimated in your office that makes it
here as it's honest,
as it's orange estimates in your process.
So I mean I guess if you would have to do
change orders.
And the guys don't even know how to use
cycling.
That's a whole training exercise to get
that project managers.
Most of them will do their own change.
I've always done 90% of my own change
orders myself without going back to the
estimated department.
That's right.
Just because I had had the experience and
you know exactly what it's going to take.
Sure,
if I was here at this point now and see
your behind,
I will because I've never used the FBA
portion of tech, but I will learn it.
And then that's why everybody can do it.
That's why I'll do it. That's the way.
All day-to-day usage, super simple.
Very simple,
especially with the lever codes and
everything. I was actually,
but everything's got to be right in the
back.
I was actually hoping there'll be a bunch
of estimated in here this week with me.
We're not doing a bunch of adjustments,
so we're supposed to be.
Where's the best place for me to go to
learn?
I'm just because you got a YouTube video
on yourself.
Everybody else wants to be different,
right?
So and everybody's got to set up a
different place, so no.
But it is really super. I get not set up.
If you figure that out,
let me know because I'm going to be in
the same place.
This guy seems to be a wizard of
everything. I'm just having him say, hey,
I do that. So we got to do this business.
So yeah, working with kind of, well,
say we're past the phase of the the basic,
except for there's a bunch of people are
using it, so they need.
That's right.
And I that's also that's here's,
here's how we use it here instead of
going out.
I personally have to come to you because
there's no three years and I think other
estimators they want to learn,
they should also come to one person who
say what.
That's where we've had lots of issues is
we have new estimators start coming in
and we're just doing long take offs of of
well in the system, so coming in.
Going into this lower portion down here,
which nothing wrong with additional labor
and and adding any of this to it,
but the main you already got it set up on
here the codes,
but I'm going to use the codes.
Those capture so much more than just
adding well capture being put the holes
in it, the clips.
I've seen an estimator do this before.
I just never estimated myself yet in the
system, so that makes sense.
And then those are talking about the
chart that got next to me on my peers. OK,
hey, what's happening? Back that way,
you know.
So and that that's one area that we've
been our estimators on the job there and
one of the reasons that they're like, oh,
we're not getting a hold of these
projects.
And why are your guys's atlas so
different than some of these window
estimators that have come down?
They're coming in and doing the wrong
well takeoffs when more of our senior
estimators are using labor codes and then
using additional labor to fill in a gap
where we need additional fillets.
Or so on and so forth.
How many instructions on this lane is
estimated? Yeah,
they're actually using that just two or
three,
three that are dedicated estimators.
One of those are Karal and Karal,
Isaac and Bach.
So who is Jesse? Oh, so he doesn't.
If he estimates himself,
it's probably directly in heavy bid and
he's probably more estimating the the
field portion of it.
Anything fab that's associated with
Jesse's department.
Usually it's first to Karam.
Karam is our most senior estimator and
where do those kids sit? Are they Gilbert?
They have the 4th floor, second,
third floor. So I'm on the third floor,
but I've never been discussing.
They don't keep coming here all week
because they were gone all last week.
Oh yeah, yeah,
they all said it's like an official set
of offices.
Jesse's in one of those and they said
outside of his office. Well,
they must be on the first floor is that
official office.
So I'm all.
I keep coming back to the I I think, yeah,
yeah, we can do this integration stuff.
That's not a big deal. I swear.
I think our time will be very well spent
correctly. Yeah, I agree with you.
I think you'll get more buying from
everybody else if the hours coming out of
it are realistic.
I I think we had we we'd be better off
doing this.
Now we can make these labor groups do
exactly what what that endling.
We can make this exactly that if you want.
That's that.
That would be a hell of a lot better.
And that's.
Another area where we have confusion is
this layout going to handling,
this layout going to fit.
Most of the time it goes into fit and
then but we also have a fit up category
interview.
So category five and seven are going in
one category and then we got Weld.
And then we have clean material handling
and material handling in here.
So if we simplify these labor groups out
to basically what my PC form has on it,
yeah,
with the exception of I need to add burn
to this, yeah,
then we're going to keep getting a
consistent breakout. So yeah,
are you the master of this topic?
So why not fix it? Yeah.
So I'm I'm open to come up into this deal.
I think my time would be last very soon
there and talk about this this
integration after we fix this.
Then we can set it up,
set it up relatively quickly for it to
just give you the breakdown of the hour.
I used to get it too if you want, right?
We're breaking a whole less than not just
an hour, so let's do it so.
I would kind of suggest here you just do
new ones down at the bottom,
then we'll redirect and come back and
delete these.
So maybe you're talking to Phil,
your layout to speak,
cost about two categories and you need a
number for the label group.
I think it's gonna be,
it's gonna freak out on your dad.
She's gonna be a number.
Also a little return of here that we just
had.
Everything to do with cutting was one
through 9 laser, press break,
water jet one through 9.
Everything to do with fiddle was 10
through 19.
Everything to do with welding so.
We just had things in groups of 10
because somebody wanted.
Sometimes somebody would say, well,
I want welding for this and welding for
that. It would stay within the same.
It would stay within the same family.
That's just the way I'm used to doing it,
not having them all over the place.
And then when you make the routing.
The routing flow through the shop.
They break that activity, by the way.
Um, let's set that to be.
On these in this production it it it has
some effect so specifically like you know
and either you can break it down by that
each year or two.
So cut his saw and burn his plasma table.
Yeah, yeah, I think the most part,
especially the ones with the auto clips
and whatnot, like H.
And I are very common ones that we use.
I think columns that runway estimates.
I can hit a runway estimate then 10
minutes and that's cool and welding base
plate on both ends.
And then we have in there type H quarter
H type H516 type H.
3/8 So as the fillet size increases, um,
you can just plug that lever code and
Jeff, I'm cutting.
I've got a question here cut in.
So you've got plate plasma cutting,
but you've also got plasma shaped cutting.
And then you've got saw cutting.
So saw is cut.
What is plasma cutting in plate or what
is plasma cutting in shapes?
It's still so.
So how do you differentiate the time it
takes to saw cut something versus?
Burn cut the shape so with with that.
I guess we haven't really,
we haven't really broken that out and
that's another area where we've been
trying to fine tune is I'll pull the up
all the reports from Land Tech and see
what their run times are and.
Anything associated with that,
I'll in a separate hours of this is your
ACPC time associated with this for
running channels and Eagles and that's
always factored into our budget.
Because if the ACPC goes down,
which is more common than like like it
could ever be,
everything defaults past the saw.
You still have five,
you still have minutes or even piece.
So you as far as the actual time,
that's Monday regardless of what.
Well, it's,
but this just slowns up all those hours
of calculation background.
But what would you,
what would you see normally in the shop?
If you have different cutting centers,
do they have different codes?
Most of my logics you get federal,
it doesn't matter how it's cut.
But they're not tracking it.
They're not used.
But I mean if I were estimating it and I
had something that was twice as fast as
something else,
my goal would be to feed that work center
because I knew it was twice as fast. Yeah,
and they're not making that decision on
the estimate as far as which 1% it can be.
14 and 22 takes this this amount of time.
One less by the imports was less by a
slot, less by one inward.
Here's the amount of time to work at it.
So OK, I mean,
I can see huge differences in the time of
the job.
Yeah, for sure. Yeah. But you know,
most of the time, the 14th,
20 years will be cut on one machine,
correct. So therefore,
I'm not paying which machine I'm saying
that they don't really have a big mind
here. They have,
they went box out yesterday, they got.
Kind of immediately minded as channels on
the bank and they don't have any of those
beeps.
So they're all kind of normal software.
I guess sometimes they buy out though.
Quite often it would simply buy out
everybody from somebody that doesn't have
to be minded that they'll cut it.
You know, when they get the beam line,
if we get cut,
Chancellor put polls in March,
it's correct. Last year,
actually this year alone,
you would have spent $700,
000 in selling beams and then what's the
chief of beam line that you're.
Like a Python little Python XI have no
idea what what's cheap to say.
Working can well, all these people,
but probably if a bit dev can probably,
but I don't know that I'll get it so.
I hope,
I hope that more long-term then what
where do I think I might be five years
from now if I think I might need the full
system saw a drill.
Yeah,
I'm gonna buy something that can be part
of a system that I can add to you.
You know, like the Portland,
it's a whole system, but I I wanted the,
I wanted the automation of the movement
of the material.
I didn't want to gather the joystick
moving and stuff.
So that meant I wanted a system that
works together.
And so I I we actually got Bicep,
which does that.
So I'm not familiar with it.
I've priced them out. Workman, Bicep,
Python X. Yeah, I've priced them out and.
Hey,
does it matter how many times a week you
want to do? Hey, just, hey,
do this substantive and repurpose like
bid up instead of bid because we we don't
have to be $40, you know what I'm saying?
So get rid of the 22 and make seven up
there 22.
Or something like that, right?
In order to move it down or something.
You follow what I'm saying? Yeah.
That way we don't like to repoint
everything else.
And probably the same with burger as well.
I'm sorry, I wasn't watching that.
I think next week I may go to Gilbert,
just to take what you want to do instead
of start with those guys and see how you
do it. I'm going to do that.
It seems like after today, tomorrow,
the next day we finish this and that's my
next thing. It would be a lot of time.
So I'm going up the place about 5:40 and
nobody's there. I'm the first one in.
I'm the guy walks in and turns the lights
on. OK, and then I'm leaving, you know,
637 o'clock to come here and that's when
people are starting to stroll in.
And there's a couple of people. Well,
he used to give me graphic.
I'll show him at six. OK,
now because it was too early.
Now I wasn't early enough quickly.
Now they move over to the big corporate
office. Eight o'clock's pretty good.
That wasn't one of the working of things.
Yeah, I want to get up there once.
You'll you'll probably want since you're
since coatings will be in here,
then you'll want the clean and the paint.
As well.
Is that material handling of that label
there?
Is that what is the material in order
that it is allowed? No,
that one we can probably just update to
just clean, but that's that's one area of.
On the area of confusion we've had since
we have two areas of material, yeah, so,
but we can adjust that so that it's a
included.
I see you got #10 if they have people
that's the full pending vote.
Do you have one for partial pending vote?
Basic world or what?
Everything other than the full.
I'll have a box anyway.
Everything other than the full can will
is going anywhere. OK, now I can split up.
Which that's a good point too.
We've got there.
I'm wondering why these things are
ordered by code like, you know,
one through 10 together.
That's why I used to. Yeah,
that kind of makes sense to me.
I'm wondering,
would that be easier in the long run for
an estimator to say that, you know,
it cuts down here.
Like layouts up here, like this.
You go click, click, click, click, click,
and maybe. But I see that group. Oh, OK,
so that would.
You don't see that in the estimate.
They're going through selecting these
options.
The main thing we're getting right now is
when they pull up their estimate summary,
all of these descriptions are available.
These different paths are dividing up
across so many different but these ones
here are out-of-the-box or did you pay
them?
These are out-of-the-box and you they
already have this shows but they already
have both of that home plate for assigned
to it.
Yeah this one's this one's given to us by
template. Yeah and then we've.
The only thing we've really done,
I guess we've made any custom ones in
there, but we have made some ones as well.
So you say,
have you made custom assemblies like a
ladder,
but three different kinds of ladders for
physical disclosure.
We do that assembly stuff like that, so.
So that's more of more of what our core
estimators here.
Kron's probably the only one who's using
it.
It's pop didn't get a good understanding
of it last time.
I would like to be one of the guys that
learns how to do that ****, yeah.
That's I've I've done that, you know,
they said on another thing and it's like
it's what Microsoft,
I see how the time is, you know,
I'll count plates on a lot of them.
I can say two plates on a lot of them.
That's a lot of them, right.
Yeah,
one thing I am curious about is sometimes
I have customers supply me with kiss
files and they have well program. Mm-hmm.
Is there a way to enforce and not have
that, you know,
not have a little community,
but we have better control over this.
I've I've been able to give a a global
head of the official down there.
So you can still reply and all that. Yeah,
because I've never seen a e-mail in your
wheelchair, right.
So I don't want the nuts coming in at all.
No, not a chance.
I plug it in and it plugs in at 1000
hours and then the doctor down and and
typically it's less because they'll have
like 3 foot of weld and then there's
eight of them for one.
But like and it'll be it's two and two
cap gets on it.
OK.
Are you are you typically getting it from
the detail or OK,
I will say get it from the detail.
I would get the IC model.
They could use a model here after this,
but they the detailer can turn the web
off on the next to work.
Yeah, no, there's there's no one.
I submit a a developer question like
because I'll ask what we have to have a
global. Yeah,
it's the delete or remove it because then
I'm going through and you're like click
delete.
Why you open?
Click delete because you can't even go
into the highway all and delete one of
the. You have to go 111.
It is terribly diagonal.
So now we can we can go in and point
everything to the new box and got or then
we'll come back and delete the rest of
the.
And then we'll have it much more
simplified.
So you go to operations to do that labor
operations.
So estimating labor maintenance,
labor operations.
There'll be a few other places,
so this is where we just want to get it
going to the right area.
So this is a little bit tedious, but.
So it might be easiest to say like sort
by labor group and then just repoint the
groupings.
Check wherever that be going.
Do you need that separated out?
Come to think of it.
I know that it was said we don't.
That time's not even,
but it is an estimate.
I think there's logging at the end of.
Yeah, but we need it split up.
No,
I think we could just let's because yeah,
right now anything quality control wise
it is.
There's a separate empty bucket that's
added to every project. Yeah,
and PC just adds their time to it.
So you're not checking everyone,
each and everyone is saying individually
and saying, Oh yeah,
we're going to check this one up,
check that one up. Well,
and that's the other part because I mean
the fitters should be doing their own
checks before.
So most of this check on gets wanted to
go around that time of.
Check done by the actual.
I don't know if you were a shop that was
doing nothing,
but there's thousands of operations you'd
have, but what I see out here, it's more.
It's like I'll check a bean, all bean.
Sometimes they can only spot.
They can only spot check.
They can get 10 meetings.
Let me go check on my.
I'll try to look here. Well,
I walked a couple of them a couple days
ago, but I could see marks on. Yeah,
on the meetings.
Like somebody had put a clip on and then
grabbed it off properly or whatever.
So.
I can sign that to you by what if if you
just say like to get through it then.
Yeah, a little different risk to do it.
So let me get you together with my son.
My son does the he works at Shop Money's
work net.
He he does all of the programming
production controls for his son that
makes it PC.
So he's all of his constantly like.
Yes,
he he's actually living with one of their
guys,
so I can get him with my guy Chris to try
and get him in an integration.
That would be super sweet. Yeah, my son,
I'll just screw you about ACP.
This year, every time they do an update,
they end up destroying all of the
settings that I have made to put into my
stuff because they don't offer any sort
of guideline.
I'm looking through the paper from manual,
putting in the feed rates,
putting it in top quality, yeah, and.
Which is fine. I know how to do it.
It's definitely trained me how to do it
quite well. Yeah, but if I'm not, um,
that machine's not gonna run. Yeah,
if I'm on vacation, they give me a call.
I'm trying to run 316 stainless right now,
so.
I'm doing a I'm doing a website for
support and I'm going to have as far as
that I'm going to have where clients can
get together and talk about that stuff at
ACPC.
Who should donate to the PC?
Here's what I'm struggling with.
I want to add on there as well. Yeah,
having the the chat boards for for the
fabrication.
Like monthly webinars and stuff too,
where I I will try to get some of these
guys come on and say, hey,
let's listen to your clients and see what
they say, what they want, you know?
Oh yeah.
I'd definitely be interested in that
'cause I'm always, I mean,
once you're in the industry,
you're in the industry. Yeah.
So no matter where you are, it's a it's a.
So.
He said what do you style that we want to
do that this one we will put into our.
So I'd say we put on the check into our
fifth category, OK.
Because they made it clear.
So you're so it really is the quality guy
is not responsible anymore.
It's just the bidder that's responsible.
So the bidder is checking the fitment
prior to the going to load it and then
the GC comes over.
As on that was on inspection report.
So QC is still doing a check,
but QC dollars are tracked on a
completely separate code on every single
project. OK,
so QC knows where to put their time on
the project. Yeah, OK, yeah.
So when we were.
When we were looking at this previous
project schedule,
which we can see that everyone should
have in here.
It's the same code for every single
project,
but I'm just amazed without the
estimators to see her integration with
this two topics would be just a problem.
So yeah, where's staff?
I actually expected the quality control
is always zero.
011400 so OK.
And I cannot know the other thing.
He was still up. People are unsustained,
wasn't telling me.
I've done this port to copy it up there,
copy the and then you just paste it there
rather than had to be able to click
through and find it.
What do you think they're going to call
on? I'm not even. I don't know.
If you you can also look it from label
group on the left and it'll stay on check
over there so you don't have to scroll up
in.
I'm gonna just drop that.
It's like I I got some second scroll a
little bit.
Looking very fast today,
the program's not shutting down.
That's good.
I told you I was trying to be the same
house. Yeah,
that's where you were with smiles.
Thank you.
I take priority in my ability to.
How many reprogramming they've ever given
me? It's been, let me see,
just something I'm going to get at it and
that's what I can do with it.
Land tech is one that I have not been
able to. I know it very well.
But I hate that program. Yeah,
I've almost said that's very, I would say.
So I'm gonna use the restaurant real
quick 'cause I'm drinking water like a
fish today.
One thing I have a certain level I have
migrated.
So have you heard or are you aware that
the goal is to have all estimated for all
facilities be in Phoenix?
Have you heard that?
That's that's the goal,
the way I understand it, so.
Well.
I don't can't really tell them if some
people are,
but it looks like there's 7 or 12.
Some might be panel shops and there might
be a when you say Phoenix,
you mean between here and Gilbert?
Sure. Gilbert. OK, Morgan Gilbert.
Gilbert,
that is run by a guy in Denver as they
roll up to Denver.
Seems like the lead estimators in there.
This is what I've heard.
I haven't been verified any issue.
The facility in Great Falls is empty.
There's like 25,
000 square feet overhead cranes,
but there's hardly any work.
The selling loading load field is oil
field skids.
They're doing a lot of this.
I'm researching hard,
trying to read people that wrote trip
reports, you know.
Anyway, place in Casper.
I have no idea what they did do that.
Yeah,
I've been trying to pull data from these.
Yeah,
trying to pull data from these facilities.
Like who's been there? What do they got?
What are they good at?
One of the jobs we want me to do is where
you know different parts of the projects.
I go, then I need to scale the jobs.
I know I need to like say something that
I can see that so I can see their.
I now know what we can do here.
I'm actually a little surprised. No,
it's like this place.
They have a little shopping.
It's like it's metals,
20 guys in it and and even besides pills,
they got a little tiny.
Council chair,
10 foot press break and they do a few
stairs here and there and they got this
little invitation game line to do their
stair springers on and they're not really
set up to do structural like calls,
but that's why he's he's saying.
Yeah,
we'd be saying out loud and buy a house.
OK, well,
doesn't the company own a facility that
does do those?
I think they're trying to get to the
point to where they're doing,
want to do everything in house and we're
good to the Jordan has done it in house.
Then they need to say one of these shops
I've been with these states. They do it.
OK,
so I think you and I have been told the
same very similar thing.
They just want me to determine where's
the best and and if they can't find a
facility that we own that doesn't the
best, they want me to give them ideas on.
Where we can buy it out? OK,
I think we have a very similar mission,
but coming.
Yours is coming from John Snow. Yeah,
mine's coming from Jeffrey,
but I think the. So he, Jeffrey,
would you? He's the same thing as John.
Oh, really?
Yeah. Is he mobile? He works from home.
He's here two days a week.
He's here on Monday. Oh, yeah,
he's here on Monday.
He'll be here on Thursday.
I'll introduce you to him.
So he's my old boss from.
We worked together for a decade.
That fab shop we worked on and that fab
shop was crumbling because most of us
have left for whatever reason.
Some is rebuilding.
They've taken seven of our guys over
there and they're putting up 65,
000 square feet.
New facility, one bay, one bay tanks,
one bay spatial.
These guys want to hug both,
first the show.
They should go to this area.
They have the most organized.
What is the steel pad?
Have you been to steel pad?
I have not been steel pad,
but I've heard of it. But yeah,
so you know this facility was you guys
were next to AF Steel.
I did not know that right.
You guys were right next door. Yeah,
right there,
another building and then they're going
to.
Here ASDL has expanded. Yes, they have.
They've already,
but they do have all the right equipment
set up already.
They're only the problem is the the
people that upper level management aren't
the people.
Yeah, I had the three big,
the big three above me that followed the
three drag and then me and then everybody
else is under me like, OK,
and then I left the like most people in
those conditions,
they only lasted a year or two.
When I ever been there, they said.
Yeah, yeah, that's better. At least, yeah.
'Cause they got nothing. OK,
it's they just jump up and on costs where
everybody will label their mental.
I used to get really bad because I didn't
do that. Well, that's not my example.
Two good work done. Three people.
But as far as the shop,
the way it's set up is really good. Yes,
they got really good equipment.
Like working shop, Yeah.
They have to be one competitions between
each other. Hundreds of beams,
hundreds of columns means like 34500
beams a day. Yeah,
that's actually started to turn steel
fast facility and.
I was literally moving the whole time
over there. They had PDL theme lines, so,
yeah, yeah, so.
So I've always been very heavy.
So are you and just got the brand.
They've got 3 beam lines and then a cobra.
So they they were telling me their best
week.
They're pumping out 800 tons and the
structure will we have to do that
equipment,
but the advocating house is they sell.
Think of things about material and it's
not a system.
Let's say you got to have for every
machine you got to operate and you don't
have to do that.
They have to move the material themselves.
That's a problem.
I wonder how many tons of Valley consumes
per month. Yeah, well, the question is,
do all these shops stay busy?
I have your Phoenix is well,
I think Phoenix Phoenix is expanding
because the semi con has been talking a
bunch of money here. Yeah,
I think it's that's a temporary thing.
Just one data on little bit.
2.
Where is that? I was in Arkansas.
I.
OK.
Well, I mean,
I only changed over the load,
so I mean I keep waiting to.
It won't work since we're already in my.
So.
OK.
So they'd like to figure out where to
build a facility that can do hiring for
that.
I'd be happy about that too.
Right around the corner of your house.
Is that what you're trying to say? Yeah,
San Tan Valley too. Oh, that's a joke.
I don't know.
I got a pretty good backyard.
And it's just having it spread out like
certainly just creates other issues.
I have estimators here.
It's in in probably, right? Yes,
it's in the year or not.
It should be worse.
You probably can leave this. Yeah, yeah.
They don't seem to want to spend a lot of
money, so.
Which can't like the places around in
this area because of panel shot.
If you look at people's signature files,
you'll see they're the three places that
they have 3 audiences.
Open, stand on.
That weld around one leg laying. Yeah,
that will be better,
but all they told you they really want
the less, less.
They shouldn't use those some other hours
going to be.
Yeah, but it doesn't use it.
So unless you put time in the labor
standards from these other fields,
it's it's gonna be easy to put it
wherever you want to be really.
Some guys have left, you know,
the rest of my sales team,
but I had a bunch of sales wise and some
operations guys.
They've already appended 50 million in
work.
They don't have facility either.
Data center skids was 40 million and a
bunch of barges was 10 million.
But this was work we used to do at K-wood,
Steelwood, uh, the skills are integration.
So steel is,
steel is the most of these jobs,
obviously the steel.
What you're really selling are pumps and
motors and valves and instruments.
That's what I wanted. It's still like 15%.
That's all I know. Thank you.
You know, the other side of it. You know,
like all the pumps and all that stuff.
No electrical, you know,
if it's certified,
you know it's just basic stuff. Yeah, but.
So if you're burned on the way above the
on the well, your holes, the cut,
excuse me, the punch and drill.
They we need to go look at that.
So go up to maintenance,
estimating later maintenance and punch.
And go to the drop down at the top,
the touch pipe maintenance.
And then where do you want holes for the
cycle will be basically cut for the
processing basically.
So they just change it.
Do they even have punches here to punch
holes? I didn't see any much.
I need to change that terminology.
They got cut.
Drill. It might be a thermal process.
It's they they need to say whole method
number one,
whole method number two and then it lets
you pick what you want. So yeah,
their terminology is all in here or
should they need to change it.
I guess people so screwed up on that all
of them that are startling to be like,
I don't punch anything.
Why are we using the punch?
We need to use the drill. I'm like.
It's not saying you have to literally
function, so they go to drill as well,
good maintenance,
estimating labor maintenance and drill.
Same deal drop down at the top and drill
type maintenance and change those.
What are you going to change it to?
It's all hard. Yeah.
So punching in is not hard. OK.
Yes.
Yeah.
This is ****. Maybe on here.
I think we've got it right.
Yeah,
they don't show up for their training.
It was yesterday. Save it to me. Oh yeah,
afternoon is first meeting mornings for
production and.
So, so then you go also to maintenance,
we're good. We're yeah, labor groups,
you're back to labor groups,
maintenance estimating labor,
maintenance labor groups.
Go to the drop down at the top.
Labor group maintenance and miscellaneous
labor groups.
So here's other places where that is
going to be said clean goes with clean.
Sure that it works.
Oops, probably not being used, but.
You came with splice times with the labor.
I think it'd be 12 if it's splicing the
pieces together. Well,
it's something to prep for the field for
both the spice. So they'll prep the shop.
They'll make sure the beef might not just
spice.
They'll have bolts a lot of times on the
end.
Good maintenance estimating.
I'll show you where it is.
So you can see it really better.
We're going to come right back to labor
maintenance, splice, you know,
column splices so you can on a.
Labor code you can say use this splice.
It's not used by default and it's just a
lot of hours.
So most people don't use this. Yes,
they don't put any material themselves
and they don't put labor to it with labor
codes. Most people don't use this, but.
There it is. If it's there, why not?
It just doesn't give you a breakdown of
what it is. Is that kind of is that holes?
Is that is that actually putting it on
there or what is it's like it just
doesn't give you a breakdown.
So let's be cleaned up not using it so.
Hey.
I I think we put it under clean.
We do not. I think we had a clean man,
right?
So the manual labor time that gives that
hours per fee field.
So which I really kind of hate that field
because it gives people too much leeway,
but it's used too much,
but what do you want me to do with that?
I say I'm keeping it in other just
because I know when somebody's and then
there's not way,
then it at least ask the question. OK,
cool.
I think we should have everything ordered
in the right.
So you can probably get back and delete
the other ones now and.
Well, I'm all, well,
we know what this is today.
Always thinking again.
I don't think about 9:45 in the mornings
when I start thinking about my dear real
hearts.
And it's so much salad to return.
Perfect.
Yeah.
.
If it's used somewhere,
I think because this is for.
So that's been up for her T Morris.
It.
Labor time.
We're trying to get the other facilities
the same thing.
Somebody's kind of gone through with the
people.
I hear the local facility can be quite
busy doing pipe skills.
I think there is. Yeah,
that was going to Camber.
Do you want that in Camber?
Press button where you want to be?
It's good.
Cameras probably has to keep there.
Honestly,
the camera time just shy of the pencil
anybody never use it.
So because it looks like it's a flat time
right now and actually we adjusted a
little bit better because.
Used to be dynamically found and most of
our camera people are taking more than
three hours.
So if it's if it's anything outside of my
machine,
that's when it would be over because then
he can bring it, yeah.
So the two hours is probably something
Mark and then two hours you all set. OK,
cool, because I would say that.
2025 right in the three years,
14 new jobs and you got on camera machine
out there collecting dust and stuff.
It's a pain. What about man flight?
Press break. Um.
That one probably.
Is that just consider processing in
general in in in terminology? Yeah,
this one would probably be more under fit
just because they're forming would be fit
so.
No, I don't need. I don't know.
We should not be in.
It's on a certain entity, yeah.
Bending is definitely to me, you know,
and and sometimes I can argue whether
bending and rolling is the same thing,
but no, no, they're totally different.
The theory is a little bit similar, but.
like different as well. I really like
Well,
we've also put we've put restorate time
in handling too,
really is possibly handling to play after
it's been processed and a lot of times I
mean depending upon the project.
You're like,
that's the extension you'll if you want
it to restructure or welded together,
I think it's what you got there. Yeah,
I think it's it's no animal. No, I mean,
we can keep it that way.
It's an estimate extra anyways. And yeah,
that's just.
It's gonna be another area where we
release it per handling cut fit well,
right? So.
You still have visibility to the time,
regardless of type and label. Yeah,
you still have visibility if you want to,
yeah. But yeah, if you run a report later,
this is cut to show up.
It's not. No,
that was still up in a separate category,
but it'll still be in the total amount of
hours.
And then from there that's the
fabrication shop project managers is
fresh enough.
I'm going to direct my guys to put this
towards handling because we took the time
for this and put it.
Here or this is going to go to fit for
tracking purposes and then you'll be with
the operator and you have four hours to
break to play.
This is your and and then in time
tracking you'll add nulls.
Break press operation,
handling and then we can see that like
you got to cut. Well,
if you have a category,
so handling that that will allow the bird.
I got there only one business.
So you can take, OK,
that's where you put your banding things
like there's others that you don't pay in
the postal buckets, right? Yeah,
that's what that's what I'll say.
I think I'm pretty much using kind of
like all processes.
Alls and calves and OK, OK.
Yeah, I hated that.
We used to have a category fab and
everybody put everything. Oh yeah,
I'm sure they did. Yeah. And it was, yeah.
Then we went to fit up and well,
that became confusing.
But.
Yeah,
it depends on how you're going to shop.
If you want to know,
our fitters could weld and our welders
could, yeah, so.
As we moved away from that.
Right.
I have that move that was only called
layout man, right?
I guess I'm freaked out. You want that?
This one I don't understand.
I don't know who would stand on that in
this.
Yeah, dollars has a priority.
That's not something that we're going to
track in this an extra. It's. I mean,
you just you send your assembly on the go.
I don't have a free job on here at all.
Right, that's that's just a weird no.
I don't think that's it's only moods.
It doesn't even look out for the.
What does it do? OK,
it is accounting for a gallon housing
cost.
And then when this and then I would
assume that you would call these paving
the system on it and this would get you
down in private.
So that makes sense to me and then
they're just.
So move, we would switch to, Bob,
would you guys run a system that has
galvanizing and paint over it?
I'll be a lot of green environments.
Marine environments. Yeah, on it.
Heavy corrosion areas.
They're even just down there at the top.
We made light poles,
the same light poles we said at 10 feet.
Sometimes the same coastal city.
And so they want to galvanize it,
that panel.
Yeah.
'Cause they still want to look pretty,
they don't want that to be optimized,
yeah.
I think everything else is good to be
more other.
Should be.
I didn't get to taking the time to do
this is actually if you're going to move
to more estimating in here,
this actually is going to be very helpful.
So what's going to happen when we change
all these categories and we try to run
all estimates through here that don't
have that do or don't have these
categories? It's reporting all this.
So if we went to all this and.
Change.
So it's not going to affect the labor,
but it'll affect the buckets that most
into that. We're not.
It's been done in anyways.
We're not changing labor. I'm curious.
We're not changing labor at all.
We're just redirecting more of that labor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I still would be there.
I mean,
I hear Karam does like 4 estimates a week.
Yeah,
it's about the number of the other guy.
Hey Cortana,
the otherwise it's you need that.
There's some others there.
I think 15 is probably what the average
per piece is going to, yeah.
And then the other one's probably rural.
Yeah, yeah, I'm not sure.
It may be that the labor operation will
point to one and then that's the only
problem with only using the label.
We're not seeing the 15 or 16, so.
This one's fine. This one's fine.
And when you kind of paint that's that's
what we want. What I said,
you're more bad that coping was under
burger. Do you want that under burger?
Yeah, I would. I would say so. OK,
if we're to open the house,
we're using the mouse C7 torch and we're
I I was just,
I was just kind of thinking you,
you got everything in the car is only
plate and that was going to be my plan.
So I just want to make sure I see it.
OK.
Do you hear any ranges at all?
Because that's going to get money real
quick. Yes,
we're using obviously some of the torch,
but that's truck time going to the detail
department and they're going to cut the
beam the land.
Yeah, all that's gonna be under there, so.
Uh, let's see which one is.
It's using good fabricated information
first.
A good operating.
Yep,
I've been in operations at the bottom and
then the coats there.
So it's usually a manual apartment rate.
Wonder if that's what you're in the
meeting changing.
Go to let's see what go to labor codes
and see what your like labor codes are
using.
I don't want to bet you it's using the
manual.
Labor maintenance, labor.
I was forget that.
So we had to sneak it into this every tab.
Oh yeah.
They're gonna have a plate.
And then just go to the Formalas tab.
And hover over that and it'll show you
over the formula if thickness is.
Burn manual.
So the coats and the and the plate
machine are usually the exact same rate,
the exact same function.
So if we report it,
we report the whole thing.
So I guess the question is do you want to
use a different burn burn rate?
For the coats and the.
I would definitely say so considering the
operation is gonna run a significantly
faster burn rate than, yeah,
an operator out there with a hand torch.
So yeah.
Yeah, that's pretty much it.
So let's get a look at the break.
It says 9 lane rate, so.
So.
Problem we're going to have.
So that's what the plate machine is using.
Well,
that's what every plate machine is using
right now,
which what is 76 eights of the bust
out-of-the-box.
So I probably have 69 for the result,
but I don't know something in between
there, but yeah, that's one thing we can.
Um, in downloading this for sure I.
You know,
I don't know what you want to do here.
Do you want to?
We could either change the plate to a
different burn type,
or we can change the coding to a
different burn type.
Anything other than this,
the semi and automatic is going to be
faster than this.
Um, go to semi automatic.
I'm gonna bet that's probably more
realistic for your blade machine.
Yeah, you get an automatic. It's like,
it's like super fast.
That might be actual everything's back.
Yeah, it might be,
but it doesn't account for all the
movement of the hip before before the arc
starts, right. So.
The others would be.
But.
2.
So it's oxy and.
You just have to find the right to share
it's in the before and then we'll be able
to adjust.
OK,
so it's 10 gauge and then it should just
be 15 inch, 40 inch of a minute.
Is this the machine that's up to the
order? Yeah, yeah,
quarter inch through 3/8 it'd be 110.
9675 inches per minute.
I don't believe they're that fast because
I don't think it's accounting for
everything like you mentioned.
It's not you know the the machine may
actually burn that fast, but.
It's not trying to move the head over
here, over here, over here. Well,
I think there's, I mean,
whatever the programs that calculate this
take a lot of this into account,
right when you pick these.
Cut speeds like when you make a turn,
depending on how you program,
it slows the speed down the arc depending
on your cut quality.
Pierce times or depending on what you're
piercing, you know those drive a lot of.
A lot of this.
But the guy who uses for consumables
matters a lot and 110 inches per bed for
quarter inch right here,
that's 550 feet per hour and I'll find
most people are.
Running it,
they're going to speed by half of what?
So I mean look and see what the what the
other speeds were for quarter inch.
What's the semi? So automatic is 550,
what's the semi?
What do you guys want?
What do you do with base plates on there?
Base plates, base plates, cap plates,
stiffeners, gusset plates.
So it's a small one.
It's anything over 2 inch.
We got it next time. So you guys got this,
your boss being. It's a bottom now.
They got nothing. It's they were too good.
We're we're limited to 96 by 240 on that
table and you'll see those plates for all
40 foot and I could purchase them with a
bell burn to the whole.
So and it was a pain trying to find an
inch and 1/4.
Late at 40 foot,
you have it as long back at the only foot
place for me.
Don't press that smooth plug and steal
that in Phoenix I would have always come
the clock in between.
They don't respond to the messages.
They can have a check semi on that for a
minute and see if it has to put pages for
that. Well,
that's that's probably still slower than
what you're really running,
but right now maybe is what it's using,
but it's like super slow.
So that would be at least semi on that's
what you're saying.
Yeah, and we could change all this too,
right? You know,
we could get out there and change all
these rates to make it match.
I don't if you if you're not really sure
where you want it to be better, then you.
I don't know if you want to like use to
say let me get what half inch would be,
what quarter inch would be,
what one inch would be.
I don't know if that's what you want to
do or yeah, well, I mean,
at least we can get it. We can.
Yeah, we did. Yeah.
Do you have a What do you want to change
it over to Sara?
I'm not sure with Sara or probably.
I think Sara is at least closer than
manual. Manual is being really slow. Yeah,
the automatic is.
That's the problem.
That's why the feed rates. Yeah,
it gets at least a lot closer to where
we're doing that.
And we're only manual as the the the
coding stuff, right. OK,
so while we're in the here, the.
Yeah, get back in there.
We'll we'll repoint the manual to.
Yeah, the burn.
Two more down. Keep on going down. Burn.
Keep going up right there.
So you got manually code for everything
torch, yeah.
Unless I send it out, yeah,
so there's a drop down at the top.
Burn lanes, burn tight lanes.
We'll take the manual.
We'll point that to where we want to go
in for your hand cokes. That would be.
We can even rename.
I like renaming these sometimes so that I
will then like you get some manual dash
papers or something and even the
remediation.
I might change it as well because that's
what shows in all the formulas and so
that that way you know what these rates
are.
Right, we'll have a look at it and see.
Or do you change the rating? That's oh,
that's the manual. Got it? Yeah.
All right. So what we'll have to do now,
then we got to get back into the labor
case. We got to be right in trouble.
We're going to do the labor case,
change that formula for the cutting.
So it's supporting at the semi rate
rather than the manual rate.
And so unchecked.
See if the one below it just put them
around the read and we'll see if it's the
same.
Which won't be hard to do.
You know.
This looks like.
Yes, we'll have to create one for Barnes,
which is no big deal.
You can go to the drop down at the top.
Maintenance and then we'll find that
formula. We'll hit new.
We wanted to find it and just change it.
So you have new at the bottom and then in
the edit operation formula is what you
want up there.
And just see what's been Burn Man.
Get rid of that.
You need to get rid of Burn Man COVID.
Get rid of that whole thing there.
Yeah. And then hit operations down here,
the drop down,
there you go and get your tables and add
operation. There we go.
So now we got there. So hit OK.
While we're in here,
will that accept that if you have else
and if? Yeah, yeah,
because it's it's looking at if we can
share it,
share it based off capacity and if that
is all zero.
So it's going to bypass all that and get
straight to the burn function. So OK,
so it doesn't expect an argument.
We put it after else. Well,
we we put it after else after the burn
was in the.
So it's not it's not some of the other
statements don't have an else and if at
the end of them.
My tip it it it's it's going to be good.
OK.
Look, while we're here, see the length.
This is what I was telling you about that
was wrong out-of-the-box. In my opinion,
the the the length formula basically says
width plus length.
That's how much burnout would be.
It's really.
With times through late times through,
yeah,
you might need your chain cutting or
something.
It's not necessarily going to be that
same thing,
but what I typically do is I'll just put
a parenthesis around that and then just
three times 2.
So the default is always cut the
perimeter.
Do do it at the end of the end of the end.
Yeah, now we've done.
Say that again then.
Basically the default is cut approved.
Yeah, yeah, if you do better,
the common cuts is fine,
but the default is cut approved, right?
Yeah, I would do that.
And like I say out-of-the-box,
I'll bet you 90% of this.
In the United States that are using this
and that included that they're only
getting with the line, yeah,
especially with what we're doing for,
we're cutting base plates and all these
small parts when we are going around the
perimeter. Does that make sense?
You might want to go ahead and change.
There's another two formulas here with
times length that we're going to do the
times too as well.
Yes, yes,
because if you go back and use those.
I'm just afraid that you'll get the same
thing. Good point.
The weary traveler will step into our
traffic again. Yeah, it should be good.
Since April, yeah,
it should be that that one right there at
least. Um, you got that one.
I guess you got both of those when we
added the one at the bottom, right?
You might if you if you want to take that
bottom one.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
You might want to move that up.
That might be you won't have to struggle
when you get a fix all this.
You're going to have to change every
formula.
Cool.
So now we have all the blank rules just
need to be changed to that or to play the
labor case. Excuse me, right? Terminology.
Uh, you were changing.
You had hit me on the labor day.
We don't need to.
Just click on what you want to realize.
I'm sorry, I've looked back to driver.
Should be.
Yeah, that's quite true. That's cool.
I think it'll be more accurate, yeah.
And I would imagine that's still going to
be slow, but.
We'll have.
We'll have worst case scenario covered.
Yeah, actually, I don't know.
We may not be changing now because it was
using with the link at the very slow.
Oh yeah, there you go.
So I don't want to sit on that with.
With them to be late, so I don't know.
I'll be accurate. Yeah,
I guess or more accurate.
OK.
Oh, did they have any information?
This is why I love this,
so customers can't hold everything from
long believe that it's so.
I mean,
they got people on the system and don't
use it, yeah.
I know you're pulling this out into
another spreadsheet right now,
but if we are affecting every estimate in
the system,
so if you want all the estimates that are
that have been in there to be what they
were,
we we would need the global edit on
better label.
Labor archive, yeah,
you could put labor archive one day or
something, so it's through it.
That's still a lot,
but it better change the hours,
but you may not get back and look at it
after the fact.
No, I think, I think,
I don't think this has been as fast as.
So.
So that's good.
You need to see the lighting screens at
all. You want them in a different order.
Going in order of the rose to Michelle.
So the burn makes the cut.
Yeah.
Attention to my son,
so the one you already have that is.
There's a reading about ACP's and you
said plus for the eight group.
I like the trend. What did you talk to?
Yeah,
but you can get the database is all you
think. I don't have a chance to test it.
I won't forget any of this.
I'll try messing with that for.
I'll see if we can get into it. Chris,
choose. Yeah. No, we shouldn't get.
I'm gonna be awesome fried chicken. Yeah,
you can share the fried chicken.
That's what we heard for sitting in this
safety training room all day here.
This last day of the audit, Yeah,
last day of the audit at the facility.
The last day of it was field. Yeah,
so that's the last three day in the field
as well.
That was like just one of the
environmental audit.
There's an environment that's separate,
separate entity.
That's why I think Chris is not able to.
We have one.
Was.
If he saw the auditor was digging into
something we were weak on,
he would take that guy down a rabbit
trail a bit of stuff that just to
redirect.
And we have to do AIC, ASME and ISM.
All those audits.
I'm not happy with those guys is I get an
honored one year that tell me to do
something. Next year,
the next honor will be like,
why are you doing that?
It's like because your guy don't even do
it.
That there is very they were very
inconsistent.
Why is there two other statements?
We could probably change one of one of
them is coming from one field,
one is coming from a different field.
They could, they could probably change,
but yeah, once other.
No, I think it will.
It should be once pointing to that hours
per piece field and then I think the
other one is coming from all of the labor
operations that say other.
We'll get it solid and if you want to do,
we just have to change the name of one so
we know which label is which.
It's all right.
The biggest thing I'm having.
You master this sense of grips,
our beliefs.
How can you tell me I can't have 11?
Tell me where there's an 11 or two.
I think the actual prescription was
obviously.
And yeah.
Yep, that's why I can do both.
It's just love and have.
Good.
She got me very appointed.
Oh.
So it might be.
Or instead of 30 candidates.
Huge.
It definitely did increase my leg.
Increase what?
Definitely did increase my leg.
Oh, yeah. What was it? Yeah,
it was 148 where we also have it in K to
the.
So which was?
close.
close to 100 hours.
On me.
So I'm just going to SP3 and see.
Yes.
Thank you.
OK.
Purple feels super expensive.
Ridiculous.
Nice part is is we just figured out that
since we're not pushing our projects over
and trying to sync all of our budgets
with it,
we can now be in the minimum planning.
And still do small estimates and
proposals and changes and stuff inside of
this.
Some of the people are using this system,
but for a while there was based on
roading,
so we were almost speaking like serious
cash.
These would force proposals and stuff.
Yeah, we could tackle and get rid of,
yeah. So going on the end, so that.
Yeah,
to my understanding that they're phasing
this out.
So if you don't have access to it,
the training on the system. Oh,
so don't you?
So what is the new system basically?
The new system is to my understanding how
you build.
That's going to be whether they're doing
bids in and then tentative proposals
until 100% of estimating is moved into
Tekla and we can generate proposals from
everything from here.
So it sounds like it's going to be Tekla
heavy bid heavy work.
Yeah,
they do not want us to be continuing on
this,
but I mean up until like last week this
Austin Revolution Industrial.
So they clearly have made changes in here
and now this is.
This is actually recycling and I think if
I generate a proposal now,
it shows a long road in here towards just
last week when I generated the proposal
for a bid that I submitted, it was it was.
Yeah, so I need to start now 6:09.
What's the difference?
What's what the definitions are?
What's the?
I guess it's kind of a similar similar
software.
It just has a different structure to it.
Um,
this was set up with everything being
overhead, structured,
built into your numbers.
Heavy bit is very.
Overhead has its own items and broken out
a lot early.
Each labor item is track to its own
extent,
so a lot more visibility for everything
across the board,
whereas this has a lot of unknowns left
into this is what we know covers all of
this.
Heavy bins. Yeah, yeah, heavy bird.
Heavy bin is usually they have the
ability to do their field takeoffs and do
all that kind of stuff in there.
Or you can do something similar in there,
but heavy bin has a lot more.
All more to it, but it's it's not,
it's not, it's not,
so they're going to expect to do for
detection.
Yeah, this report. Yeah. Yeah.
So I I need to request. Yes. So yeah,
this one we went in 150 in hours.
Might as well. I mean,
I assume we can get a heavy bid.
So 150 there is side of divider.
I believe it's this fast execution.
So I don't know one of the estimating
side of the Saints gets that runs by
there are two separated three.
So and what I plugged in for pain was 70
hours, so pain's pretty close.
In fact it is slightly up there.
Well, in this people in mind with pain,
we.
Uh.
We put it in the rate without considering
the efficiency.
So if you put that at 100,
you probably have.
Your 70 ish, so you know,
kind of gotta figure out what to do there.
Secrets.
So efficiency,
what docs to hours or docs to dollars?
So if it's at the hours, OK,
so if it's at 90% efficiency,
what it does,
it takes the calculation of the hours,
divides it by .9 to bump it up so.
You.
That's what this should be part of.
So to me the the the next biggest concern
would be.
Yeah,
I know the total hours will be in use
from here typically, if I'm not mistaken,
but it's totally being redistributed.
So do we need to do that work,
that distribution of hours in here or do
they just need to stop doing what they're
doing and just say this is what we're
using?
Well,
this this is what they need to be using
here for for what they're doing, I guess.
And a lot of times if I'm not completely
going up with something,
all we would run if if they didn't use
that one to do it,
all they would run their estimate.
So that there's something in here that
has this breakout. Yeah, until this point,
it was all some in general category.
So now this has worked out the way that
my form is requesting the information to
be given to me and I think it's going to
be a.
Beneficial.
I think I heard yesterday or day before.
Well, it's always going to be very high.
Yeah, the ratio here,
I think that's what I've heard is the
ratio between fit up and well is never
right coming out of Tekla and you guys
are making adjustments to take.
Well time and move it to fit out time.
Yeah,
I think I was here something like that.
Yeah, that sound right.
That does sound right,
especially in this in this situation.
And now you see this work program here.
This is that heavy vin. Yeah,
he's saying heavy heavy work is a field.
I think it's their field.
Instructions. Well,
are they using it here?
You say you're at this facility,
so you know, like I don't know either.
Probably not. There's you. Yeah,
that's me. And they bid for estimating.
There's one of the field guys running a
software.
That's I'm not sure what they're doing to
be honest. I heard it at work,
but I don't know who I heard it from.
We've I mean it changes,
changes so much so.
Oh.
Yeah, so this.
This is the incident intact one.
This is what's about to be released
before.
We have 150 hours will be estimated for
this originally and this was the manual
breakout that was put together on this
and then.
This is why we have.
My question then would be.
What's right? That's a big question.
If we can adjust this or whatever what it
is,
just what what is what what is right or
they are they.
And I'm I'm assuming Mark's doing this
person. Yeah. So it is that.
It was also 100% efficiency and we can
see well is closed. It is not.
Burn is closed. That was not. That's.
So 27 + 7 + 30 plus. Yeah,
that's like 100%. That's like 100.
We're gonna get 75. They're running at 75.
And even so go back in here and take this.
75% see where,
see where much the differences are yet.
I can see the reason you want to estimate
at 100% because you're going to want to
know and then you make the adjustments,
you run over and look at 75%.
We want to get that number closer,
but estimating at the lower rate.
That just adds another tweaking factor in.
So we'll see.
But it will also say nobody runs it 100%
on time.
And the problem is this one day we're
building a canopy,
one day we're building 6 line stainless
for all.
One day we're building aluminum rail,
the next day we're throwing boxes in the
mix and then the next day we have
structural columns in it. Yeah,
so and because of that,
we're not efficient.
You're switching up all the work and you
don't have a really good system going on
one thing and you're about to. Thank you.
I think 75% scandal way out of there.
Looks like he's.
All this discussion,
so it looks like he's using the basic
breakdowns of burging that before.
But he's redistributing fit up and well,
redistributing,
handling it cut because the fit up well
is essential on both the tunnels and both
are essentially the same hours.
So it looks like he's redistributing it,
redistributing it. Excuse me.
Yeah, I'm going to bet.
Let's see what the difference in the will
is right here. So we've got 61.
95 total hours.
The bottom one is 100 and yes,
it's like it's like the top.
He's about 120 because you got 6135,
that's 100, 119.
We got a 40% difference in weld.
Go back into power fab real quick,
go up to maintenance,
estimating even labor maintenance and
weld.
Was 150 the actual 150?
Remember when we saw the job before it
was 119 and there was that overage?
That's why I remember seeing that you're
got the fillet wheel manual quarter inch.
Yeah, 6 foot three.
So I consider this right.
That's why I was like, OK, 40% difference.
I consider this rate about 40% slower.
I usually will see the rate per hour
around 11:50 feet.
So the 10 feet is around 40.
40% difference. So yeah,
I'm wondering if we change,
if we sped this up,
now you're waiting times will come down,
then again we we redistribute.
Those hours and you guys,
you got all those,
you just change the quarter inch ones and
make the other ones go, yeah,
bring that out-of-the-box.
The the if you put a a filled well on
some out-of-the-box,
you should put a quarter still on it.
And then you can you,
I think you created some other ones,
right.
But it's pretty much a pipeline where
you're saying you're like more inch to
four days probably or whatever.
So we could change those,
those few in that range and see where it
goes and yeah, you you certainly.
So let me ask you this,
when when this calculation happens for
quarter inch, they'll run a single pass.
Yeah, depending on the type. Well,
the quarters is right there in the
morning 2 passes,
3/8 is 33/8 is definitely more than one
pass.
So how does the math look if you're just
putting in the rank,
it's not bigger at the point.
It's not bigger,
but it's going to extrapolate against the
length. It's going to multiply by length.
So if you put a,
let's let's take something simple.
Let's say my rate is 5 feet per hour for
three inch. That's what I know.
I know guys can go faster than that,
but that's just the estimated rate for a
three pass level when it's half inch.
When it's half inch, yeah,
you're going to do 6 pass, whatever,
5 pass and the quarter inch rate.
I'm used to seeing this can't put and you
can whale a whole lot faster than that up,
honestly, right?
That's what that's where most people are.
In that range for estimated purchase.
Yeah, of course you have to figure out,
you know, what you put in.
And I get asked all the time, what is,
what does that consist of? Well,
most people do consider yourself a
machine playing, uh, sure, you know,
knocking the beans off.
I guess they put all that in there.
So absolutely.
Yeah, so um,
that's and this is figuring like a big
bug, right?
You're right. Yes, I agree with you. Well,
if I I'm saying to whatever you want it
to be, OK, why not?
Because like we can get a stitch.
I get asked all the time. OK,
what's the pattern in the stitch?
It's a rate. Yeah, that's what it means.
It's just a rate.
Now I've built stitch rails for different
patterns,
but all of this is just the right.
So consider what you want it to be.
I can consider,
I can consider manual to be, you know,
for about willing if I wanted to.
I'm just putting whatever rate I want for
that particular process here.
Yes.
Kind of flip flat.
Uh,
when you probably want to be on your main
shop,
'cause that's the one that that you're
using, right?
Which, which main node?
I guess I was thinking not. Yeah,
I was thinking that was the one you were
using. We can get a look.
This is the one that we added last time
you were here so that we could tweak
numbers and move them around.
So what's being used to best?
What's the main? Yeah,
it means the the last one to change.
So do we want to then go to 3/8?
Put in your What did you say?
I was thinking the same thing.
That's why I actually have it much slower
here. Yeah,
it's just whatever is the standard here.
I'm used to using 5 feet and then and
then do you want to do like 5-6 feet
somewhere in between there and the
calendar there?
They go back and fix one eggs too.
So what happens? You know,
the estimator probably not gonna notice,
but when you guys do these beams,
these buildups and now you go from a
manual process to submark.
At the estimating stage,
would they ever do that or in the future
will they do that?
Are you going to have a sub arc or a sub
arc is still encapsulated within? Well,
because it will be right, I've created.
I've created another right.
You're going to use them a lot when
you're going to have to make another.
I wouldn't do it yet.
If I grade on already thinking because we
know that when we Weld some work on a
boom,
we know the machine can do 22 inches a
minute. We know that.
And it's a two pass well for us all the
way up to half inch inside,
outside two pass well, we're done. Yeah,
and that one was more of the.
We don't think you have enough data right
now to because you did one job and you
could do it,
but if you started doing sub arc welding
lobby work,
you need to deal with that because that's
something. I'll met with shop last week.
I forget what the what the assembly was
and they were working on the shop done,
but they they want.
Job.
But then they when it came down to the
they they need some work. It was savings,
but it if were you guys were welding it
like this, like this, you know?
Yeah,
working working one way back and forth.
So today we're talking about running them
and we we could be that switching it
around so.
But I hear how many are left to do.
Well,
you got to plan average to see if I can
see.
Maybe we should change the envelope for
18316 quarter 516 to 380.
That's the most standard on the airport.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and those ones are, those ones are.
I'm sure we got 10 foot, 5, sixteens, 8,
six creates 5 foot.
Then how about 3/16 and 1/83/16?
Seven and 1/8. Yeah.
And what do you got for quarter? Yeah.
Yeah. So we'll do that.
I can do the tech study on at the late
time, yeah,
and just so that we can have that.
So I'll have to check them out because
they should have gotten that done last
week,
but having them do it 45 to be better
long and.
One inch.
3 eights half inch. Yeah,
you do it that way. So you can cover your,
you got to do that double.
And then something, OK,
a single level or a double level, yeah.
Yeah,
he's like to say you can update the
retention anyway.
Let's get to the ballpark. All right.
So we've brought the wheel down,
down the pit where we need to get back up.
So the question is.
How much?
A bunch of operations to change your lab.
And what I would probably do is say, OK,
where do we want that to be?
What percentage is that?
And we'll see everything that is going to
fit up.
We will just.
It made the easiest thing to do. Yeah,
but we have.
In order to and still need to have,
we've just doubled.
I was going to say we're basically about
50%. Yep.
So let's try that and see what it does.
Like your standards.
Do they have any bid for shop segregation
as many as well or just for a few?
They have. They have.
It's just this morning.
I always wish they were just across the
board.
We're doing all the things like this for
this, you know?
Well, Mr.
Tells I'm a lot of Mr. Jason.
You never know.
We've been doing this five times here.
You know we got five groups of materials.
So I don't think shoot your room need to
do.
Well,
we can probably tell what you want with
this once going to fear.
I guess the the layout is going to get a
few as well, right?
Yeah, you know, layout stuff.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, I'll lay up and check stuff.
I just gotta be only if you will change.
But.
So.
At 2:50 so.
Then.
75's.
I'll take a little nap while you're doing
this, but it's all right. Yeah.
It wasn't quiet out there.
It must be on break. Oh yeah,
it's 10:40 when they're on lunch.
Yeah, I couldn't tell. I see it set up.
Yeah, there's about five boxes left. Yeah,
sorry.
Somebody to change.
I'm sorry, 0.
Why is that?
Well, to punish Nathan,
you don't need to get up.
That's why it's sincere.
I'm just mad for it.
We're going to do it.
Thank you.
I'm crypt and blah blah calculator.
I'm pretty good at math.
Repeat.
633367 I think I think so.
Oh.
No, no, baby.
The chicken ain't here yet.
Like level. I've never done one.
So all we're doing is we get more
realistic well times and we make up for
the time we've been using by adding it to,
you know, the layout. Yeah, yeah.
Then we have a run that against the
sample size.
Now we're looking at one and we're going
to look at it at 36.
It's got 6892 with 136.
Was Mark going to give you a bunch of
jobs?
Was Mark going to give you a bunch of
jobs?
I was kind of halfway.
And that's why I wondered if it mattered.
I don't want to be where we wanted to be,
but it yeah, it looks like.
It looks. I bet she's got,
I bet she's got one. Yeah,
we could get back to what they're
actually.
We just appoint one schedule and then go
back to the jobs now and see if it comes
out right.
You get that same e-mail when every
single job,
every single release it says here's the
hours we're using.
Yes,
we we can go back and check a bunch of
those, yeah.
But I think you have to check it at 2
levels because I have a feeling that Mark
is correcting the the older pattern
because yeah,
they're going to be changed and that's
why they came out exactly the same
because somebody's modified. I know.
So it's got to go back up a level, yeah.
But I have a feeling now if they run it
through check the.
We're building it to the matchbox hours,
OK.
Now we'll test the system.
This this should.
What times takes a while to do this?
That's how it would.
He gave me something hard to do.
That's my back here.
He's gotta get this damn thing run for
two weeks, yeah.
Just to grab a beep.
I wish. Let's go. It's not.
Better have gone to Barloway last night.
And.
OK.
Or it was, uh, let me see.
Let me they didn't have those two burgers,
Tuesday burger. We had like, uh,
$8 burgers.
Check your. That's great. Yeah,
it's fixed. Yeah, I'm kidding.
These aren't what I have is gonna be good.
Yeah, that's what we did a minute ago.
Yeah, OK, yeah,
but we're going to the end shade families.
So we did all the these lectures. Yeah,
channels and everything.
That would be all anything that's taller
than the spice.
Yeah.
OK.
That's it.
Somebody got to determine what percentage
we're going to use to 75% of pay numbers
we ever want.
I think 75% of the estimated amount is
not right.
So I I I go to find the other one thing
because.
I don't think anybody's runs 100%
efficient and I think.
I mean, I understand your reasons, but.
The reasoning is we want to know what it
actually takes, but I get that.
If we if we had time studies and we knew
all these were real,
then I would agree with you that if you
have one. But I don't know.
I don't believe we have the right time
studies yet. I agree with you.
So until we get the right steps,
in my opinion, you have to be more like .
9.
So one of the things I would do a lot of
times.
Say my were busy. Yeah,
I would start adding contingency 'cause I
knew that other queries were not as fast
as my. Yeah, I mean.
There's so many ways to tweak it, right?
There is. Yeah.
It's just when it's being tweaked in the
background,
you don't actually know what it is, yeah.
I also know if we can keep the shop on
over time, 45 and 50 more efficient.
Oh yeah,
once we've got over 52 hours a week,
then then cover the comments that we made
yesterday.
You wouldn't have guys standing around.
Wondering where you're going with your
time,
which job are you going to put the time
on? Well, that's the crazy part.
I think we were three years ago. I was,
I was working 70 hours a week trying to
push packages out to the shop,
programming and purchasing.
And the shop was working 708090 hours a
day. We were always busy,
always ever coming in.
And there's between estimators just
rewarding shop only work to us supporting
the field with anything and everything
that they needed. Always.
Now it's, I mean, so what changed?
I guess the department doesn't,
doesn't support us nearly as much as they
used to.
We'll send them their opportunities and
we'll sit on that until that's the way
that's the due date or won't we get it at
all.
But what are they? I mean,
I hear that they want to keep hiring
estimators.
They're doing what's estimating when
rates are really low.
Are we just chasing along with the work?
That could be,
that could be a portion of it,
but a lot of the work we're looking at
were.
I think some of it's our labor rates too,
because we're charging big shop rates and
we're we don't have big shop and when we
end up having to put your more money into
subbing things out and.
Things out and and then me trying to
account for that in the budget and a lot
of times I'll deduct hours because
obviously everyone's more efficient.
So I'll deduct that from my labor and
reduce my labor hours and take that extra
money and put it towards the sub
application bucket.
They're not always considering that and
so that's bringing us sometimes before
and but most of all of the the fab only
work that we've gotten this year has been
stuff that we need remark for bidding.
And it's a lot of the stuff that we're
not getting is that that kind of said the
estimators.
I think they are just as many as they
were, but.
It's a mixture now because they've got
some of the guys who are doing structural
doing electrical estimates because we're
heavily becoming an electrical company
because there's so much revenue in that
and so that just feels like their focus
has shifted to a different area and they
don't give us new.
It's because there's so much more over
there, there's so much more, yeah,
that goes into the shop.
That's what I mean, right.
So and that's like.
Are we removing the fabrication or what
are we needing? Yeah,
I think that's why they want to go after
more custom miscellaneous work that other
trades don't want to do.
So like the data centers,
they got tons of miscellaneous.
We call it more difficult than average
miscellaneous.
It's not building draft beads and ladders,
you know,
it's really custom miscellaneous work
that other shops.
They're just afraid to do it, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
So the son picked up these skids.
It was 92 skids. Yeah,
it was $40 million worth of work.
There's the other shops. Well,
there's skid shops out there now.
They were full.
And some have never built skids before,
but the K guys that came over there were
used to building skids.
So they went from a three-man crew to now
up to an 18 man crew to the.
And all they're really doing is
assembling because they don't have,
they don't have any equipment.
There's just assembly.
We call it fusion welding. OK,
so fusion welding, they're buying it out.
We're good. Yeah, reporting to work.
I think you and I are gonna need to align
for what? We're gonna need to align.
Could be. I know.
I think it's easier that way because
otherwise it's a mixed message coming. OK,
I agree with that.
And I I think we're really close on most
tires. Yeah,
I think you're constructional slowing and
I have tanks, stuff like chairs and like,
yeah,
I think I'm on the structural
miscellaneous stuff and I think that it's
my.
And So what I'm telling,
what I'm kind of saying is data centers
are pretty similar. Yeah.
And the interesting part of data centers
is actually how they're going to give
them power.
Because there's no power for data centers,
that's what everybody's mentioned about.
So they're trying to Congress, you know,
they propose a bill in Congress to stop
data center build out for a year till
they figure out how to deal with.
Chart with power and water,
because the whole country is that's it's
hard something.
Yeah.
And so I think that these data center
people are realizing that if they don't.
You know,
they can't Jack up people's water and
electricity rates because they're getting
unpopular, right?
I don't know if you guys have noticed
your power bill probably went up 20%.
Mine personally didn't. It's not a old.
I bought a house that was grandfathered
into the solar system.
I had to replay.
I had to redo all the solar pounds
because they were so old,
but because I was a grandfather,
I got to keep the old crates.
So mine haven't got enough.
Mine is completely covered by my solar.
I just paid 30 months to stay connected,
but if you're not honest.
Yeah, that is approved. Yeah,
20% increase. I got, well, one did change,
but there is a Corporation Commission
which regulates that allow power
companies to increase the rates.
376 is that right? Oh, yeah, not not 376.
Yeah, but I think short term,
we're not there. Short term,
we've got to go after some parts of, yeah.
Yeah, I see.
I'm still getting my feet wet training
last week, training this week.
You have to meet me as mayors.
I I I I actually thought there would be a
lead here both of this week.
Did you do all your KPA stuff then?
I'm still not done.
I'm still getting emails. Yeah, I need to.
I'm trying to figure those out.
I tried to prepare a couple of them out
this morning. You know,
I can tell me turn my programs.
I need like heavy bit.
I have no idea about.
I've heard of the program,
but I've never used it.
So I'm gonna have to learn to use that,
I guess.
Yeah,
some of them are not giving you access to
'cause the license process is too low,
yeah.
Like to me,
Salesforce is what I want to look at,
which is all the opportunities we're
looking, yeah.
There's a small job that's worth looking
at that it's probably going to be one for
a mine and you get to look at the cycle
side of it and the heavy bit side of it
because I went through it with Isaac.
I was sitting in on a call, yeah.
He's like you.
He's like making changes so fast and I
can't even keep up with it.
But he clicked a few things and the price
I got in a 70 grand and I'm like, whoa,
is that real?
Didn't seem like you moved that much
stuff out.
Yeah.
Yeah, I.
To Isaac worked here for two years and
then he went off to his own business and
then he came back.
I've been here a long time to see all the
OG's.
I've seen people come and go back and
forth and it's there.
Well, we did plate being too,
got the angle and rods.
It.
Doing good. Yes, I'm cheering you on.
Yeah, it's our thing. Yeah, that's sweet.
The bad thing is when when we go,
then we we evaluate. It's like,
not quite there.
We bump it up a little bit more.
I think they say, yeah,
don't say anything over.
Well, I'll see.
I'll be really good at adjusting and
pushing later. Yeah, yeah.
What's your title? What's your title?
Manager. Advanced application.
They'd like to see the plan or work
correction within three months.
What to do?
I've got some jobs and we calibrated.
I know what I'd like to do,
but I just don't think that's where I'll
say get to that point.
OK, we'll work on that.
Then they finally got said, oh,
I understand you're looking for a
checkbook.
I'll get to that later today or tomorrow.
That's chief. Yeah.
Every day came up with some evidence.
Yeah,
I tried to do Salesforce and Salesforce
was a no.
Who's Chris Keller?
Chris Keller is the controls the.
He's the head of estimating. Oh, OK,
they're they sent an e-mail to him saying
about requesting.
10.14.
But he's there left me. It was just,
he's just here. He's now sales,
but he used, in my mind,
he used to report to. They moved to about,
yeah.
Do you know a lot of people here already?
You obviously were some of you. No, no.
This was all last week and this week, OK.
Good.
It's one of the things I tried to figure
out. I was like,
who are the real people in the touch
points?
Who's got the information on the lot,
yeah.
He just sit down next to Teeth and ask
him questions. He knows all of them. Well,
I know I sit 8 feet away for Teeth,
but I I've been there very much.
He sat at my desk for 15 minutes and
download the system, yeah.
Yeah, so Jeff sent it to Jesse Jackson.
I just.
Say what? Yes. Oh, it's not that. Oh,
you have to work through it, yeah.
Did you use the PowerPoint?
They got a lot of programs with her.
I'm honestly, we did that. So yeah.
I said if you want to take probably so
I'll you said we'll jump apart.
So it's very transferred a little to the
office, but it's right.
So I just take the.
Should have called. I think it was.
I think it was standard.
We were doing something like that,
which is completely different than doing.
You know, we have sheets out.
But let's say for these people, did you?
But we lost them a lot. Yeah, I was.
I was like, I guess.
I guess I don't know how to do it though.
It's pretty fun. I don't know.
I just want to make investment. You know,
I think 10% margins in that business.
I think that's.
So that the structural is very commodity.
It sits in as well.
So if you're going to say I was saying
70%, what's the back end?
I will say because they're making 20% of.
I'm sure still bad.
Yeah.
Something like we were doing.
That was the super album. Yeah, yeah.
Like we go to there are bringing along
with the impact. That's what it does.
We have that. That's a structure,
skeletal structure,
pharmacy on the inside.
Now that's rats in the skin.
It's got thousands of this, you know,
but we erected it.
If you go inside the Phoenix Convention
Center.
It's super, you know, feed is super cool.
Mm-hmm. So I can get in there.
I was a bit.
I was on the space only to be placed on
the slide. Oh, I didn't.
We get these. We're going to, yeah,
that's what I think.
Looks better.
Almost right on 3141 versus 3244.
I'd probably be happy with that for now.
I'd be very.
Material handling, you know, whatever.
But so yeah,
so cut basically needs to bump almost
double. Yeah, cut needs to double.
Material handling means 50% for for
giggles. Is there another?
Their job that we could run this against,
I know we're working on a sample size of
blood.
I was just like,
what was that other job that you, uh,
remember which one? So he pulls up a five.
He pulled up a much larger job.
So when that when I see on page one that
had a lot of.
I think it was TSMC.
There's a lot of TSMC guides, I'm sure.
Sent these variables,
science points it looks like.
Is that all of this?
Is this preparing the clean noise?
So that's what you said. You're not.
I have a chart going some that's probably
confused because or if you want to.
Set.
This thing.
She I got this.
Six.
I don't know.
6:02 so.
OK.
How are you talking, Johnston?
We have to do a month a day until I heard
it comes here.
I tried to I come this morning and you
got a toll.
They're going to see you.
I'm working on doing.
What is it?
It's just the whole job.
I based on my job on my walk yesterday at
the shop, it's like, yeah,
we have a bunch of that here.
We just have to buy it up.
And that's just my equipment.
You said the same thing.
They can,
but they're not based on the equipment
that I see here.
It's like basically columns and bigs.
It's like these come through.
So I may have the baseline.
If we if we get it,
then we're just going to talk it out.
That's the problem.
We ought to have it so much.
Somebody's getting this.
I think it's the waste.
It's in my opinion. No,
it's the same thing I say.
I just walk in the door, right?
Nobody said.
We're trying to say this works.
I haven't talked to Jeff since I've been.
I I met him. Jeff,
John and Jimmy because it's only
interviewed me.
So I met. I had never met.
He was on my original role.
And my first day,
I didn't know he's in my office. Uh,
what was that?
I don't really have, so it's so easy.
Yeah, people here most of the most of the.
I'm supposed to be being with you,
the guys, 2 desks behind me.
I don't know where he's at.
Yeah, that's.
The hours.
But what you can do is to find and
retract. I think it's like from.
I didn't do that. I'm not sure.
Where they have they they got a shot of
premaged panel A and installed.
And I I didn't know what they could do
here, what they could do here.
I'm in the middle of helping the field
install.
But they want it installed.
So this all if you didn't deal with it,
it's kind of paying it down.
So that's when it is, you know,
if you see now,
I'm trying to help them get.
Interesting. Yeah.
So I got to get some coupons.
So I've got to do it.
We've got to come from all the other guys.
What the hell is going to happen? OK.
Well, that's not.
I wonder if it's five in the end,
but but I get to the report that shows
it's less than or something.
Let's see that it's OK,
one by number of opportunities and OK,
one by no,
it comes straight up to sales stores. Oh,
really? That's right. That's all I did.
I won't give you.
I need to back them to that. All right.
I have a different right to answer points
and Jeff.
Now you can see what the difference is.
OK, I need your list of.
This is what we want. Negotiation. Yeah.
Do you want that? Sure.
I'll send you a copy. I mean,
I'm just getting along with this couch.
Yeah, I'm just getting myself on the list.
Yeah, I don't know what's going on.
Thank you.
That's the only process I can see myself.
I'm sorry.
Did you get a chance to get the new
account? All right, that's the way out.
It's got no question.
I miss that question.
That's like the visit to the. That's fine.
OK. So how do I say it's where I use the,
I'll go to the additional labour and I'll
figure out what the development is and
then I'll the if the part's the same
project and I'll figure out the 12 hours
and then I'll plug it in the hour.
That's right. That's well. Well,
it's time.
But it's right.
It's probably shouldn't be Fed up.
Fed up looks way up proportion the way to.
Trips.
Yeah, that'll make a difference.
I was going to say that that made my
heart skip a beat. OK, that.
You're preparing another one then? Yes.
This is one that.
So handling was 69 and 75.
That was at 46 or 59 so I.
18113 So I thought close it here.
It's at 78. It said 69.
It was 8855 plus the 40s that was about
28.
Let me let me get these while we're here.
Hang on a second.
You, you,
you're going to get individual jobs.
It's like, yeah,
he doesn't know how to do the jobs in I
believe,
but is that what it it actually took to
do those jobs? I can take,
I can take a look and see where we
finished out for actual on this one.
But this is that it's on the screen now
on the left, the one that's on the left,
that's what they released as both. Oh, OK,
so that's basically that's. So yeah,
that was,
I'm pretty sure with this one we were
provided with the total hours and said.
Put it right out together kind of like
this. They gave us,
they gave us one lump sum and said to get
out.
So this would have been another one that
would have appeared.
Uh, one of our estimators. Yeah,
so and this will let us.
I wouldn't trust that as much as the one
that I trust from.
No, the guy he worked with here, he said.
He's at the meeting today for LLC.
I'm guessing we should trust Parks more
because he's out here with him all the
time. He knows much back to Katie, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so this one,
every pretty much every single one of
these packages, they.
They originally bid the project at
quarter inch across the board.
We got the final drawing set and all of
the weldments switched to 516 instead of
board.
So all things were reestimated before we
sent them on to the floor just to see.
To make sure we weren't going to bust it.
If we're going to bust it,
we're going to try and get ahead of it
and say here's where it is going to take
us. If it's over a certain dollar amount,
then we're going to see, you know,
he's estimating or tracking the cost in
some some form.
So that's that was kind of the process
with Pawson's to get them in.
I reestimated them before they got put
out on the floor and then and then we go
from there.
So so the the mix between your fifth,
Weld and other.
Is essentially what the fit and Weld is
over here, but yeah,
it depends on what your other should be,
what bucket it should be in, yeah.
But you're essentially the same.
I should have on that last one.
I should have recorded that as on that
last job.
I should have recorded that as well.
Can we get back and redo that?
Yeah, yeah,
the person that we were adjusting off of.
I'm sorry,
I should have grabbed it while we were
there.
That way we can look at 234K of these,
whatever we want to look at to see.
Do we see consistent spray in there? Yeah.
We haven't looked at actual hours yet.
Uh, the other ones from Mark yesterday.
Yeah,
but all the way to supposed those are
supposed actual hours that have been
docked because the guys didn't have that
induced that they put their time on the
job.
It sounds like Chris is probably getting
tasked with making sure these numbers are
right, the items in here,
so that you can eventually say, yeah,
these are good now,
let's push it out all the.
I like what he said he wants.
He also wants to be actionable of hours.
You and I both agree with this.
The whole business has to go on actual
hours. Yeah, once you have it,
you can start working.
Which helps, you know,
fix it by trying to get better. Sorry,
it's reduces the wrong emotions. OK,
this is the right data,
but I put the wrong shot. OK, cool.
It's this. This is our.
So.
Yeah, 150, OK.
And then had that, uh, 6144.
Yeah, that's a service.
OK. So do you,
do you have a snippet of that that you
just showed of what the job really belong
to that? This is just for these. Oh, OK.
Yeah,
this this one is really the last one we
were looking at that I can, I can pull up.
That I can pull up will be so this one
299.
You're gonna give us the actual one now
then? Yeah. So I'll pull up.
Take the details for this one again,
so the screenshot.
382 is, yeah, total. Yeah.
What's what's correct? Yeah. OK,
everyone did that. What is it?
The other one had coding time that we
have in the county for both of that time.
Well, we're talking about it. OK,
so in B3 right now,
that's the lines were 3320 and.
And the actually was when these was so
and then if I go back in here and I go.
7.
Here, here.
What's that? I'm not too certain.
I think they're following. Yeah,
they're starting to try and I think
they're using heavy bid.
Thank you.
This is pure speculation at this moment.
The one that I'm curious about is the
Blofield shop,
because it's such a mechanical shop that
I'd be surprised if they don't have a
piping package estimator.
So let's just where we finish with
actions.
Total. We finished 10 weeks,
just under 10 hours under the original
budget. It's 299. Well, we used 86 versus.
Of course, it's gonna be.
Well,
previous 86 and we had 88 in this is.
And uh.
71.7578 looks perfect. That's.
We use 45.2546 burn. We use 17.75.
Stop.
Every bid versus Aqua, they say. And yeah,
the tech was way better for the structure.
It's basically simple for several
contractors. That's right.
I didn't know that.
If I look that up after looking at that,
why would they be easy to begin with?
I don't know. Interesting.
They're feeding structural into it.
I think that low row middle of field
stuff, yeah.
I mean, I don't have the history yet,
but I'm working on getting it.
Yes,
I think power fab technically is going to
be everything that structural it just
drives and even that electrical that
you're talking about be able to push.
Why aren't we going to do that today or
tomorrow?
What's your actual on the 25060948?
Do you have that?
That's the first one.
That's the second one. The one. Yeah,
that one there. This one.
This one was just released for production
today. Oh, OK, because, yeah.
Can I do do one additional project with
both international? Yeah,
or do 40 whatever, you know,
the more the better.
740, I think, right?
And.
Tekla's hours are total of 58 budget
being non 69. Um.
We're kind of going all over here.
No, they're not.
So like as an example on the 240758 fit
up and weld are basically right between
Tekla and the budget.
The last one we looked at 2506-0948. Um.
It's pretty close between fit up and weld
it it's there's a little slight
difference.
The two front this one is there's a
forty-eight percent difference between
Weld and a 20% difference between fit up.
And if we look at handling cut burn.
So just handling one job is 8.
78 high in Tekla,
30% low on the next job in Tekla,
20% high on this job.
That's a nice average. Yeah, that was.
30% high on the first one,
53% low on the second one,
112% high on the next one.
Burn is 34% low on the first one,
1% high on the second one,
28% low on the on the third one.
But it's all the same families of jobs.
Are you basically making things with flag
plates here?
Are they different types of jobs?
This one and the first one are very
similar to both of those.
Sounds like the birds in one place were
lacking the other three in the middle way.
That that T6 one,
the one we did in the middle, that one,
the one that we looked in actuals is a
mixture of structural as well as some
miscellaneous. So it's got.
Angles, gust of plates,
a bunch of little stuff,
and this is mostly easy columns. Yeah,
because in my mind,
if you start mixing handrail with beads
and columns, it's a good universe, yeah.
Yeah.
And and and some of these are pretty
small too,
so we'll see a little bit of a wide road.
I'd want to see a bunch of jobs in 500
hours or more, yeah.
And if we want, let's see,
we can keep it on the same scale of the
758 project,
which is structural and a small
anonymously is in one package 7581.
So I don't say anything that makes me
want to say,
we'll need to change this by this. Yeah.
The only thing I saw that you just read
out was we were low level of burns, right?
Yeah.
On, yeah,
essentially that middle job was about the
same, but there's a rounds of it use that.
And you know,
I I know if if Mark's doing this split,
but.
I get his experience, he's got it right.
He's happening every day,
but I'm going to put a little bit more
weight on the tech,
but from the standpoint of it's going to
be very consistent,
whereas he's going to flip the drawings
and get a.
General theory, right?
And so I'll go with.
If if if I see some slight variation
there and then it's because of his, yeah,
the way,
I shouldn't say the way the wind blows.
I don't know it's more than that,
but he's not looking at every cut and
every everything.
So you're taking that with a grain of
salt, yeah.
I mean, a lot of,
I don't know if you tell me,
but a lot of structure is either dollar
per pound or dollar per ton. Yeah,
a lot of people bid like that.
I don't like it, but they do. To me,
it's like you start out with the hours
and things really going to take and the
cost.
And then you look and say, oh, OK,
about how many,
how much money is that per time per pound?
Why is this one higher than the norm?
Or why is this one lower than the norm?
Because it's important.
I use 30 lbs per man hour for what I
would call our standard work.
I've done the same thing. I was like, OK,
it's just to get your thumb in here with
that. It's like if you see 100.
What it is?
But that doesn't work for structure.
It didn't work for duct tape chutes,
hoppers.
That other fuel gets used a lot,
so that's kind of throwing a bug in this
as well.
Because that's a fifth of the hours on
this job. Yeah, no.
16 well at 3 foot 10.6.
So then I took the .6 and.
Let me please say it doesn't jive.
Is it's changed at this point.
So these estimators looks like it ought
to be in fit up because weld on this job.
Tekla was higher on by 38% and the.
Fit up was way under,
probably because using the A reason
during the manual manipulation down there,
you don't get fed up.
So I would bet that goes in. In fact,
I won't put it in there.
The other part is it's it's also odd
because.
We adjusted our Weld rate and I
calculated these wells.
Essentially this was 516 Weldman,
3 foot 10 of well, which is now .6,
whereas before.
It was 1.
2 OK and then so my hours per piece,
all these 1.2 is another .
6 and these are all under that should be
cut.
These are all under the other category.
Yeah,
that's the hours per piece falls into the
other category.
Essentially when I was estimating these
and they gave me hey now you need this
estimate for two hours.
This is how much I need time based on
Tekla.
Now I can go in here and globally edit
that pieces.
So.
Not, you know, a little bit more actual,
but because it's hours per piece,
our metrics that we've changed, yeah,
change that, yeah.
Um.
So that is one thing in skewed the other
categories in skewed.
There is.
Really zero patterns.
So like burn on this one was pretty close.
I mean right almost 18.69 versus 18,
whereas burn on the others one was 28%
under, 1% over, 34% under.
There's just no pattern whatsoever. Um.
I mean, I think it's gonna be.
I mean the word hundreds.
I think it's also going to be the
hundreds ones driven by Mark and the ones
driven by Gilbert.
Because if you start mixing those,
you're going to have less. Yeah, yeah,
I think you're you're right. Well,
in all of these instances over years,
right.
Yeah, these were, these were mine,
but it's really the actuals, right?
The actuals should still be the actuals,
be the actuals. Yeah,
you have actuals on 247 about 8.
That's what I do. Yeah,
it's the actuals in the 566. That's the.
Are you charging, charging yourself? Yeah,
OK.
And you have it by job. Yeah. OK, good.
And the 566 was supplied by Gilbert.
So we were held to their dollar amount to
be supplied that breakout.
I estimated it half year just so that we
could see if we would go over or not.
How to do, you know,
I guess we'll see you in a second,
historically and guess we're around
*******.
And then.
It's.
Hey.
I'm good at what you're so sorry.
Yes.
Yes, Sir.
Yes.
Pause.
Perfect. I uh, I will make sure that uh,
that you are doing and we'll get you 1040.
That's all right, Sir.
So.
Yes, Sir. Yeah,
go ahead and get started on them.
That'll give me a head on my.
So thank you.
Yeah.
So that particular lot is what we're
talking about.
To.
But then we have.
One and then when we go in here,
we have sequence 3 level one.
I don't see a sequence 3 level 2.
So I guess this is the log.
Yeah, it's handling at zero,
but we have 96 plan hours.
Thanks to the project.
So I think.
This production still.
So that's.
That's 5 minutes moving to based on that.
She is less than five.
We have 13567,
so is this one big job and we're just
looking at where pieces of this one big
tab? That's what I'm going to do.
I mean, there's so much data here. I mean,
I see 600, 370.
1800 There's a lot of data here, yeah.
It'd be nice to.
I don't know if you can dump it all in
one bell swoop into Excel.
Like those budget numbers don't match
well.
Show them here either.
close adjustments.
Um.
What we were saying the other day was
that was the estimate.
That's what I'm saying.
It doesn't match this, but then there's,
I mean, I see three,
I see base adjustment plan regular.
Yeah, see,
there's there's actually an estimated
hours field as well that lay in this.
That's where I wasn't expecting to see
the estimate,
but they were saying they were using the
adjustment for the estimated so plan.
Is the sum of adjustment plus base.
Yep.
Time track machine so severe.
So she did before.
We.
3.
I'm from North Florida.
Is it a?
Surprised to send this in the e-mail.
It'd be like you'd send a spreadsheet and
say here it is this.
I would assume that Tekla was baked.
Well, it's got the,
it's got it laid out the schedule.
Instead of typing this every week, yeah,
just having that as a report.
Estimate versus actual bunch of jobs.
It's.
How in the world does it let you have the
same sheet name?
And I'm saying that was answered the
question.
I'm also all of these.
They said that we have one sheet in the
folder that we constantly we just keep
adding ages to.
So each of those is the job number on the
bottom. Yeah,
we did the job number at the bottom.
It's regular.
It's lots of associated with it and then
once it's done, we hide it.
OK then.
The.
Where's this loadable on your your
computer? No,
this lives in Mark's folder in the
archive and shop.
This is what he does this Tuesday on
management. I put a space in.
We used to have Fred Dutton doing this
for us each week.
He would pull reports whole time and then
go through and review changes and send up
and and then he stopped working here.
I'm afraid to see the archive and the
application stop.
I can't see.
See.
March.
There's the adults for the practical
shopping clear, 40 South Douglas.
You guys have that session?
I don't really like. It's awesome.
Would you be willing to talk to your guy
at Tech about it? I haven't contacted.
It's Dan Lopez. If you've seen it,
watch any of Power Fab's videos.
He's the one with the heavy standard
accent. Oh, OK.
They they would like to some input on
what people like about those type systems,
what they don't like,
what you want to see improved.
I have a feeling they might be looking at
doing something with that. So yeah,
I know they really could.
You know, the integration and and having,
I mean,
it'd be really nice if we could mark off
something in the quality control side
there. Yeah, and yeah, mark off in. Yeah,
and whatnot.
I'll give them your contact if I get up
with.
How's your audit going? What?
How's your audit going?
Saturday meeting for an hour and a half
and.
They never called me in, but I haven't.
I have a corporate environmental here
doing the . And then I have a...
I'm not as much fun as you guys.
It might be. It might be.
Beautiful weather out there. It's not.
It's not bad.
Can't believe it's going to be 80 today.
I believe it makes it to 80.
Is it I heard is there any today or
tomorrow? That's just stupid.
I guess it's not the the most orgasm.
It's like bags, paper bags for shipping.
It's instruments. It doesn't seem like it.
Sunday, Monday is supposed to be.
Yeah.
Pretty intensive of that.
Do you need a relate something?
It's just I can't be expected.
That's it. This.
OK.
Jimmy, he'll be here at one,
so I think he hasn't responded,
so he didn't see there.
He said it couldn't make it to let us
know and he'll dial it.
So I'll be on the average machine.
Yeah.
Yes, I can follow him. Yeah,
we want to see like a servant for all of
this.
This.
That's a question.
It's one of the people losing,
but sometimes don't look like it's right
now and that we've had so much today.
Any butchers? Did they hatch work at all?
This is wing. There's no.
We've been even though preschool.
I think they just announced technical.
We saw the things as approach goes back
to, yeah, we makes sense.
And we installed and actually installed.
0.
What's the difference between what switch
does and what low run electrical does?
What Revolution Electrical does?
Which which main is data centers?
What are they? Lights data centers?
Yeah, who knows?
We have switched radio and then pass.
I'm working.
Pull on a lot of power.
We did like lighting packages and the
Intel. We're kind of like more horrors,
you know,
like it's something you see anywhere
which and make them more concentrated on
the bigger.
Davis, things like that. That question.
Jimmy will be here at 1:00. He can.
He can give you a very detailed right
account.
But we're getting big much.
We're expanding more in electrical than
anything else now.
Yeah, yeah. Since I'm going to be said,
OK,
I'll just put that up is the issue is set
on a scratch. Yeah.
As long as we can use, they would.
I'm sorry,
we'll make the amounts about it, Justin.
I don't think what is the seller.
Or what do you want to consider?
I like this building.
I wish you could watch out with Jimmy
today as possible. Yeah,
I think I think you're possible.
I don't want to be. What? Awesome.
Thank you.
He gave me something to do. It's very,
very. He came up with me yesterday.
I was like, how long have you got?
Mustache, you know, like one month.
So, like two days ago.
I will go up looking here.
But.
That Christmas gift.
I don't know.
He said there were bringing gifts.
He didn't say there was going to pop in
and bring gifts like that.
We could take it back. No, I'm quick.
What's going on?
Absolutely.
That needs a.
It's a new year, right?
No, I don't.
I did it. Did you get a phone? Oh, sorry,
I'm taking both.
Do you try out to be hungry every week?
Yes, Sir.
Yeah, you can call them down all the time.
That's what we'll show later. Yeah,
I probably just hang out on weekends.
Yeah,
I I last year I traveled at least for
four and one weeks.
My wife will get away.
OK, our kids are off. Mind you, yeah.
Good. We got three. I'm here, right kids.
And that one was just born in August,
so brand new, you know,
and that was born like 6 months ago. OK.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, he he's just what,
3-4 months old and so,
but they live right across from by myself.
Oh that's cool. Yeah,
that's why I have to do two of my three
kids, five of my grains,
six wheelchair because.
They found chiropractic work here in
California, get them involved here,
practice here. She moved here.
So then they don't have to be when you
got to move here. Southern California,
yeah.
How old are you kids?
You have mother.
312621 I've got young kids.
I was late getting started. Yeah.
19 year old and if you want to be 25 year
old got married and says we're not happy
because we can't afford it.
Then they got breaking right away, right?
Yeah.
I always said Mary, but he's.
They've been growing. I'm serious.
He lives in DC.
Works with government contractor.
I really made state of what he does,
but um.
Something with Arc GIS for for the
military.
His girlfriend has a really interesting
job.
She is a secret service in the White
House. Really. Yeah, that would be.
So she was.
She was telling me back Thanksgiving when
they were home.
Favorable world, she left.
Really interested in that.
She's sitting there.
You can lunch and mark every Rubia is
going to be another. So she, yeah,
she gets a extra long time and maybe all
is coming through,
but she learned that was the name.
There was that shooting at the National
Guard in the White House. She was leaving.
That was right at two.
Her shift was done at two or five in the
afternoon. She's walking through a car.
It's in the car,
right here in his office and says shots
fired made down.
When that comes out, it doesn't matter.
If you're on the grounds,
you're hitting back in the White House
when they run in and shut the White House
down.
And I didn't know the Secret Service
actually police is outside the White
House as well. So that is actually.
Co-workers that were the first one was
right there with the guys and a lot of
them were pretty staking up from that so.
Of driving.
There's my son in.
I just visited my daughter in UNLV and I
stopped for a lunch. St. George,
UT as I'm drunk, but how far?
I would come up and he's looking at my
truck. I've never had a problem.
We do that before.
Come out next meeting and he's looking.
That was a day chart. And as I did,
traffic was just complete **** show. Yeah,
I think they were looking in cars to see
what.
They could see. Yeah. Wow.
Because I think you were trying to find
the. Yeah, but I was going the wrong way.
I was going to the.
I can't imagine the one with the Secret
Circus. You know what here is?
I noticed she was.
TSA in Orlando Airport and Transfer to
Secret Service.
I did not know that they're in the same
department.
And so we'll solve this as an
opportunities.
Of course she had to get training if I'm
not,
but they accepted her and so she's she
don't know about two years.
I have no idea what's the same report,
but is she part of the protective detail
or is she?
Yeah, she's fully.
Check out and all the gangs and
everything. Absolutely.
You said when the when that shooting,
normally they just have pistols on their
side, but when that happened,
then something like that has a lot of
breakup involved in the she said.
And now it's like a fourth year in a one
point and they like went all the way up
there. She took us on a tour.
I was talking to. I was talking to.
This has got to be, you got to be,
you got to be. It's got to be universe.
And he's like,
what's standing this one in the last 20
years, he said.
I've seen Prince sit down and and play
that. Elton John. He's like,
I just saw these people come through.
We got a lot of stories being interesting.
Yes.
I asked them.
I asked all of them how political they
want to, you know, because, yeah,
different administration's from you.
And she said they're actually.
They try to not watch a lot of stuff.
They don't want to be too biased with the
other coats.
They don't know the other side,
but you said the flip side of that too is
they're kind of seeing the news, you know.
But she said everybody, you know,
the news takes it so different. Yeah,
she's like,
they're just normal people and it doesn't
matter who gets through.
He's like.
Is she does work the White House or does
she have to go on these advanced teams?
So the White House is her main focus,
but when he travels then they.
They ask for volunteers that want to go
on a trip with them,
and if they don't get volunteers,
then they get volunteers. So yeah, sure,
very different places, you know,
every now and then,
but they do have to go.
I start running trips every every year.
They don't fly on the luxury
accommodations.
They usually fly in the car.
They're not flying the airport.
They're not.
How much gear you gonna check with you?
Let me see. I can let me see helicopter.
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
So did you tell where? I'm sure.
He was just that.
Trump was just at the Kennedy Center,
which is in DC,
but they had to take a whole detail there.
She was.
Working that,
but may that be cool because that was
kiss was there. George Strait,
I forget who all else.
I'd like to see things.
She's like outside of.
I was sexy just being in the White House.
I'd rather do steal.
Yeah.
But.
I heard a lot that.
Like a lot of shops barely touch the
capabilities what power I have to do.
Probably I should I should keep better
statistics on it,
but I'm guessing 60 to 70% of the clients
have had it for.
For 15 years.
It didn't use it to that labels. I mean,
I believe you and I know we're taking the
knowledge and stuff. Yeah, the guy,
the guy I had dinner with last night went
in control of that suite to power.
I will be dabbled in.
He said most of the time the estimators
and the detailers are the same people.
If you really don't set up,
really just don't need it. So yeah,
estimators and detailers for you to sign
that's.
That's not what I've I've seen,
but I haven't seen that way. Yeah,
it's like, I can have that too.
So this is about 100 and there'll be a
shot.
That I'm getting it.
So I feel that very much somebody's I
know whether they want to use the
software if it's for project managers is
like pulling feed and getting in there,
which I don't understand because their
whole job.
Project that's what's happening on the
projects.
I've spent about actually half my career
estimated in the other half of the
project manager.
So I haven't had the opportunity with you
very much, but I would like to.
It is. It is weird to have an idea,
but you know, and that's a that's an ad.
We shouldn't get some project vendors are
all in the right and others are just
don't want to.
Thank you.
The time structure came down and said to
rise at the cutting edge.
Please.
But because it was just laughable and how
slow we were,
but both of you have been one ran a
Python.
And Horizon ran. I have a beam up there.
Beam one start next year.
Are you guys driving to see something?
Show.
I mean,
it's I think the cheapest way to increase
capacity. I'm supposed to think the,
you know, base models are about 300,000.
I think those we don't need abortments.
It's like a coasting song in front of it.
They're very, very nice setups, but.
Thank you. Probably just for our code,
but it's probably about 1,000,
000 bucks for it. Yeah,
you got the advantage, though.
It's actually going to the drill saw next
to it.
Plug and play, but yeah,
it's it's more like.
You know what I'm surprised you went out
is nobody's off at that job. And it's out.
I mean, they've got it. I mean years ago,
man, it's a freaking doc program.
Why didn't somebody?
Update this thing to know I I had heard
that SDS was looking at buying it because
you know that that structure was that lot
that suite and it really elevated.
Yeah,
because it was gonna be a Tesla when you
write it. I have it.
I give the SDS and the DOS level. Yeah,
SDS is awesome.
I'm I'm a first year old business.
Start working.
Yeah,
one of the things these guys have been
chasing was all the pesto work for Intel,
yeah.
Problem is,
it's it's a material handling job.
It's not a bad job. Yeah, it's a maximum.
Yeah,
but they have like 100 different designs.
So they throw about at you and every week
the schedule move cuz medical will come
in a couple of weeks,
go out a couple of weeks. Yeah,
and if you don't have all the designs
built, built in your system set up,
releasing it was hard.
Set up, they get you 22 days,
22 working days to build one and then
they pay a premium for 10 day build or
five days.
And it's just a game of managing the
logistics of it. Yeah,
you just have to have.
10 truckloads of four post border sitting
out there.
It's got to happen and then you need all
three eights play.
It's. I've done it three times.
I've never made money.
By the time you get set up about a year
and a half later,
they just ramp it down and some new
management team says let's do it again.
It's like.
Never going to work because you don't
ramp up fast enough to make to get in the
sweet spot to where you're comfortable.
Well, a lot of it's almost manufacturing.
It is manufacturing. Yeah,
it's absolutely.
Doing it,
I've only seen one fabricator that got a
job with a lot of repeatability on it and
just they just needs to be efficiency.
Yeah, they get everything.
They're like we are not there.
And then figure out how to go.
We're telling them how to go.
We're setting up all the gigs we're
setting up and they killed it. But most,
most publicators don't seem to get to
that level, but do you work for J.
So I think they have a structural shop in
Kansas City,
but they're doing some festivals or we
had a shop in the back of CO where.
You're paying dollars $2.00 per month.
Holy cow. So we were doing the bottom.
I mean, it felt completely came apart.
This was a test. Yeah,
they were just bailing left and right.
We got that.
They shut that contract down and all of a
sudden, yeah.
Multiple people not complying to things
in the PDX area.
There's no pedestals for you.
I don't know if it's but either pedestals
or.
Doing like the data center platforms and
whatnot. Yeah,
I that I can imagine that it's the
pencils are pretty specific.
They have a lot of features. Yeah,
a lot of drilling at the end of the day,
it's a stump.
If you ever been a chip fab,
all the utilities are on this floor and
all the tools are on this floor.
So they set these tools on these two foot
tall tables with all the utilities.
So these.
Tables are pretty complicated cut outs.
I know I know one I here in Arizona.
Yeah, I know. And there's one of them.
It's not like they're.
Be a huge deal of things.
They're shipping them all loaded boys.
I appreciate it. Anything.
Every single time.
Somebody gives me something.
You're a good guy. Not by choice. Yeah.
If I if I have the freedom to choose
whether I can get glue or not,
that is definitely not for that is.
15 when I was diagnosed slow.
So after that, free little became, uh,
that's a busy dude for you when you have
glutamine. I have an autoimmune response.
I like blood cells attack my stomach
lying when it intestines.
I figure it was stiff. That sucks.
What's that?
A lot of people say it's from the GMO.
It's all the genetically modified foods
we got.
Our body just can't recognize the the
greens and and all the different things
they do to them anymore.
It confuses your immune system.
Well,
that would kind of explain why you see
more today. Yeah,
we were kids 30 or 40 years ago, yeah.
We need stuff.
Second and dish out.
Show.
And there's been bringing the gifts. No,
we will speak.
Problem.
I had. We were,
we were a little bit changing banks.
So I know one guy came in and he's like,
here's your presence.
Please consider. Yeah, that's bonkers.
Holy moly.
That's dedication and it's finance. Yeah.
And I left two of them. Wow. Holy crap.
Well,
I guess they're certain of what they're
supplying. They're they don't have.
I'm really enjoying that my daughter is,
she's 21. She's still,
she's still at home right now,
but she's old enough to where she likes
buying gifts.
And so I don't buy a single gift at
Christmas anymore. She's like,
who do you want to get bought?
Well, I don't know.
We bought some unusual cords.
Makes me look good. There you go. Good.
That's what you're done.
Yeah, I'm not. I'm not.
I spent over $1000 to get home from
holidays, so I was like.
Your gift is my presence. Yeah,
so I'll be home for 9 days, Minnesota.
So you buy yourself a Frontier Airplane's
car, the most uncomfortable airplane,
like if you buy that.
Annual pass. How do you do?
All you pay is the taxes.
So I've been applying back and forth
between here in Vegas for the last seven
months, $15.31 a flight.
They just had a sale and it cost $299 for
the year.
Package, right.
So it's $299 a year and I think $15.
31 a flight. Utah was the same. Oh,
you find it here because I was like,
I thought we should do that for Tucson,
but it doesn't help her. Yeah, yeah, no,
you find a gateway, right? No, definitely.
Frontiers have been in Vegas or Utah with
something about 15-16 bucks each stage
flight. I don't think they'll do too soon.
I have Vietnam. That's nice frontier goal.
It's like sitting on a bucket, man.
It's they're not so much of hard rocks.
When they cancel their flights,
they're done. Yeah,
the whole thing to that is you got to
take the morning or mid-morning flights.
All the evening flights,
they're always either delayed or
cancelled.
I never had to wait twice in seven months
and delayed me probably.
15.9 I was stranded in Seattle.
I got to the airport and I'm in security
like.
Your plan is new. What are you doing?
It's curious. Well, what the? No,
you didn't get the e-mail. Yeah,
there's my e-mail. Cool. My rider.
So I'll figure out what I'm going to do.
Yeah,
I'm going to talk about I've got a while
from here. They get canceled. Yeah,
that is pretty. That's weather cheap.
I flew to San Diego.
And then when I finally got on the plane,
we get down and they reverse the jets and
everything and the whole place.
I might survive this longer.
Yeah, I I have an orange County,
California too.
More bumps and rabbits on those ones.
They've seen a few, a few fights.
I fly there and they were done.
Just got a struggle in the American dumps.
I don't have the everywhere,
so that's good.
I fly some country all the time.
Southern country.
I react and they're they're have done in
Minnesota. So I get.
Yeah,
my flight was the expense department from
holidays and it's getting my two dogs
watched here back home.
I used to be oil in the Southwest,
but I got a daughter-in-law of a bunch of
dogs.
They've changed less than seven or eight
times.
Yeah, that's what I hear. Yeah,
the prices have become the same as
American. Yeah,
I just like if I go to the American city,
I fly American, you know, go to Salt Lake,
I fly Delta.
I go to Houston to fly United or.
Bill is really nice, really nice everyone.
I have funded it while I just,
I I can't give up my status of American
that I got now.
It's it's always going to be, yeah,
I need to place out with that,
so I have clear.
Elite member or whatever it is.
I actually got the points I have.
So this year I have three companions that.
So anywhere I put my flight,
but I did all that before I started the
frontier things.
That'll be up to this year.
I get bumped up first class a lot.
And so I'll be like, wait,
I'll be up there. Well,
they'll come get you, right?
Because they'll, if they got a seat,
they'll find out who's the highest ranked
person.
Yeah, steroids will fill you up.
If I'm not, if I don't get in first class,
if I don't get bumped up, then I'll,
I'll walk by first class and I'll see
somebody up there.
If I see a kid or something sitting there
smishing something, I'll earn that seat.
It makes a lot of difference in the world.
Oh, it makes a huge difference,
especially when you're flying from one
side of the US. Yeah,
you're out there for hours now. Yeah,
flying out here,
a little over 4 hour flight from
Charlotte and I got first bus on the way
out here. Yeah, that one would fly.
I didn't make any.
Most of my advice would be hours. So yeah,
I'm in here. Yeah,
that's that's probably good.
Yes, this one.
Well, I've got a lot too, do you?
But when I travel to the Pacific
Northwest,
I've probably lived in Seattle for the
longest time. You know,
I'm a long distance girlfriend.
So there's no. Why not?
They're all paying time. Long distance,
girlfriend. That's hard to do.
I just created a long distance.
I live here 3 days a week,
four days a week. Yeah, yeah,
it's it's interesting.
We see each other most month now though,
so yeah.
It.
I had a funeral with my Brown on Monday
and people out here,
we flew back to Minnesota together,
went to the funeral together.
He got a flight back to Seattle.
I kind of flight back here. Yeah,
see him for a day or two.
That's nice.
Who's file is correct in any office from
here? Some country does.
The.
About 3 hours appointments.
I used to go to Wisconsin.
Couple times I went through Chicago and
American never made it.
Always got bogged down to Chicago.
I finally said I drove here,
flew up on Allegiant direct flight to the
Janesville. I was like, yeah,
that's what I'm going to do from now on.
Yeah, because you can't.
That Chicago airport is horrible. Yeah,
I've refused to connect through it.
The one that I'm having much trouble out
on the status,
I've gotten started in more times than
not in Dallas. It's. I hate that airport,
but it's the biggest American hub, so.
If there's a lady on the West Coast,
I'm going to be in Dallas.
Yeah,
my dad wouldn't be interested about here
is in Florida.
He almost never can find a connector in
the red flag.
Florida and here it's always, you know,
that's a.
And Delta actually flies direct at land
too, yeah.
That wasn't too bad. I love Seatac.
Seatac has so much stuff in it.
That's and they're completely doing a
bunch of it.
So it's nice to live in there.
There's a couple areas that are.
Flow off by San Francisco. Yeah,
what I think about Seatac is going to
security there to go to Canada.
Some of those lines, I mean,
the reason I got Century is to avoid that
**** if you don't have a Century.
Sea tax lines to go to fly to Canada are
just, I mean, just you could be there now.
Last time I I may I get satisfied here
and maybe they had a a different thing,
but they had seven different TSA
checkpoints.
For one area, right.
And that would get you to gates AB and C
and but yeah,
I mean now you know it's this,
it's this customs clearance, right?
Now if you have Global Entry,
you don't even almost need to stop
walking. You can just walk right through.
Facial recognition gets you,
you just walk right through.
So that solves that problem if you don't
have it.
Pre-check now is getting to be.
There's so many people.
It's crazy a few months ago.
I had the kids pre-check.
I'm going to get clear because I sat on
for 45 minutes and days got ****** ***.
I got to get clear and I get clear and
it's pretty short still.
I hope that it's clear because Charlotte
doesn't act clear. If Charlotte gets it,
then I'll do it. But.
That whole thing is such a freaking
hustle.
Yeah,
it's still the the TSA pre-check goes
goes pretty fast. You know,
it seems like you know like 10 people in
London going to that TSA pre-check,
but couple of times there is a long line
and it came clear.
I hate when it's clear people get in
front of it. So yeah.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah,
we must have flied another light once
'cause the lines are so long trying to
get through, yeah.
I'm on the way to the airport for 30
hours. As soon as I get a net channel,
I'll start traveling. Yeah,
don't be wrong.
Last week I flew out at Salt Lake to
their home and.
I had a red eye, which I hate,
and I actually got done really early with
the client.
So I had about 11 hours before my flight
and so there were a couple of flights I
might get on. So I went on to the airport.
I actually sat in that airport for 11
hours.
I mean, what are you?
You're leaving here at 3:46?
What time do you get back to the shop?
So yeah, about 35. No,
I'll put it back later cause it's 3:46.
Plus you've got to go.
Plus you've had three hours, 7 hours.
So my flight leaves here 341.
I I land at 938. Of course, going back,
it's faster because you catch the catch
the wind, yeah, but.
41 at home, so yeah, it's about 404.
Do you live directly in Charlotte?
I live out there in Bath, Charlotte, so.
A good friend of mine,
he moved from Phoenix to Houston.
He works for Ferguson and then I just
moved back to Raleigh and his wife's
family is there and parents need care.
Yeah, that's about.
Two hours instead of moving. Yeah,
I think we're pretty happy we live in
Houston.
So you're planning to move here or you
want to keep doing this or you can go
back and forth.
All depends on if they want to build a
shop, if they want to do something,
where they want to do it.
Keep being told it's not going to be here.
I get the sense of let's look at the
assets we have and try and.
Make those more productive.
I get a sense there's some of that
happened.
I mean, there's so much binding work.
You know, semi bond is busy here,
but there's data centers are doing this
thing.
I didn't work in Arizona's in the mining
state. So much work in mining coming here.
We're not really set up to do.
Finding scale.
Yeah.
What's their next closest shop?
Other than the manate shop? Do you hear?
Like what state? Bloomfield. Yeah,
Bloomfield, NM, just on Durango. Yeah,
just on the coast.
What is it at the drive up there?
It's pretty small.
I think most of their stuff's like back
and stuff. That's right.
I don't have a lot of equipment.
It's smaller than here.
What's the next one after that? Casper.
As I said, Casper,
they have something in Texas too.
I haven't heard about that at all.
I see it on the map.
What do they do in Casper, you know?
Oh.
I think there are all pipe fitters out
there too.
A lot of them are existing stuff.
So pipe fitters,
their Montana shop is supposedly set up
pretty well to get a new light structural.
I hear there's not. I mean,
the report that Chris said,
there's hardly any you're putting it out
either. Yeah, yeah.
Where we do a bit closer because that
barely.
Well, I think there's there's thoughts.
There's there's a structural shock. Yeah,
really.
I didn't notice that when I walked in
yesterday, but I think that's the thought.
Could be, could be, but it's it's pretty.
They got,
they got a plastic cutter out there.
They got a roller.
They just got to come out there and eat
it with a stick.
They got a little tiny press break and a
little tiny shear.
That's the extended instruction. Oh,
and I have the one that just counts.
That's the extended instructions that
they have here.
So you forgot to mention that every time
we use our breaks,
we use our shear breaks.
No,
I can't even run it at it's actual
capacity.
The capacity they want it's derated so
much so.
And I'm having a break. What's that?
Iron worker? No, I didn't see it. Oh, OK.
Yeah,
it's jump up their angles and fly bars.
Yeah.
But mostly the flat light,
but the ain't going in the CPC.
There's one that's working with it, yeah.
That's like a low hate relationship with
that thing is.
I will go out and then the whole machine
will lose calibration.
And then be like, well,
why don't you turn the machine off? What?
You know what your machine up at the end
of the day? Well, for batteries,
you shouldn't set your machine up. Well,
we didn't know that the battery wasn't
working.
We've had this machine for for barely 2
years. Why are the batteries working?
No.
Yeah.
We'll make it work, yeah.
So what's going here like 10 million here?
I think at least the goal is to do at
least 30 million next year.
So it's going to take a little bit. Yeah,
we've got to sell.
You might have got to get equipment to do,
go do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, it has. We just need somebody to.
Now we're confident.
Never justifiable recently.
Working and going anywhere in the valley.
Well, The thing is,
is this job that we're going to be
installed along.
I don't know who estimated it.
They estimated bidders back or
subcontract,
but the jobs are actually being shipped
from then.
That's just what's not mine.
It's like somebody in the land won this
job,
and I think they won it because they
didn't bring the job.
But there's no reason that a shop in the
land should be competitive here, here and.
Just outside just north of Phoenix and
Clarksdale.
Ouch.
But I think that's what everybody's
saying.
There's no reason like if I think in the
pipeline,
if we were to look at what's in that type
of sales pipeline,
if they can self perform, you can just.
Farm that out.
The question I have is how quickly can we
look to the sales pipeline to see
anything else?
I don't think we're ever going to be able
to. Everest too strong work.
Bechtel is just not going to be a job
that fits here for.
A lot.
I think you can see what they do with
that one. Me too. Yeah.
And Bechtel's a bullet.
Bechtel's a difficult customer.
Everybody's worked for Bechtel.
I don't know. Oh, they're brutal. I mean,
documentation. I look at,
I look at the drawings. They got,
they got some open welds.
It's not too bad.
Nothing really unusual about it.
But it's for years that it's like, oh,
the pipe racks are just like this call to
the baby crisis, you know? So it's pretty.
But I think the trick is job,
but I don't think we're set up here to do
it.
You get the drawings in November 26th and
you got to deliver 7000 tons in March of
27. Yeah, that's.
Well,
it just means that some they haven't.
They're they're not even ready to at
least because they don't.
They didn't have them.
Yeah, I was asking, can we have the Tekla?
I mean, I stopped. Yeah,
the time is pretty fun too.
It's like really good to tell this size
in that short period of time.
They gave it to us a week ago and then I
did yesterday or day before the other day.
So the truth of that is that thing if you
look at the.
You know, I don't know if you've seen the,
I haven't seen that effort.
So we sat on and I think like 2 months,
yeah, I don't know if I can see that,
but I think it actually came from
somebody from Denver.
That heard about this and look,
I don't think it was here.
I think it was stuck somewhere else and
then they gave an extension till the 22nd,
like March when they got to the 22nd to
put the bid in.
So how are we going to make it better
today?
Or not. It's just a bidding exercise.
People are going to find out that Bechtel
shops well and there's going to be.
This is my gut feeling.
I was trying to figure out what the
closest historical shop was to be.
'Cause there's not much out there.
Salt Lake City must have a good
fabrication SMV. That's Salt Lake City.
I mean, they probably are.
It's probably the preferred shot.
It's so close. Yeah,
I don't believe you think so.
So send them all over.
That's really has enough backlog right
now. Yeah, but I'm we'll see her.
Maybe I'm close to backlog too.
Yeah, yeah, that is.
They had one really busy shop and I went
like eight or nine months ago.
I was in the shop in Salt Lake and I went
to actually just have that.
Then I went to the in Nevada after I
didn't take the job in Salt Lake and they.
I was already working in Nevada.
I can be there at the what's it called
Southwest.
So I went there and I toured that shop
and talked with them and they kind of
laughed and said I'm not even looking for
the people that are hiring to meet them.
OK.
See, yeah.
And I know they have one up here too.
And maybe they got a shop here. Yeah,
they have a shop here.
It's way too far away from my house.
It's like, all right, I have two hours.
It's out there. I need some money.
Wait it all like, no, I'm not going there.
So there's in in Salt Lake,
just a little South of Salt Lake.
It's something called.
I actually wanted me to manage their
their their TSMC jobs. OK,
I don't want to drive to TSMC every day
either.
These aren't is there structural ceiling
plate, which is north of Salt Lake,
where I was last week.
JT Steel is literally about two blocks
from that setting. I really like this,
so they do.
I have a little bit of work out,
but these are when I was in the Fresno
government, right?
We need some like this stuff.
So I need to be sorry. What's that?
What do you think these are?
I thought, you know,
art in the name had something to do with
welding, but it's not. When I did this,
is everybody told me crazy?
You think that the attorneys are correct?
This says CRZCR.
You know, I like that. There you go.
That's what you're seeing.
I know.
Yeah, it's getting a great even want.
I want to do business with them.
But they want to sell us plate with a
semi truck load.
Who's that Friedman Industries and we
don't. It'd be one thing if we took plate,
sold it to the job.
For usage, but usually we're buying job.
So these guys want us to buy and we're
getting, you know,
it doesn't have to be one whole semi
truckload of one size. That's fine.
I mean,
I don't have time to run like I need.
896 two 40s quarter range,
896 two 40s and 3688 and I like that's
kind of wild and they got insane.
One inch through through 316.
I think that's the lowest they go.
They'll sell me 964 is at 46 cents a
pound delivered.
And what is like Smith sell?
They're around 64 to 67,
so that's not Texas.
They'll deliver it cause they got trucks
coming into the valley and they'll.
And give it to me at that price,
which is great.
I just can't justify the freaking plate.
I don't have and that's kind of why I'm
pushing to get this in the process
because if I can have a solid plate,
I just start selling parts for the jobs
and track usages and then.
Divide and conquer and skeleton
definitely.
But at least I've got a good plate
inventory I can plug cost into and and
then quote it out to myself. Yeah,
and and do kind of an internal thing.
I mean, that sounds all very good.
I want to use the word easy,
but I don't want to use it.
I don't think this is really a a super,
super simple system. Yeah, I I,
I that's why I picked up super quick.
So yeah, they do have the best data.
Yeah,
of all of the I've heard that they put
good things that they're like the best
there is.
Yeah, that's the thing though.
He beats everybody's prices here.
And then I go to the ACCV and I'll have
this guy who's getting 26 cents a volume.
You have the structural.
So how's that work though? Well,
they pick up our material,
take it over their gown and I can bring
back. So it's really affecting us,
but maybe we have a they get stuff across
the board.
But my issue,
I don't be able to act the trucks to get
that done.
There's there's times where like it'll
get moving up in customs if we have one
extra piece up and then they also behind
all the MTRS.
ACZ that I have, by the way,
you added two extra visas because there
was nothing good to go.
That's going to stop me.
So my problem with it is either they
don't usually get back to me, you know,
I can't find out stuff, you know,
you got to have a couple names to call.
Oscar and somebody else is like,
it's like, yeah, I don't know.
Ours is pretty good. Yeah, pretty good.
Back and forth with them. That's good,
I'd say.
Good portion of all my projects this year.
Really. So and then even, I mean,
they stored materials at their facility
for us for also the two months.
Are they the ones that are in the area?
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I've got. Our next,
the next level. Yep,
they're in the back end or something.
I mean,
they've been around for forever as far as
I know. So, yeah, well, they got that.
I'm already expecting to heard that.
I heard the whole Mexico thing.
I've never heard that.
I think they're what, Mexicani? Yeah,
yeah,
Mark and Rabino and Chris all the way
down there into the facility down in
Mexico.
In that it it sounds like they run up the
far. They keep all the,
they keep all the workers,
they have stores for them in there,
so they keep the guys healthy and
everything's all running to the T in
there, very organized.
This is still trust the.
Stuff leaving our facility sometimes, so.
There was a while there we got into the
thick of the gravel because we couldn't
get a damn truck raid, so that was there.
Looks like your maintenance expired on
1/30/25. Yeah, that was a while ago.
Reinstates maintenance,
one of the set price 2025.
I'll maintenance.
It's be on bottom and post as they can be
directed to Papa Connector based on the
training technical support.
The only thing I also need is the.
Cutting edge, cutting.
I want all of their modules.
There's been no reason my brother
shouldn't have every module possible
unless my machine is restricted on that.
Oh, that was pretty close.
I told him to be about 16 grams,
so I'm guessing once they add on the on
the add. Mark's copy of this one.
My guess is we'll probably get this one
replaced tomorrow, so in theory,
depending on how long.
This process goes to and might be able to
get this stuff pushed me on Friday. Yeah,
awesome.
We can get a little chunk out of it, so.
But you know, that'll work.
Let's do a quick test and see if we can
get into port 307.
That's.
That.
Go back to your um.
That picture's really there.
One thing that I'm questioning here is
the text about if I directly left bottom
right doesn't have it directly.
That points to where the program actually
is. I mean it it could be like mine.
I have. I can run multiple versions,
so that points to which version I want to
be running for that database.
It may be with only one,
it just force the right one.
I don't notice it,
but it's just different than mine.
So.
So he said,
I don't see any reason why it would be a
different be a recipe because same server,
same.
Unless it's just not about,
I mean they can have, they can start it,
but I mean they can create it and not
start the service.
That might be the the other thing.
While I was trying to pull the picture
back up.
Please follow up.
So you see that Bob or stop service yards.
So usually it's just like,
but that was whatever that was.
So I think I don't know. Yeah,
that was this morning.
So I mean the iterations work there.
Yeah, I mean.
I mean, that's it.
Hey.
See you in the college.
So for have we submitted everything for?
Yeah.
This is probably a crunch. It's it's the.
Yeah, you're asking me to look where?
I think just that port or that IP address
is not.
But.
I love you.
Are you just testing the imports?
Right.
But it's.
What's the default? 15 and six? Yeah,
15 and six. It is one gives us an.
Hello.
I see.
Yeah, he just wants to go on the tool.
I think you should be very good.
Diversity of IT.
That's seems to be the problem there.
I was used to the luxury of just walking
out of certainly, yeah, I guess that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Two, I got a 12.
What a combo. Yeah, two different ones.
Yeah, I love that you're here,
but you did.
Yeah.
Ball and that was a normal Blue Healer.
He's uh.
When you're when you're eight months.
The development of a,
we'll be able to kind of bring them down
in some ways. Yeah, definitely got to.
If we were building, face and energy.
I love that dog,
but I've just never owned it.
That's why I want the place a little bit
bigger yard.
20 acres so they can just go wrong.
I.
You'll share.
OK, cool. Yeah, that's my new one.
My first one made me want another one in
my second. It seems we have a lot other.
All right, look at this. Excuse me,
thank you very much. What's up, man?
I'm running an official name here.
Why you got an exam?
I meant the other things, but uh,
it was more automatic.
So that's actually we're waiting for IT
is probably restarting the server because
we're having the server connection should
be in like, yeah, yeah,
the next one is our regular ones working
just fine.
It's just this new port and not having to
talk with it so.
But we can at least go over kind of.
What items you're looking for in there,
I'm assuming probably pretty similar to
like the ROQ stuff we've been known for
wire.
We want to get a place of wire broke out
in there and cages and and purchase of
the lengths of the wire and then
purchasable items for.
I guess bio items for electrical stuff
and that I hopefully will never happen to
the wire again because it's extremely
stressful or in to.
But then you only have like 100 feet to
drop. But yeah, boom. Um on.
I mean it's like 47,000 feet. But um,
the idea, the biggest,
the biggest concept um is.
We're putting a lot of effort within BIM
modeling on the electrical side from,
let's just say,
just supports right from any standards
from.
The level of detail we're having to go
through for a lot of these models is.
I mean it's it's an LD 400,
so it's we're modeling nuts and washers,
right,
as we're getting it's pretty accurate.
So since we're putting such a cost into
doing this,
I want to be able to leverage the
abilities that we have within Tekla from
a nesting and assembly tracking
standpoint.
So that we can actually run it through as
this if it were a structural building,
right?
And where I'm running into is it's where
all the assemblies are for the most part
unique from a strut length and a rod
length.
But from the grand scheme of things,
there's only like 10 different types of
designs.
Realistically what we're doing and then,
but everything's done from Revit.
So if I do just an IFC export out of
Revit, I lose all of my metadata.
So I don't really know that it's a people.
I don't know it's half the draw,
it's just a body shape there, right? Yeah.
So what I've been working on is within
Reddit,
I can actually create a BOM that has a
set parameters in it and we can actually
create an Excel spreadsheet that defines
what those are and if we can leverage
that Excel spreadsheet where we can bring
that into Tekla.
Tekla doesn't need to know that it's the
exact body from the model standpoint.
They just need to know how to correlate
it to a P1000, right?
And so if we can come up with that system
and figure out a way to carry those cut
lengths and just the overall assembly
types.
I think we could just treat it as if it
were a fabric and we can still do our
RFQs, we can still do nestings,
we can still do assembly, shippings,
everything like that.
And so our electric prefab where we're
talking,
I mean thousands of trapeze supports.
We can, you know,
do the same thing where the saw operator
only needs to care about his cutlass
basically given that day. Yeah.
And then go from there.
So that's like the big picture design of
what we're trying to accomplish. So I can.
So they're so you're make sure I
understand someone will repeat back what
I think I understand.
You're looking to,
you're working on exporting out to do
Excel.
We get the right format to bring in here,
then we will do the next thing and order
the next thing and everything exactly.
So we can consider bringing a kiss file,
I think, and I'm not set on Excel files,
but.
And it's been the easiest thing that we
can clearly define what that material is
is from itself and then and then I've
developed it's been working so far as my
gaming convention on like a a.
TR1 is the single tier trippy support and
then we come up with you know.
All the they're all usually typically
rods and then like AB would be in the top
end connection would be a beam plant on
one side and like a big half inch spring
nut on the other side or something. Yeah,
I can show you.
But I think cause I can build a VOM
within Revit to meet whatever parameters
we need. Yeah,
but then I can give you the import table.
OK and it it has a lot of lot of fields
on it and I'll show you the ones that are.
The required here,
the nice part is what you guys were doing
with like the material database is
especially on strat.
It's the same thing we did on Eagle is
you're gonna have just a standard key
1000 P 1001 and they're pretty unique
shapes and then.
We're talking, you know, yeah,
my scene for code and there's not those
things,
but there's there's not a lot of big
field that we have to create.
That's possible in my head.
But we're we're spending so much money
just to get to the level of detail that
are are a lot of our binge requirements
we're installing,
we're required to install within eight to
what we want.
So at least you're whereas after you can
view from a a design execution so.
We might as well be fabricating it to.
And So what I what we've done in the past
so far is like I would send the these
guys just a a list of strut links right
or a list of raw links or anything like
that and they just kind of mainly put it
in and then give you a a deliverable back.
Um,
but definitely want to take it a step
further on.
Probably having those sizes to be
portable, yeah.
And then I still think we just have the
flexibility of doing the one offs like
this wire thing, yeah.
And because I don't think that's anything
we want to build into our system as far
as wire links, it's.
This is just kind of a one-off deal.
We're we're pretty much talking about
linear, linear stuff. Yes, Sir.
It's not a nesting of a plate or anything.
No, it's not a width length like things.
It's just a linear length.
And then we just bring our, you know,
curves down to, you know,
as it's like a sheer nesting.
Like it's theoretically not, you know,
we don't have, you know,
curved cuts on the wire, right? Yeah. Um.
Certainly looked at this, it's been,
I've been working on it.
I just haven't got to the point of the
import side that we spend trying to get
our because Revit,
Revit's it's a different thought approach
on how you build your assemblies and it's
their family approach so.
It's you have to kind of have everything
complete set up beforehand and it's not
as to me.
It's definitely useful in a in a prefab
application as in a tech, but.
It's the industry standard for doing
mechanical design.
And then all the other softwares that
I've researched on how other flexible
jobs do it. Yeah,
and they're bringing the Revit,
but then it's very,
it's very cumbersome compared to.
Like one stop stop, the tech,
like they're still doing their RFQ's and
combining in a separate ERP.
They're still not leveraging them
estimating like we're.
I would spend all we're doing is the
trial of the what we've got and there's
something there out there that's built
for the from what you're saying that's
sounds too great.
There's there's the program,
there's one other software out there that
that you actually.
I would say combine better, yeah.
And it's only really useful though when
you're trying to actually recap like
things to conduits that you know and then
also like routing an entire room to have
it more suited for that. Yeah,
but it's not still not producing cut
lists, still not.
Nesting and just treating it like BLM and
being able to refine like assembly to the
shippable. Yeah, it doesn't cover.
Like I said,
the purchasing doesn't cover any of the
labor tracking,
doesn't cover the shipping. So well,
it sounds like from what you're
describing.
We'll make this work and it's because
it's our prefab based that they're
primarily doing everything almost 100%
just trapezes and basic supports because
a lot of stuff we're doing is is single
conduit runs.
It's nothing that we need to prefab.
I think you'll bank and get it out to the
field. Yeah, they think they're doctor.
I'm gonna hear it.
It's like this means like we could easily
implement and then and then the nice part
is too is that I think it's gonna give us
the flexibility that like.
Same thing would be. So if you get it,
it's just like then it gives us the
flexibility that we can route it to
separate shops. So like say, yeah,
the shops slow down,
we can route all of our shop processing
here and we can have largely bundle cuts.
Yeah,
they can do final assembly in that shop,
yeah.
I mean because we we did all of those
healthy frames, right.
And that would have been we could have
leveraged that at the lecture shop or we
could have done it here,
we could have done some here, some there.
But yeah, because it's our lecture shops.
More,
more geared towards the higher volume
stuff, but we got the bigger and so.
So here's the spreadsheets I've been
producing so far.
I was 72 grand. It's starting.
Yeah, I think until Keith does something.
Yeah.
Mercy.
There's really nothing, you know,
like if they ask,
there's nothing you have to do on the
sequel end.
Or permissioning and or any of that as
long as it's true from saying on the
address. So it's really.
They said that's supposed to be switched
to port number and then we just pop right
in. Yeah,
'cause it's all set up in the same
instance as the other server. Yeah,
we're pinged into that.
All very good teams.
So this would be probably one of our
higher volume type products for like a
data center.
So it's definitely a lot more of the same
assemblies, but same concept.
I don't know why it's it would just be
large number of of.
You need some of them versus by the lines
to go to the last page again.
And then so pretty much with the set up
for the pretab guys since you have,
you go to the top.
Assembly types and then gives you your
actual,
you know parameters of what dimensions
what and then those kind of or correlate
down to this chart charts based off of.
So that first one,
so the charts based off of your tier one
tracks and then respond label.
Um,
your lane was gonna be your strut length.
It's up there. Yep.
And then 5 inch or 5/8 so I can fix that
down to like the key 1000 and I can, yeah,
change those and then.
Broadway, broad side.
So they're all the parameters are in
there. Yeah.
And we build this however we need to
organize it.
And then I can also relabel everything.
And all I have to really do is when we
kick off a job to say, hey,
these are the this is how we need family
to look and yeah, we establish all.
Of our actuals of sizes where kind of
like our detailed standards of it needs
to say P1000 Tab of team, you know,
kind of thing. So the solutions, yeah, so.
Scroll back up to the.
So that's what's what's described in me,
right?
So the T1 EC 100000 is the whole assembly,
is that correct? Correct.
OK. When you you were to don't need to,
but if you were to the plan view and look
at where those are labeled out,
you'll see that that label call out, OK.
So that means that are assembly. OK.
And then the components within that.
Or it makes me the rod side of the path
in the tree, I'm assuming. So OK,
I see RR1RF30.
So that's if that's it.
I tried to build this.
There is some instances where you would
have 3 supporters on one shuttling.
So yeah,
you don't actually see anything on these.
We're just trying to sign for worst case,
but this one really only has R1 and R2 OK
position. Yeah,
have any that that actually.
Did move in different and yeah,
I need to adjust it like my zeros are
technically actually like a standard one
inch. So basically we would be.
Yeah,
you're talking about the like on on that
one, you're talking about four assemblies.
So you've got 8 rods that are two foot
long, correct? The ones that are,
the ones that are two, right?
So to get that in the tech one.
Hello.
So required fields are quantity,
drawing number, main mark, piece mark,
description, grade, length.
So that needed assembly.
I'm thinking we're going to do a.
Hello.
A label. So the strut,
it's instruct type 158 single.
Is that bought as is? Is that cut?
Is that what is that?
That's got to be cut.
That's one in 5/8, about 1 foot six. OK,
OK, so I mean, with the tech,
with the technical terminology,
I'm thinking about the Stratus
maintenance, right?
And then you've got an R1 and an R2 as
parts,
but it can't be called R1 and R2 because
all of those are different links.
All those are the ones that are user
different links. Yeah, so.
Would be R100R1R200 with your labels
000R1 and then R1001. Yeah, R1002.
And then if any are the same same length
of R1 and R2,
I guess you can technically interchange
those,
but to keep them in the assembly format,
probably easier to keep them named per.
Yeah, so,
but technically it's what we have in our
database, our regular fab database.
With the P1 thousands and this having raw,
I would think they'd be able to run this
will be half in here. Yeah,
because that's why they're shifting by
hours.
I can't because I have to create unique
assemblies that are,
they call them families, right? Yeah,
a family for it.
I can't really try to do a way that I can
go through and combine all like links.
Yeah, to call it a new, right?
So if if there's a way within our nesting
zone.
But we can if we could combine like links
together, even though they'd be unique.
Yeah,
we could still leverage with like a
bundle cut. Yeah, and yeah, I mean that.
And then as the guys bundle cut, you know,
whatever quantities that we show of two
footers,
they would just go in and just say, OK.
I would just put all my 2 foot lengths in
a pile. Yeah.
And then as the assemblers come and say,
OK, I need to make a T1 EC one,
then you just go to the two foot bin and
pull out their R102 and reassembly. Yeah,
because what I'm trying to get away from.
Is.
I'm trying to utilize our columns on our
stick out because we have a a min Max to
be able to round up all of our family
links. Yeah,
I'm trying to get to like 4 inch
increments,
but I think we're only gonna be able to
get to the one inch just so that matching.
You know,
shop guys with fraction marks and yeah,
and attritions with fractions. It's yeah,
so yeah, so I get it. Um,
so that's a running function that we'll
do in the BLM when we export.
So we shouldn't technically have to to
deal with any of that, but.
Yes, is all the same material.
Is the material type like obstruct the
same material type items?
Not always,
but you're gonna have releases are gonna
be typically done in by by area.
So like classified areas are gonna all be
stainless,
stainless and then once you get into you
know exterior it'll be or something like
that.
So will that need to be in this table or
is that given globally somewhere else?
We wouldn't.
I would assume that when I define my
strut type,
we would expand that out to just feed the
actual P1000 number. OK.
And then that would be like P1000. Yeah,
that's three, yeah.
And then that would be defined into the
the grid.
So the struts are all in the strut.
Correct. OK. What about the rods?
Are they always the same thing or is
there different types of material for
them? You would have,
you would have different grades available
depending on. That's right.
So you know we can use rod that's in
there as the shape.
And then create a strut shed,
which we should already have here.
It's a carrier right here. OK, OK,
which cause we we were doing like multi
trade racks,
probably over the old one in the previous.
Yeah right so.
And again, it's kind of.
We were getting to different.
I had some that we were designing within
Revit,
which the design of the unit of the
Revit's very simple.
Everything architecture pieces are all
kind of already family, yeah.
But it was a pain when we needed these
guys to actually fabricate them.
And it was kind of a they're treated as a
structure component.
They're designing the. Yeah, yeah.
And so we did a lot.
That's where I think the database has got.
Pretty messy,
but I was doing some within Revit and I
was doing some within. Yeah,
actually advanced steel.
The majority of we did those ones.
Is that the same advanced steel with this
actual steel? Yeah, it's a it's a.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
It doesn't align well with here. Notice,
like, believe it or not,
they're they're expulsion terrible. Yeah.
What sucks is it's an Autodesk product
that doesn't work with Gabit and it
doesn't work with with either.
It kind of just stuck it out there and
said we're not doing anything with this
anymore.
Cheats the exactly,
but it's it's really nice.
It's just like within like Eco Structure
where you can build families out and do
the same thing within. Yeah,
so it's it set up right. It works great,
but they're talking about end of lifing
it and turning it into a plug in for
Revit. Yeah, so.
In that case,
that could possibly solve a lot of my
other issues. Um, but.
Yeah, I'll get one. I'll get on in here.
Maybe it would be cleaning it up so you
can just have one specific call out for
each. Yeah, just because we have,
I mean one in five days back-to-back,
one in five days,
one in five days solid and then.
1000 and P 1000, so well, that's yeah,
that part of our actual kickoff was
technically they're all.
They're all very similar in the P1
thousands,
but you have actual unit thread that's
different than PHD callouts and how they
do theirs. So different manufacturers,
they're they're somewhat interchangeable,
but also kind of the specs. But I can,
I can definitely that's something easy I
think to clean up on how we do.
That so something really nice that I just
figured out.
We should figure out how to get a
different fees on the drive.
That's what my thought is.
I've got it figured out on how to what's
available,
what we can leverage from Revit.
I think you just need to start from what
tech will accept and I can build.
Of the BUNS to accommodate, so go to um.
On the background here to close this and
hit technical user assistance at the
bottom and then search for Excel
important.
They're being one for production control
in EDC.
So the.
Not all of these fields are needed.
You tell them whatever you want to,
but drawing number, benchmark, piece mark,
quality shape. Yep,
that's what we require.
So if you can get it in this format,
it may be able to do it where shape and
dimension are in the same field.
I think there's a big core type for that.
So if it's not split out of shape and
dimension separate, but.
But I guess you're really not defined in
shape in the spreadsheet anyway, are you?
So no, I mean,
those would be defined down to just, yeah,
the unistrutter.
So that's that's pretty much it.
And you you can use in the fields that
you want to.
Like if you want a category, sub category,
whatever you want to,
you can use these titles,
but but that so I would imagine the strut,
the drawing main mark piece mark would be
the same.
And the strut would be there on where
they do 72 is and then your rods would be
drawing number and main mark would be the
same as the strut and the piece mark
would be the R1.
You know you get bridge with it somehow.
Or one next year, year, year,
whatever you want to do with it.
And then it should. I mean,
we could call a few in here and just
important and see what happens.
If that works, yeah,
you want to talk real quick, yeah.
Take a message.
If you have a an export,
you can try to import it.
You want to just take one of the line
items off of that drawing when you're
looking at.
Yeah, like that P1HC100 or something.
The other guy I can add was.
Coming up with and this might be too much
work or something I was just thinking
about is.
Because I can possibly create,
let's just say within some structure I
could create a kiss file that would be
defined as each one of those assemblies
and then create that as a body and figure
out some way of manipulating like kiss
file essentially with with the links and
then just.
Just using that as just a single import.
I wouldn't and I I wouldn't worry too
much about trying to force it into a kiss
file. Really. In my mind,
there's some kiss file in Excel, right?
There's not. So if the Excel.
Makes it easier than I would just because
once I think what's nice to do is that we
get that situation where there'll be some
sort of a field change, right?
And then we have a like a sub blank
ordering system where the guys can spill
out, you know, length, width, type,
whatever and then just send it in.
Hey, I, you know,
Jimmy screwed up the design, so I need 30,
right?
And then we can just leverage that back
into here, type it and then export, yeah.
Are you looking to do estimates for this
in here as well at this point?
Probably not.
So the way that the way that election was
estimated,
they actually have a a pretty good idea
from the field side of this. Yeah.
And so technically the way that they
estimate is based on the Nika value and
then as if these were all done in the
field. Yeah, because they kind of.
The way they're estimating software works
is that they just put in a parameter
saying we can support every six feet,
make all the condo to run and then it
automatically populates K um.
So,
but in what would actually be long term,
what would be nice would be from a
project management standpoint,
we'll be able to actually to be able to
come up with realistic expectations about
how much you can put through a shop. Yeah.
So you're not going to overload them.
Yeah, kind of.
And that's maybe not to maybe not to get
into all the work, but yeah,
I'm not actually into the same,
but might be um uh next, right?
I think so.
So man, that's awesome.
So you'd be looking at them to create the
cut of this and what not you.
I mean ideally you can do this on the
tablet.
Yeah, yeah, almost 3% of the tablet.
The only problem with that would be, um.
Talking for like one of that notions. No,
I'm talking about for licensing.
You can only have one site for one good
site per per server. Yeah, actually,
but for we'll call it.
Or database report. Um.
So if you were to do them the other edge
site, they probably will separate. Yeah,
I don't know, separate it somewhere,
but I believe they're.
They're on the same.
They're operating on our same servers
though at the Dunn's facility, so.
Other than an IP address,
I don't think they would actually know.
But if you want two different databases,
then currently go to your go site that
they're using can only point to one of
the databases.
They can't read from either or and the
database is just from a material database
standpoint.
Word. Yeah,
like if we want to set or separate that
from all their trials, right.
You want your own thing.
Here's all my and that's gonna be a
totally different database,
which is what we were trying to open up
and I don't I I mean.
I would say, I mean,
ideally we throw the same department we
have, you know,
their own electric coordinators,
but it would be just easy to to have an
electric coordinator operating in the
same zones then or the same environment
and then.
There's no reason it it it should muddy
either,
or we can just send it to these guys and
then they can produce the cutlass and
then it just gets it gets routed to,
you know, the electrical team, right?
And then he kind of executes from there.
Yeah,
because essentially we're both on the
same server service.
That's where we're running into issues.
There's no reason,
especially with those sizes defined,
we can create electrical only jobs in
there and these.
To find them out from everything and and
then you can be more you can go less and
then you can use it over there,
access the compass the same as we would
hear. Yeah, that's something.
I could see you running with the
Everett's.
It is.
It is a mix like, but yeah,
it'll come with its own pickups, I'm sure.
Yeah, but I mean I would with our current,
with our current workflow and everything
like that, I would see this would be,
I would need maybe one Douglas for and it
would just be.
Yeah,
Mike would would just have control over
it and he would just be delegating to the
dot guys as as it goes in and out kind of
thing. Now are you wanting to do um?
Line.
You want to track other things within the
system. So after cutting,
you want to track the shipping of it and
whatnot there. Ideally, yeah,
we we would package, you know,
because we're going to be greatly.
We're gonna break things down into like
separate work packages. So you'll have,
you know this,
you only would spread out across,
you know, several work packages. Yeah,
and then we'll see the process from there.
And so the guys working, you know,
in area one.
It'll be shipped out as an area one
package, OK, right.
And then and trying to keep everything
bundled to where it directly goes to site
and stage to that area. Yeah,
we don't have to shake everything out.
It'd be using a sequence as possible.
The actual work packages or your exactly
and that's kinda how we're setting up.
That's how we're kind of setting up our
claiming anyways. Yeah, that work package.
So,
so correlating that backwards from our
our take off because we're actually just
similar like what you're doing within
structures and far as like the once it
goes and gets claimed and kind of builds
the model, right.
So we're using that same,
they call it asset tracking,
but it's the same concept within of it
and it wouldn't be that hard.
Most of the work package is created.
It automatically creates a BUM based on
this. Yeah, we bring,
we could bring them in as separate lots
and we can combine across lots. Yeah.
And then still get the efficiency out,
so we'll be able.
Track it.
Separately.
So do you strike come in like, uh,
like what? What license is it going to?
Twelves, 20s. OK, I think, yeah, 10s, 12s,
20s, I think. Yeah,
I keep 20s probably are more typical than
I've been getting in. However,
past the stretch shortage,
that'll be better to find.
So we got to set that up with the.
Yeah,
price and maintenance in order to get the
lights in there.
Do you know who's adding the maintenance
if that's what we have with order? Yeah,
yeah.
That's great. That's not in there, right?
Or is that great news?
But we've got a number of grades in there.
You can get add down with Bob and bring
all the other grades in.
If you leave that blank,
we'll bring in all great set of stuff.
It's always good.
If that, which we have something for the.
This I think will work very well with
that.
And then so essentially if ideally when
we redesign our our families, we can,
I can further expand these to where we
need to get to fittings where we can get
it to.
Washington minutes, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
What the I don't love and ready?
Yeah, but it's a 40 foot piece of what?
Be able to get it.
You still want to pull it out the truck,
yeah.
For sure.
Yeah.
That's what you. That's what you want.
No.
OK.
Yeah.
So can can you you you said you can
modify ribs and you'll kick it out in
this format. Yeah,
the only thing I'm not 100% sure is how.
They're not gonna be electronic numbers.
Yeah, and I, but at the end of my opinion,
worst worst case,
I think I come up with a a way to massage
the data from from revenue export.
We can just do some pretty basic itself
up and then yeah,
get it into this one app.
Yeah,
I'm wondering if it's one of those deals
where you can, you know, you know,
R1 comes out,
append those last little digits of the
drawing number.
But it's.
Yeah, that's that problem there.
The easiest of, yeah, but yeah,
it's really flexible.
And what you want?
Great.
How's that going to get to find the
because that that wasn't working without.
Yeah, on the the grade will differentiate,
so it'll be a stainless,
a hot dip as any gold and so I'm not sure
there's some duplicates in there.
But honestly,
ideally you don't want to have to touch
it when it comes out. Yeah,
and I don't know how feasible that is,
but you can.
Somehow if I agree.
Which we can have to do that sort of
global edit to. Yeah,
but that's it's honestly that seemed like
a parameter we should be able to easily
set up. Yeah, OK, cool.
See if I can get in.
It's really the only thing you need to
try is the cutting of it and should be
done pretty much right. Well,
I would say yeah, the purchasing,
purchasing receipt and then yes, cutting.
Cutting.
I know we probably have the same sort of,
you know, QC. Yeah,
we don't have any codings on it.
And then you know,
shipping and then the BOM and receiving
field capacity for assemblies.
Made here or there in the field.
The assemblies would be made at here at
the shop.
So who orders to put the rusting parts in?
Like I saw you have bean clamps for that.
So the the beam clamps are probably.
Just take this further down. Um.
The way that they do their ordering is
they just do a a bulk order essentially
at the beginning,
but then the vendor does a a min Max kind
of thing.
So I would just say as the Azure
assembler is is pulling all their stuff.
They just know that they're gearing up
for this assembly.
So they're gonna go pull, you know,
I know I need 100 of these and we're
gonna pull 400 nuts kind of thing based
off of what what that is.
So I think we could leverage it further.
I just don't know if.
If that might be taking a little too too
badly on.
Do you want the do you want them to track
how many have been assembled and how many
have not?
Or just I'm really just tracking Caddy
with UC and shipping.
Because we're gonna be breaking the work
packages,
I think we would want to be tracking
total quantities of being done because
we're gonna spread across.
So you you would want to be able to track
completion based off of your.
So probably your way out to the.
Yeah,
a lot more simple cutting around some
work, yeah.
And then if we wanted to track the the
completion of the assembly,
if they have a QC portion,
we can always find a station in there for
assembly and then have an inspection.
And then when we fill out the inspection
report for this is going to be the job.
Yeah,
they're just doing they're doing the
first article inspection and then like
every 10 or so kind of thing,
but but I think they globally.
Go through that because yeah,
then we would just end up creating a blog
like we did for for codings because then
they could go in and piece tracking gear
and just manually have completed and move
batches.
Definitely.
Yeah, that's that's let's see, let me see.
So the issue is, yeah, like I said,
the switch is probably getting it in
there in the format.
So can we can we create a a route that
will just say like?
But we just call it electrical assembly
or you just need to fall in there.
I mean create a route and you can put so
much from so or would that be where where
you just what do you make more sense that
kind of bringing in one of the something
fabrication.
I mean I mean if you could learn to spit
up and then.
Yeah, we have.
These are all our routes that we have in
here. So,
so we can just tailor one of these,
create a new one for electrical.
I mean here.
Does the costing have to roll up any
specific way or can it just roll up under
company 40 through 700 here at this stage
we would.
So I think we would treat this the same
way that.
We're kind of doing now is that we we
would actually do combining and that
would to the electrical procurement and
then they would just tell us the PO that
they cut for that and then it would be
added in the system here.
Because I don't know at least the way
currently set up is is they have I mean
because it's still it's it's all under 40
but it's still it's two different
divisions so they just get it.
Keeping Mark in his procurement strategy
would probably be the easiest,
but then all he has to do is just say,
hey,
here's the PO number and inspect the date
and I think just bring it back in that
way.
But ideally we could get it to where I
see.
One of us.
Unless they have like a coordinator in
here,
not the new doing where to purchase from,
but.
I want to see that this is not the other.
Basically, it cuts on some of the week.
What we need,
even if we go where we have that QC one
as well, we can add a QC one,
but if we want to,
so our fit up triggers the QC inspection.
Just cause that's tied to it,
but the assembly portion we can tie a
case of inspection to that as well.
The only problem is going to be I guess
you can can do that,
but if you haven't typed an inspection,
you can still mark it off the piece
tracking if they're doing.
All one every 10,
so anything that's in the route here that
expects you to be on another set of
pieces.
So then you see what you know 10% of it
then.
Expects it a little in the future, right?
I mean, he can. I mean,
he can go through and and check off at 10
we're done, right?
And then just do the physical inspection
on the the 10th one. Yeah.
And or you know,
you can do it this way just like the
whole batch has been assembled.
And there is QC testing like a whole type
thing you can fill out that you can still
just fill out for the 10% of it.
So you have those records that you know
that the whole block is done.
So where's packaging and loading?
That would be the next thing is there's
way more packaging on the list of
quantities.
Search.
And that's like we take them stock,
cut them when they cut out the cut list
to take the stock and get marked out.
So those first two categories will get
down.
That's the cut of the skate cut and then
the assembly portion will be striving.
And I completed because there's a huge
volume here.
Are you guys going to make packaging that
makes it easier to move them?
They have for for the local stuff,
we have carts that we ship back and forth.
And so they're ideally you would load up
a cart and then that cart would have all
the the same traps and then whatever
needed.
And then then that would be correlated
with that work package and you go to that
one, that one. So.
Yeah, they need those parts here too,
just to.
But I imagine those go to the field.
The field has whatever. Mm-hmm. Yeah,
so they look.
Tech will need to know the road belt.
I don't know how many of these parts
should be,
but let's say I mean this looks like a
huge quantity would be.
No, but I mean,
is it like 3 carts on a job or is it like
50 carts on a job we probably have on?
We'll probably have 20 to 30 in rotation
and then total is ideally we try to break
everything into like one week work
packages.
So if we're a week ahead of that,
a week's in the field and a week's coming
back, yeah,
I mean that always really gives you 10,
you know, in the field at the time.
That's here locally, correct?
What happens if they go to Ohio?
That's Iowa's problem. OK,
now in the past what we've done.
So between Iowa and Texas,
they have their own fab shops there and
so that's their own rotation.
So we don't worry about that.
We started doing prefab for Dallas here
until they got there.
Their prefab shop up and running and then
now 'cause that's what we what we did on
that line is we prefab carts and we did
the first shipment while they were
getting started and then that was their
first set of carts they used to ship out.
But I think the firmest one that we're
gonna have to figure out is.
New Mexico,
it's probably the next one where we're
going to have to come up with some sort
of plan to be able to ship and then
ideally not,
we just need to validate how we're going
to get it back and get that cost out ways.
You know,
she doesn't have enough in rotation to
get, you know, longer lag. The farther,
yeah.
And you mentioned like do you do I get
something back with those carts or do I
just do single trips?
And then maybe when the guys come back,
you know,
maybe we do some sort of classroom when
the guys come back for, you know,
their family stuff every couple of weeks
and we just, you know,
have them drive and be all.
But if we track those,
it's as assemblies in here,
we'd have to ship and then we'd have to
unship them as soon as they came back,
right?
And to feel that they'd be available.
You just leave it away. Yeah,
it's just to get interesting with two
shops having a bunch of cars.
It's like a you're chasing those things,
right?
Or they disappear pretty quickly too.
I'm really down one attractive.
Try to think how that would happen to her.
There's not really a mechanism in here
for doing that. I mean,
you could put them on the truck basically,
but that's you'd have to receive them in
the field, right?
Or else they can constantly show never
received, right? Yeah, yeah.
Um, I guess you could do.
If you after it's received,
you can do a next step, yeah,
and to show return or something like that
where those assemblers constantly show
it's not returned and then once they do
get returned and check back in,
then if you can go through the unshipping
backwards.
Yeah, I'm almost.
Those are what we're just talking. OK,
yeah, just carts.
But there's massive stacks for these
things. Yeah, well,
I'm almost wondering if we were just
within something in.
So there's not really anything designed
that they track this asset that goes back
and forth,
but I'm wondering what the over again
some of the inspections in here is pretty
much a long building, right?
And I need to try.
I need the forward inspections to.
Scrap guys that would check out like
grinders and I'll come with you over here.
But when they checked it out,
it was in a famous state, we'll call it.
And then when they checked it back in,
we've,
you know how we were doing the follow up
and stuff,
we've been following up and then closes
it out, you know what I'm saying? So.
You know,
that might be a way to do it that way.
And that's something we could probably we
can leverage and and like some one of the
other forums within the ERP or something
like that, yeah.
Or just manage it like you know like
through asset, right? Like we can.
I think we could build it to be where it
would be very simple.
Once the like the field crews would come
and grab stuff and it would disappear and
be gone.
We never knew if we got it back or not,
right?
So we had to build that to this job site.
We got back on this date.
Here's the token.
So if we never saw it come back,
we'd be like, hey,
you grabbed us a week ago. Where is it?
Yeah.
So I wonder how Mark can just track those
cards. The what? The tool room guy.
Yeah.
I don't see really.
We'll get back together tomorrow.
Is that great?
I wondered if between now and then we
take like the.
Bill of material that you were that we
were just looking at,
get the whole thing and where we can get
it to the important and then kind of OK,
here's your release.
Let's walk it all the way through and say
set one package. Let's go ahead and.
I'll be the next thing forward or getting
on that list and just kind of walk it all
the way through.
It it it it all sounds to me that if we
really do it then we'll run across issues.
What would be good if we could get that?
Is there a way to get that electronically
rather than a PDF? That's what.
Let me see if I can get um.
That way is I can get the Excel one you
just released out of the project PDF
throw out the check that we need to put
in the Excel for.
That's intensities.
So on that wiring I think I did really
kind of unrelated,
but I used chat to do the nesting on the
wire and it's utilization came down to
like.
Uh, I think we have like 15% drop. Oh,
and then they went to tech room.
We got what, like like a percent if that.
Yeah, it's like .04. Yeah,
that's where you got, you know,
really worrisome on how we're gonna take
off, yeah.
When when you know the database,
we can just export out the export out the.
I'm curious if they did it the way I
asked them to, or they just copied it.
If it's a big machine instance and it has
it in the end,
we see disable all the other sizes, yeah,
and then then it'll just be catered to
what we have.
We can clear out everything we don't need,
yeah. And then if it's not,
then then we can take that export and
yeah, push them through. Because yeah,
my guess,
considering how many times I went back
and forth with IT on this, yeah.
They copied and pasted the same instance
in a separate port.
So if you just say installed in service,
they will have the other ones selected.
They will just read the there's no copy.
Yeah, yeah, that's my guess. Any concern?
I haven't heard back from you yet.
I mean what's going on with it 'cause
this this admin is incredibly slow.
We must keep maybe is a call that's.
So this we have.
I don't work. Take care of.
Yeah, we can do that.
There's no reason we can't have it in
here with the regular stuff,
but we can also keep it separated,
just keep it clean. So we get.
I've got,
I've got a copy of the blank database,
so I mean not blank without the box
database.
So if on the other one we just want to
say I don't want to have to take the time
to get through and wipe out everything
you got in there and you want to be clean,
we can just restore it. Well,
we got to have it restored.
Yeah, but several of the processes here,
reaching back out to IT needs and
assistance. Yeah,
it's not too hard to join. I mean,
it'll be a big ask,
even I'm sure it'll be a real problem.
Yeah,
promoting all of our jobs and disabling
all of it.
Do they need all the signs that they
don't need? Yeah.
So if you had done it all and that it was
all red, so everything, you know,
a project manager. Yeah, OK,
but that's all we do. Yeah.
And then and then and then files for
download.
It's the one I didn't click.
He just dropped it in the folder.
So I know it was there. It wasn't it.
I was like, how was it there?
And I just like,
did I really not grab that one? I'm like,
it must have been so many years to let
him go crazy.
Listen,
I wouldn't be out of the realm of
possibilities for me to look at that and
go. I don't need that. I do need that.
I need it done so.
That's OK.
I was just sitting there going through
each drawing.
It'll be a lot faster if the import
actually increase.
Yes.
Do you need anything fuller, Mr.
Ragner and then cook? Thank you all.
Why is it on the water fridge?
I don't know what's in the actual water
fridge.
Oh, more liquid. Yeah.
And what?
Hey on a when we did call one call to you
with on 82. That's OK.
Did you actually do the revenue file or
did you do everything should check now or
so I think it's one of either to or?
I mean, that was the other thing.
I don't know. I don't know.
They double check so.
What we're working on, we're trying to,
we're working on the frame.
Manipulating that, uh,
DOM once it's out to and drag these into
the tag list so that you don't have to
name the tag list about anymore.
And so I wanna see just, yeah,
that into Excel.
Correct me.
Yeah, the file.
Yeah.
Show me.
That's fine.
I just you go to like you know the sheet
section,
it's like the last one that should like
our generic track one, track two,
track three.
They have like the full deal built out.
Yes.
Stay a little bit higher. Yeah,
just feel free to.
WhatsApp.
Um.
Show you what I got.
Yeah, so when I've been looking, yeah,
I'll show you first one I've been working
on is uh.
Yeah, 82 the the cold electrical.
So pretty much this these spreadsheets
I'll see by getting to Excel.
It doesn't have to be these ones,
I just need.
It doesn't have to be the specific ones,
I just need.
So I'm going to work on.
Yeah, I can export all the schedule.
Yeah, just just take this,
just do call 1 electrical to tier one and
then can you actually pull up?
Are you able to modify these tables?
Yeah, yes Sir. Cool.
Can you pull up what and show us what's
available?
I want to see if we can add some stuff to
it to.
Yeah, don't think so. I know it's how.
I know it's how you know.
That's fine.
Alright.
So yeah, I was able to.
It's going back. So what?
Can you pull it down the the charter? Yes.
So what?
Awesome. Thanks.
So go back to.
So we have so label is needed.
It needs to be exact order, right?
If it's not in this order,
I can just remap it.
As long as it has those,
I'll just tell it what column to look at
for what data. OK, so so they're drawing.
We have found.
But the count is only really applying to.
The overall assembly,
but it's giving me piece mark which I
should try.
Bad.
It'll automatically assign weights, right?
Based on, based on report and then.
I mean create anything you know this can
you we're not assigning grades in here at
all as far as on this on the strap while
it was.
If there's something I can redo it,
I'll see.
So if I wanted to essentially if I wanted
to reorganize this to where see we have
our label and then our labels can be our
and then and I would want another.
Why after that it's where the label it
would be the label would read like R1 and
then the last three digits of the label
just so I can increase a part for the raw
links.
He's running in here. Yeah,
so I wouldn't wanna.
So essentially we had all this list to
cover, so I would want.
Another label and then it'd be label.
I see it wrong, but I have a second.
So I would wanted to add another column
in there.
It.
So this is but.
I can send you a screenshot.
You can send it to one.
Just in all of them to share.
So you see what we need to do is we need
to create a piece mark for the rod that
ties it to what our main markings for the
actual trip pieces separately, right?
So so I can have first T1 and C1.
There, right?
We have, you know, it's 40 units,
shredded few thousands and then you have
four half of troughs that are going to be
RR one,
3 digits from the piece mark that R23
digits from the piece mark, right?
And we see how that ties to the main mark.
Yeah, Paul, how how that looks.
Can you see if you can manipulate that
Excel spreadsheet?
Or I'm sorry,
the right he went to kind of look like
this.
I get it.
OK, that's not my.
No.
It's probably just like fully stubbed.
It's not okay anything right?
It's not right.
But it's like in the future and then that
stuff's gonna check here.
It's whatever parameter in your can pull
from.
Hey, Cortana.
And because Excel,
we want to have those kind of,
so we're just gonna privacy to give them
a little bit.
Um, to have all these parameters? Yeah.
So why don't you just give me?
Just give me the Excel export of just
that version one and I I think I just it
within Excel.
So you're gonna be a back work and then.
And then we can work getting up the with
the team to get our actually many of
their panels or these will be ones to
match.
Have used to be fair. Well, yeah,
this is the way this was built, right?
We're still.
No.
Are we simple on that?
That's how's have we done the process of
getting like codings that that's all it
is.
Are we seeing it be the same when we're
not given any sort of like actual files,
we're doing the same Excel import or how
are we doing that? I don't know.
Yeah,
most of the coatings customers have been
supplying KISS files without without the
KISS file.
We did kind of guess any chances of all
the manual boards,
but that that would be probably about the
only other way.
Would be manual imports and index out
imports. We can do the same.
So the pro shot we've been getting better
as files. Yeah, alright, yeah,
especially with the one that's coming up
for TSMC, that's right.
We're good to go in place.
Yeah,
importing for the scope that they're
going to get that wording and that's all
importing pretty easily in there.
So I have all that working out,
but it doesn't need from the great little
stuff we weren't getting a lot of.
Locked in test files. So are you um?
Are you trying to get PFXD files on your
jugs rather than kiss files? Yes,
because kiss files are going to go away.
So yeah, they're a good job. So yeah,
and with them,
with them you can do the kiss files,
they export out of their spermis and then
give us.
Their own sets. Um, but yeah,
they've been doing kiss files and then
we've been getting IFCS. Um,
verifies that their IFCS exported
fabrication views so we can use it on the
HoloLens. Um,
but I did at least have an IFC that I can
upload in Trimble.
Problems that they do like weekly updates
on it.
So we get a new IRC every single week
with revisions.
What are we using on codings of the
HoloLens? Uh,
nothing for codings of the HoloLens
that's all kind of stuff, but but.
For for files that we've been requesting
that are actually giving IFCS kiss files,
they have not supplied a PFXD file as of
yet. So but we talk about, yeah,
what's that part of what we got is that
PFXD file is.
You need that, yeah,
but if the details are showing.
Detailing and SDS or which is probably
the case. Yeah,
sometimes it takes a little longer to.
Yeah, for. But yeah,
I have this all set up in here.
I just need to Add all the routing that
we added.
A complex paint route.
So you can kind of see what we broke out
yesterday.
So now now they'll have the ability to
track their prep, intermediate pro,
prime and finish pro for the complex and
and all of these can be marked up in EP
and go.
And then we also created an inspection
report for them for their service prep in
our inspection area so that they can do
and Moe was a little hesitant to get away
from site talks.
But most of all of his reports can be
redone in here and done from UPN go.
So I'm assuming in the future once we
actually get kicked out the site that
slowly if we do.
All of that stuff can be transferred in.
Yeah.
We also tweaked the we added three
different coating types,
so we got the high solids,
the steel spec and macro epoxy.
So we added all these in and we
configured the container sizes for what
their purchasable units are and their
cost per gallon,
which might have to be updated if that
does change and then their coverage.
So estimates when we plug one in.
Should be pretty on point with exactly
what they're looking for.
As for what our estimates summary will
show for how many gallons they need over
the price on the summary and and the
square footage usages, does that?
Does that description carry through on
travelers at all? No, it doesn't. Uh,
doesn't doesn't. So I did.
We did end up adding into production.
Additional finishes in here.
So we do have complex SP2SP3SP6 as well
as simple SP one through 6.
So we'll at least have a prep call out to
finish and that will show up on the
travelers.
But you can kind of adjust the finishes
however we want.
So if we wanted to add the paint spec and
the surface prep spec in there, we could.
It's just gonna make a list that didn't
come along. No, I I just want to.
We have a hard time getting the details
on board with right specs.
I just want to make sure that we.
The process right now is that submittal
travels with it, right?
So they reference to the actual submittal.
So I just wanna make sure we're not
possibly conflicting data, yeah.
No, we should be good there. None of that.
All those other ones we were just looking
at are just on the estimate side.
So those are options you can pick when
you're starting a new job.
If you're in here,
you can go into your paid systems and.
And go in here and move over multiple
codes and do custom systems and then
clean systems as well.
If you were doing an SP2 and an SP6 then
you can account for the layer for
multiple systems for singular systems on
your estimates.
Stop.
We got that redialed in yesterday and and
adjusted the labor in there so that it's
matching what Moe's been calculating out
for one man hour permanent square foot
and one man hour permanent square foot
for private and private so.
That's that's.
Today we've kind of been messing with
adjusting labor.
So we adjusted a couple of the well
deposition rates in there because they
were some of the out-of-the-box rates.
So we increased some because the rates
were really slow in there.
So we dialed up the.
The feet feet per minute or feet per hour
in here for quarter range, 516 and 3/8,
our most basic movements and then also
learning and increase our fit time a
little bit.
So our well time went down a little bit
time increased a little which is usually
what we notice maybe most of our
adjustments on our projects is that it
needs a little bit more involvement is
usually a little over so so and we're
working to continue to fine tune that.
Looking at historical projects,
we haven't gotten to a point where we've
been able to identify specifically where
our issues are coming into play.
So it's been kind of like new adjustments
at this point, but.
Plan to continue to look at existing
projects and we see breakouts and
estimates and compare actuals versus
estimated versus supplied meaning we kind
of get our numbers to all jive across the
board.
So so the actual back end right the.
One of the issues has always been with
what you're, which is, right,
what you're actually will linear for the
what was done versus what.
What you've got to estimate, right?
And so it's hard to, you know,
if you wait the hours done to what you
estimated was actually done, right?
And so you have to kind of.
But the way.
Unless we dig into everything and spend a
lot of time processing the PXT or
whatever the import is on it,
we're not gonna come up with an actual
true.
What was detailed of what was done,
correct?
We talked about like if I have 500 hours
on the estimate,
but with the work that flight sort of
record should be 600 hours.
I'm saying 78 feet of Weld that was
estimated based on all the clips and
everything,
but in reality we did 87 feet of welding.
Because it was detailed different. Yeah,
it's any one of the estimated versus
actions, right. Like, so it's,
it's I mean it's estimated versus you
know what was assumed, right.
And then you know,
let's say it took about 10 month clips or
something like that, right. Or yeah, or.
Whatever happen in detail,
we didn't need as many connection links
or something like that, right? So change.
So that's kinda so especially, well,
I mean,
I think going cuts very easy because
those are pretty close to always being.
Actually, but uh,
the wells have always been kind of uh.
You don't want to divide it back into
what was estimated.
So one way you can account for somebody
in here, it's not an exact science,
but when you link the production control
down back to that estimate.
It can bring those hours over and apply
it to the material that's in production
control.
Now what it does is it does it on a hours
per ton basis.
So if if it's like OK they you know my
base plate sizes have decreased my NA.
Yeah, like you said,
a bunch of folks are going, well,
then you get less hours in there because
that happened, but it's doing it off.
It's not looking at every nature well
because it doesn't know that on the
production control side.
It does on this credit side, right? But.
That that helps a lot of shots from the
standpoint of what the shots stream
because they're like,
I'm always over on hours because you're
judging me based off of the estimated
hours and things changed and there's a
lot more work,
plus all these change orders going in
there. You're not crediting me for that.
Well, once that,
once it gets production control,
it calculates hours.
So it can't account for some of that.
It's not an exact science at that stage.
So once it gets brought into production
control,
we're essentially reestablishing our
labor budgets based off of the the
revenue series, right? Yeah,
that's actually what the base hours are.
In that projects here is those hours
going to look for deduction trials and
what that does is there's estimated hours
in the schedule as well and it compares
the estimated to the base hours.
Let's say we had 500 hours for one.
For one sequence in the estimated hours
and but base hours was 575 and we used
the 575 instead of the 500 because it
said yeah,
you said 500 hours on the estimate,
but he really got 575 hours of work.
That's what we're using, right?
That's what this base.
So we're using adjusted adjustments
incorrectly. It will not do it that way.
The way I described if you're using the
estimated hours in the adjustment column,
OK,
but right now they're using adjustment as
estimated.
That's that's what I was here.
Is that correct?
The adjustment is essentially we plug the
adjustment in based on whatever the base
hours are showing to get it to match what
we have released to us.
So analyze it 50 and our base hours show
that.
It's 39 and we'll plug the difference in
there so that our who is the source,
who's the source of base hours,
base hours is based upon production. OK,
so estimated hours need to be shown so so
your.
You're constantly changing the adjustment
yet to keep it at the hours you want,
right? Yeah.
So if you would put the estimated
estimate,
you won't have to do that because it's so
like on let's see the one line that has
base size of 1614 and adjustment.
So you got a total plan hours of 30.
See that one right there? Yeah.
So that one,
if you had 30 hours and estimated with 16
in base,
it assumes the other 14 are coming and
and your and your planned hours are going
to be 30.
Save hours is coming out of the actual
time work and how much they've done so
far.
It's basically takes the hours the pieces
that are in production control to get to
get those hours and complete them. OK,
yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We're not manipulating data because we
want to.
We're manipulating it because we have to.
Yeah. Well,
it's something that doesn't really we're
not. We're not. Yeah.
We're not manipulating the data because
we want to.
We're manipulating the data because we
have to because like that's not pulling
anything over from an original estimate.
But what I'm saying is you're you're
doing it because.
You want that line to be 30 hours, right?
Yeah.
So if you put the 30 hours in the
original estimated,
can you can you add that's right?
Because that's got to say you can't add
the hours today.
If you can add the hours in the original
estimated, yeah,
put in 30 right there and then get rid of
your adjustment.
So, so to summarize,
so the original estimate would be so from
the PC form, right. So we'd say, hey guys,
this is what we budgeted, you know,
so that that's just so adjustment doesn't
even need to be there.
We'll just throw in the original
estimated out there or the original, yeah,
into the estimated hour column.
It doesn't and then it'll take whatever
the base hours are.
And figure out where to find where it
should be.
Now what you'll need to watch for though
is let's say that that was 100% that that
particular lot was 100% released and you
have this situation where original are 30,
but the base is saying you really only
have 69.
Hey, that's all that's coming, right?
Well,
it's still a plan 30 year because it's it
thinks more is coming.
So if you change the 100% release to 100%
then it would use the base hours of 16.
You follow what I'm saying?
And that's what we want to do. We want to,
we want to be managing to the actual to
what the work that we're saying can
happen and and using essentially the
knowledge of the original being at 30 to
know that you got 14 hours of contingency.
So I saw it show that it's 100% released
if we put 11 there.
Yeah,
put it in below the area and get rid of
your adjustment.
That's basically what we want to base
hours.
CS use them. Well,
it still thinks more is coming,
but if you change your percent release to
100, reasonable percent,
it calculates the percent release based
off of the hours.
So it changed with that because 54.
55% of the hours are actually released.
But if you change the percent release to
100,
it would put your planned hours at six.
Well,
it seems like it's adjusting it for
whatever we put in your original.
It is right,
but if you change it to 100 then it'll
adjust.
Who's the source of the original estimate?
We got a guy with a dartboard in Dilbert,
right? That's the that's the data, right?
So yeah, so yeah, so I would,
I mean and I guess it's probably a hard
decision, but to leverage this correctly,
I would say you would want to to take
whatever your base hours came out to be.
You would duplicate that into your
original estimate number so that you
could manage your percent released based
off of your base hours that your updated
Rev zeros or can we check our percent
utilized because like look at this so.
We're showing 16 hours and now I'm
showing that I went over,
but in reality on this line I don't think
I should do that,
but that's what I'm saying.
So the base hours original estimate now
should match and then Mark should just
know that his actual release.
So when he does,
when when we have our actual production
meetings and he brings us out,
he's gonna have.
A separate column of what was actually
estimated on this side that's showing
that category.
You're saying base hours need to line up?
Yes, I think so.
So do we need to adjust all of it across
the? I don't see you,
but base hours changes, doesn't it?
Base hours will change based off based
off of.
Imported more pieces, yes.
So if we bring in more pieces,
then it's going to change that base.
But then the estimate is there. I mean,
but if we leave,
if we if we bring in more pieces but we
sequence a lot into a separate sequence,
well, it's just that same sequence.
So we bring in more pieces, right? Yeah.
We do another thing for for this or no
for a separate sequence. Yeah.
Will it affect this sequence? No. OK,
so if we change it across the board, yeah.
So as long as base hours match the
original estimate, then you're.
Percent release here,
percent completes are all flow through
well.
So as long as as long as the PDS that are
releasing this stuff are giving you guys
the hours for that sequence and lot then
and you guys know that then that this
works but.
In a situation where it's like a,
you know, hey,
this is one out of three canopies,
here's your guys' overall budget,
then we'll just have to,
we'll just have to make sure that we hold
them accountable and then and then Mark
just needs to know that he's managing
those, those buckets are clear.
Well, what what Mark reestimates.
So let's say Mark gets something from
Gilbert. He's like, well, yeah,
it's not this, he says. It's really this.
Where does that? Where does that go?
It's technically what?
Your base hours and Jesus, right,
'cause that's where it's being
reestimated and that's your base hours.
So the idea of that by doing it this way
through when we start a job or even touch
the shot, we can have a discussion of.
We're planning to pay for a budget and we
can at least go into it saying OK,
what changed?
Can we get a change or ingest something
or is it just something that we just know
that we just need to treat this as it has
to be just production based so like
everything has to be perfect and only get
the guys who want the work doesn't really
get done.
Four hours and that's it. So you're in.
I also think that as long as I'm
searching where I think it's on the
subjective stuff, right? I'm not.
That's not coming in with based on.
I'm hearing two conversations here.
I'm having the hard time keeping track.
I think it's really important that we
agree on what this is because we're
having two separate.
He and I are having a discussion and you
guys are having a discussion,
but I think it's what is the real answer
of how to do this because.
Alan is right that that 175 being
calculated between 2 numbers and you're
trying to avoid that from happening.
But you know what's your what's your goal?
So now so now what we really need to do
though right knowing this is it's just
change the 16 to 30.
In the plan in our base.
Right. Well,
it's great if the estimator actually
estimated 30,
but we've seen some jobs where the
estimator estimated 14,
but it it it will change based upon
whatever we're given, right?
If we're only given 14 hours,
that's where we're we're adding these
original estimated hours, right?
Well,
that's what looked like has been
happening, right? Mark says,
I don't think so and he's making a so and
it seems like it's a slippery.
So on one side,
if base hours are coming in less than
original, right, that's great, right.
But you want Mark to plan his production
accordingly.
And we're talking bigger intelligence,
right?
But you don't want Mark to to still on
budget his hours based off of, you know,
having 10 guys busy versus the base hours
saying you're only going to keep three
guys busy, right?
I think we need to show the data you've
collected.
For the few jobs and show estimated base,
show what's really happening and then
everybody kind of looks at what's really
going on and then have that discussion.
And it's yeah,
we've been like even pulling data,
we've been pulling data just to kind of
look at it.
So and but I guess the base hours are.
We're talking aren't pulling in true well
hours, right. So it's just a well,
it's it depends on how you do it.
So theoretically original estimate,
original estimate,
that's what we have on the estimate,
right.
Base hours is saying this is what you
actually are going to be working for.
For what's for what's out there.
So if base hours is accurate,
I want that utilization to show you that
way over because if I literally did have
16 hours of work in that at least instead
of 30.
Then I want it to be 16 and that's what
I'll be judged on. It's the 16,
not the 30.
Now it's good information that it's like,
OK, cool, good.
Even though I might be a 28, I'm.
Under this late hours. That's awesome.
That's great work under.
But did I actually be mad because it was
really 16 hours of work that took 28
hours, right?
So if the base hours are correct,
then I want it to show that.
You know what I'm saying, right?
So then it's a constant tweak to get the
base hours as close to what our hours
that we're actually producing it
correctly. Yeah,
it might be not there because let's say
on the estimate there were there were
three columns in there and now I've only
got one column.
I don't want the base hours to be 30
hours. No, no, no, no, no, no.
What I'm saying is,
is what I want is the base hours to be
what what we're actually going to produce
it at. Yeah, yeah. So if it says 16 hours,
we should be producing it at 16 hours,
right? Yeah.
That's what we're we're shooting for.
It's regardless of the estimate.
If they gave us 30 hours, that's cool.
But we should only need 16. Yeah.
And that's what you should manage for is
what at the end of the day, I think the,
but then the biggest thing is making sure
that we're getting good data back, right.
But then the way we've been utilizing
this is, is wrong, right.
If it's what it's going to look at now.
Is the hours that were planned, right?
So the base hours of the plan are you
guys give the shot before they're done,
is that correct? Well,
originally it was the adjustment,
which is to adjust the hours to fit and
then that would bring the.
Or so, right. So if it was 16 hours,
we have 30,
we would add to that 16 to get the 30 in
the planned hours. But base hours,
assuming 100% release, uh,
base hours should match plans.
If if all material is for apples to
apples, yeah.
So if he changes base hours right now
since it says at 100 like change which it
already shows 66 right?
But if final I guess that does if you
change it to 31, see if it changes,
but it should change it to plan.
Yeah, yeah.
Now here's here's the game there. What?
If you do nothing but just connect the
two,
let's say that hours per ton of the
estimate was 9 hours of time, right?
I got 9 hours of time.
That's what it's going to apply over
there.
But let's say that this release had some
stuff that was 25 hours a ton in in
reality, because it's higher.
Let's let's say it's rails.
They're gonna be higher hours per ton,
right?
And some of the stuff in the release was
4 hours a ton.
Because they're just filler beads and
there's given holes.
So that base hours may be wacked out
because I'm applying none when I should
be applying 25 hours a ton for that
particular type of work that's in that
sequence.
So there is a way to do it by this way.
It's going to create more work there
because the estimate's going to have to
use predict what's called production
codes,
which says I'll just call this a
production code of rails and I'll call
this a production code of filler beam.
And so now pieces in the estimate are
going to have to be designated as part of
rails or Philippines,
and the pieces in production control are
going to be designated as rails or
Philippines in order to apply these
separately instead of just the overall
average of none.
So the same companies doing it that way.
A lot of companies go this route because
of this logic here.
What most of them end up coming back here
because this is that's a constant fight
back to do that.
But your releases are very similar to
right?
Your releases are columns or you mix work
like that.
Rails and beams. No,
the stairs will be with rails, but that's.
I mean, you know,
columns will be with beams, but it's not.
But you're still talking about an overall
one project, right?
You're not talking about several releases.
But it doesn't,
but it it is talking about specific
releases.
So if for now it's over the way we're
doing it now, but if we detail,
if we just make sure we detail everything
out based off of a full rail package,
yeah, being packaged, we don't mix,
we don't need to it changing.
Yeah,
but if we're if we're doing rails with
beams, then we need to understand.
So technically we would need to detail
them separately.
You guys can just assign them to
different sequence of plots from the
import and then you can bypass having to
keep them separated.
So you guys are just organizing the way
that you actually would produce them in
the shop, right? So you say, OK,
like I want to mark when you go to to
actually manpower load the the project
and say, OK,
we need to call them all out first, right?
So you break that columns into sequence
mod and then he's gonna get his own
unique.
Hours per time for that set of calls,
right?
And then you can plan it working from
there.
But where that's going to be hard to
manage into the overall budget,
the shovel was up last week.
They weren't going to try to fight that
panel too discreetly.
Or two, what they ended up,
what they will start at with is
structural versus miscellaneous. Yeah,
two different ones, which would be,
I mean.
It's not very well.
One package, typically add X.
They've already been separated.
I mean it's not it's events.
It's in for 0758 we have.
I mean there's definitely there's there's
annual braces and then there were study
palms, but it was.
So if we really go from stairs,
but if we real if we give it as a
sequence of and then block that out
though as far as like.
OK, cool. The the WTS are their own line,
but it's still within the same sequence.
It depends. Yeah,
all the correct hour paper time,
but the way that we if you don't use
production page is the way it's the same,
but it would do it per sequence and block.
Mm-hmm.
But based off of the way that we estimate
LG,
we estimated it based off of it being a
structural job, right? So like, we're not.
So that's at least. Yeah, we're, I mean,
they're rolled out to gut check your
management on the overall project,
but the way prompts really, I mean,
he's taking it off as each one of the
pieces,
but you're not gonna manage everything
separately.
It's you're different hours like that.
I would say this would be more like lucid
to where it's overall this.
This would be best on miss smells.
I think it's the better you keep
structural miss smells like you were
saying separate and then we could
separate out miss smells based on.
Rails,
stairs and strainers and we might have
seen it on this one by two because not
necessarily there may not be less
material,
but it or for that disparity like I was
talking about, but it could be that the.
Estimate just getting that right stuff in,
right.
Maybe it wasn't leaving out properly or
something like that.
So most stops that get into the overall
hours,
but then in most cases for structural in
general, they're pretty close.
Now you know it's fine, you know, so.
Based on hours instead of adjusted.
That's what we need to be putting this
right more than putting them under
adjusted out of adjusted, right. Yeah,
we spoke up.
So I didn't have this column activated.
So originally it was, yeah,
based on hours adjustment.
And then it should be original and base
hours.
Yeah,
what would the adjusted be used for in
the long run then if it was just used
original and base.
So we use base hours and adjustment and
then worked out the final hours.
So our PC form would have these total
quantities of hours and.
And then this is our utilization with the
utilization is coming so close and
adjustments up to regular hours and you
you that will give a new flavor to the
utilization per se for sure,
but it will also.
Help you on the opposite scenario where
the hours act,
the base hours actually come out more
than the original estimated. Well,
that's going to make you look better
because it's like, OK,
well we should that utilization should be
based off of a higher number,
not the estimated number, so.
It just makes it look bad when that when
that number splits.
Were you guys getting beat up because
those numbers were going on?
That'd probably be more question for Mark
for specifically for LG or in general.
So I wouldn't say beat up,
it's just the it's the common fight of of
estimate versus.
Production, right.
Estimators always trying to do things one
way and production always sharing them.
So it's the it's making sure that we're
on the same page to me on when the
project's kicked off so that we know do
we need to really pay attention to this
and come up with a way to make this into
a a.
We can or did we miss something?
At least establish what?
Is your main is angle main goal is a goal
to make sure the Gilbert guys are getting
the Gilbert estimators are hitting the
numbers really well?
Or is it your goal that Mark fixes it?
And Mark's numbers are really good.
I think the the the main goal here to
make a lot is OK, well, I get that.
The main goal is to if everyone's using
the estimate in techo, right.
So all the hours are based off of the
unit rates and and the the math that's
designed.
Into this, right.
So I think the main goal is to get that
as accurate as possible to where we are
established,
is it a bad take off or is it or is it a
unit rate of something that we need to
fix, right.
And I think that's where the argument
needs to come in is.
Is is it it's a take off thing then
that's I mean that's a simple thing to
say OK you it's clearly there's four
columns and you know you only have two
right.
But if we're trending constantly like I
saw is producing at half the rate that
we're actually estimating to that's a
global thing that makes you address with.
New equipment maintenance.
When you guys first get a job and you go
and you know what the original estimate
is before you put it in the show,
somebody looks at it and says no,
this estimate over here is 12 hours.
It's supposed to be 16 and maybe the next
time out of balance.
Supposed to be 16 and we really only
think it's going to be 12 and that's what
base column should be used for, correct?
No, it it it basically does.
It basically does that.
Nobody has to look at it and do it.
It calculates it automatically based on
the times that we have set up in for
welding and cutting and all that it it it
does,
but it it takes the average from the
estimate. It takes the, it takes the.
Total hours have to have to go to the
base for a time, the total.
But another's working out too whether so
you don't have to enter everything into
the base that's can be documented already.
If you enter something into the guest,
right.
So I would say to even another
perspective of what we're talking about
is.
This is going to get us,
let's just say to a 90% mark, right.
And within that estimate you're doing
frame versus the structural and this base
hours here is going to look at it and
generalize it as if it's the same main
hours per time as the structural.
But you know it's a more complex frame
system that's going to need more hours.
So Mark.
From the estimates and say,
I think we need to put a factor on top of
that.
Let's just add another 20 nanometers,
right. And I think that's it.
I think that's where you would add that
back end adjustment because the original
estimate.
Even though we have more hours,
Mark's actually saying that even though
the base gets re-imported in as the lower
hours,
he's still thinking that we're going to
need the additional hours to be allocated
to get it back up to there.
That's what we do,
which I think that's the point.
Let the program go from the original the
base hours and then if we think there's a
necessity to put in the adjustment,
that's what Mark would put in the
adjustment just like unit rates in a man
hour book, right.
It's it's saying that you know you're at
an 80% efficiency, but you add in and say,
OK,
I know the pipes 30 feet in air we're
going to need.
This, this and this,
you're gonna bring the guys back down.
And I think that's kind of what we're
talking about.
The adjustment is to adjust our main
hours for time based off the complexity
of the system that yeah,
technically it's in. Well,
let's see what we have to do, right.
People use that adjustment for kind of
similar to what you're talking about or.
It's we had 75 hours of rework,
so I'll put that on there or there's a
change order and there's more hours.
Usually the adjustment is the exception
and it's if there's anything adjustment,
there's always a question of why do I
have this year, but in my mind,
if there's a change order.
The original estimate is going to be
updated as well because you've estimated
the change order and your base contract
has increased.
Some people want to keep that original
estimate here and that's why they put it
in the sample. I get it.
I call it change order one January.
Or two, but they're still linked together.
But I think the factors that we were
messing with in the global system,
we're trying to make the numbers mostly
match what production was doing.
The problem that we're seeing is across
three or four jobs.
It wasn't. What's the right word? Linear,
right?
So you'd think that it would be this
factor. Well, that matched this job,
but not that job.
So there's more going on here that meets
the eye.
We probably need a bigger sample set.
Got to really figure out, you know,
what a 40 hour or 150 hour job is very
different than a 4000 hour job.
There's some things happening here,
but getting the global factors closer
will only help everybody.
I think honestly at this point you've got
to really take a look at what the actual
is in order to adjust the rest of what's
in there because we're trying to compare
it to what we said the budget was,
but I don't know that that's based on
anything.
Um, dad driven is more gut driven,
which maybe.
I don't want, but I want,
I want to change that and that's where
the idea was that it's hard to take.
To me,
it's hard to take some of this production
control stuff that we're talking about.
And really globally,
like you're saying sample setting to a
larger chunk,
there's that aspect or just go out and do
time studies, right?
Actually just basically saying,
but then we have to be cognizant about
the time study sample that we're doing
based off of the rules that we've created
on how that you know.
So the way I the way I perceived it
before is that.
We know that for cuts, for example,
it's we should get the same cut time for
everything from a, you know,
a W8 that's you know 13 lbs up to 40 lbs.
So to do it through time sample,
we make sure we.
Take a cut list,
combine all those like sizes that match a
rule that we have and then apply that
time step to that specific chunk and then
you validate back to what that portion is.
And then you can compare it to the next
step up of you know everything from a 40
pounder and up.
Now apply to check that section up.
Of it,
but I don't target because I don't think
you can get true data that you want to
manipulate your rule set based off of
just even large samples because it's
you're averaging across angles of where
you know that's wrong things we were told
the other day before because somebody's
basically fudging the.
They say, well,
we got a guy we want to keep in the shop.
We want to lay him off.
We finished this job.
The estimated hours was 100.
We only use 60.
So now we keep this guy out here working
for the other 40 hours and we post it
against that job. So we already know.
The history, what you're saying,
all that history is ******** because we
didn't really back it properly, right.
And that's where that's where I think you
validate our rules based off of true time.
I agree.
And then and then you have the factors
and everyone agrees saying OK like.
We did it. The guy was,
he was 100% off point, you know,
and then we back it into the 80% of of of
he had to always be at his time test here
when you extrapolate the data across.
Wide flanges because in both directions
or just up.
What do you mean?
So let's say I set a factor for a W8 by
whatever.
Is it that goes all the way up through to
a W 44? Yeah,
it was a cross-sectional area piece if if
I'm looking at the cut.
So if I'm looking at the cut,
if it's only the cross-sectional area
that can single size,
then they can go or shrink.
Let's say my numbers work.
Jimmy was saying for this range.
Now when I get to that range, yeah,
my number is different.
Now let's say I decide and AW24.
I put a new factor as it goes.
That direction too.
You can tell it which way you want to be
there. So when when I did it,
I I took one one piece.
Here's the we cut and exactly how long it
took. I put it on there,
pass it everything.
Yeah. And what I found was that it was,
it was generally OK within a range and
then I had to get a new range felt like
like you were talking about it was like 8
and 10 inch means I was good.
But and I wanted to get some kind in the
middle there, right? And but 2014,
I had made a new,
a new one that I outlined it to and it's
probably want to be on your machinery
today or how you sure as long as you
don't have to keep throwing them all in,
but you know that it's range driven, yeah,
I mean.
Wait,
you're gonna have to create rules in your
process that say these are our ranges and
then when your equipment changes,
you have to realize you have to go fix
that I I I really got.
Got multiple different samples from
different sizes and all up and down
through there and then I would take one,
apply it,
see how far that got me when I hit the
next size that I did that I measured and
it was like how close am I there? OK,
that's really really close enough,
good enough, but then the next one.
So I'll use that one to move up to the
next one. So yeah,
you you you can pick whatever range you
want.
Now that that was cutting and then you
got other stuff that's it extrapolates
based off of length or about weight.
That could be a totally different story.
But just you can send it whatever range
you want. So got a question.
So we've created these for you said
whatever your channel,
whatever we're cutting on here,
the guys are telling us how long it takes.
Got it. Correct. They're signing it off.
If they're doing the start slot on the on
the cap list then, yeah. So if we were,
but we haven't been doing that, right?
Right. But if we were,
would it then take that data and apply it
to? Yeah, that.
If I understand what you're asking,
if they didn't start,
stop on there and the contracting,
both of those would hit your schedule.
So you might duplicate that one out,
but it's still going to have to
somebody's going to have to actually
interpret and manipulate that data.
And yeah,
to be able to do anything back on a date
change,
it's not gonna look at the next job and
go Nope, helping us. Yeah, no, no.
But you would want to. You wouldn't want,
you want to capture it. Yeah,
and you would want to trend the haywork
consistently in this size and
consistently not hitting hours.
Let's figure out why. And then it's yeah,
because maybe one guy's buying 60s and
another guy's buying 20s and he's out in
the low three times as much and it's
being captured in the bed zone. Yeah,
and make sure your average measure too,
because.
When you if you say tell me how long it
takes to cut this, well,
are we talking just bladed like running
time or are we talking about, OK,
I've got to put it in feed up, roll it up,
get it set.
Now cut it and it goes out and that's
good. Make sure you know what you're.
I mean, my brain, yeah,
my brain is here's a cut list.
There's 23 pieces on it. Yeah. Start,
stop.
How many cuts did I get that picks all
that up? Yeah.
But it needs to that start stop needs to
correlate to how the moves actually
written, right?
So it's because technically I believe the
way we assumed it originally was that the
the starting is when he gets there,
pull starts pulling tape right across
does this.
Check gets it bit up,
gets the clamps in and starts because
rising you know on it and indexing it
over.
That's your start stop on what one cut
would be OK and and one of the things we
have a long long time ago was we just
have like a basic Excel spreadsheet that
just showed.
What the process was,
what the rule was and then just had a
narrative of kind of where we assumed
that that number kind of was coming from,
right.
And then so the it's two different
numbers, right.
It's just that he said it's just off time
versus what the operator is doing to
complete an overall where's the rest of
the classroom.
It would go handling is so OK,
there's a lot of overlap and I think you
guys, right? Correct me wrong,
but there's a lot of overlap of what is
considered the handling time and where
the time's allocated there and how that
goes to cut time and then how that goes.
Clean up or handling to go to the next,
the next station and does every got new.
It started last week.
Does everybody in the shop,
I'm sure there's some turnover there.
Does everybody know those rules and
that's where I think.
I think, I think getting estimators,
understanding exactly what the numbers
really mean,
getting them on board with how things are
actually going.
So you can look for the outliers of OK,
yeah, so we're assuming it's this, this,
but.
I'm estimating something that's 80 foot
long,
so the guy's gonna have to give him some
extra time because he's gonna have to
walk all the way over there and then walk
all the way back kind of thing.
But understanding where those your
parameters live or 100% efficiency and
where you should manipulate something
going into the next.
Sage fitness is another big one on where
we draw the line on fitting a standard
stiffener in a beam or a base plate
versus A-frame section or above 3 inch
base plate kind of understanding or
estimating side of where to take.
What we're talking about base hours and
where you actually are a true estimator
and really adjust your hours to what the
complexity is and maybe you do that
within just the overall efficiency factor
is that the beginning estimate part, but.
Do you wanna globally do that across an
entire 1000 ton project or you just do it
on a couple of parts? Who?
Who's the master of that domain of those
rules?
Gavin, that's your hand.
I it's either the estimators don't really
listen to you. Well,
and so the hard part is we haven't really
defined how we want.
Like what what process we want for time
studies,
because I can take time out of what I'm
doing to put time study stuff together
and we can make the adjustments to this.
We just need to put a plan together on on
how frequently we want to do that and
then make sure we're all on the same page
for how I am doing it.
And so most of what we have in here,
we haven't done too much crazy
adjustments since the first time studies
were performed.
We've never adjusted for the first time
studies, but this,
this was set up once and never touched it
after that. So and and we just.
Five new investments to to Weld
deposition rates. Yeah,
'cause they were super slow. Yeah, so,
but anyway, but yeah,
a lot of that stuff's either fascinating.
It's is that and that's where I think
goes into the trending aspect of it of.
Really,
if we can get a true understanding,
make sure everyone's on the same page
where the start and stop somewhere, right?
And then then when Mark we have to say,
hey guys,
the the budget's not good because of this
assembly is this or that,
we can at least have a baseline of what
was established on what it was.
Base powers are and why?
Because a lot of times it's between the
estimator and it's uh.
Are you guys sure that it's actually
gonna take the much time?
It's just one more time, right?
It's their argument on the back side,
so that's when it doesn't work.
And and put as much time as possible.
Yeah,
when you guys are trying to make some of
the kit, but it's always rely on it,
but it's always 100% always solid.
I'll speak to that and one.
But one adjustment today with the
categories is I we used to have a lot of
categories later.
So now if the estimator estimates,
we get it the way our PC funnel right now,
yes, they can.
OK. So with the exception of,
I mean there's a few special exceptions
and then as me and Ricky were talking,
this is going to muddy some stuff up.
So we're probably going to go here and.
Eliminate that other category and so that
we have that because then when we link an
estimate going forward,
this will tie into each of our categories
that we have in our our production
schedule and then jive with our PC forms
and those look like when you link an
estimate from the estimate to.
The Uh prediction control is that in the
main towers then?
Does that hold into the original
estimated hours?
It it nothing holds in the original
estimate. You you have to.
That's what you would work with. Yeah,
because usually on the estimate you don't
know what a sequence is or what a lot is.
You don't know great deal.
So it can't interpolate that.
So you have to put that in.
The late hours are if you did start stop
on the station or when you're coming,
that would be the actual hours coming
back in from that start stop on that
station, so.
That that's what I was going to say
before.
If you were to do time studies with the
star stop on the stations,
which is an awesome way to do it,
you just got to watch on your schedule
because then you're right on double up
and you guys go to the star stop on
tongue tracking and then you would be on
the star stop on a station as well.
So if it would double up hours.
To come back to your your your sample
approach of how you do it is you don't
want to go out there and then time study
just one cut, right?
But if we can group them based off of the
rule and you say OK, here's your cut list,
you know,
let's say it's two hours with the cutting.
Right. We can now backtrack that into,
well, OK, he actually took two hours,
he was like 30 cuts and we can back that
into an average based off of that.
So some's gonna be,
he's gonna hit it the first time,
some he's gonna have to double check
because you know he burned an inch and
forgot about it or whatever is right.
So if.
It's creating a big enough sample,
but that sample has to match the rule or
else it it just blends.
And so I think we need to really
establish what those rules are and then
we can spot check and what we've done
before too is we get into these bigger
packages.
We can then take those rules and we want
to get competitive.
We can go do a couple samples and say, OK,
we know that we're going to be running a
bunch of 40 LB beeps, right?
So let's go take one,
let's just run it through and then OK,
we can actually fine tune that.
A little bit and get get competitive or
something.
That's where you could have used that
efficiency back.
I think we're going to get enough
efficiency on this. I'm on three. Yeah,
like the the mark disappeared with me,
but the vanish is right we.
We should have ran that at higher
efficiency than whatever the standard 75%
is in there because there are 12
identical skits.
So you should be able to fixture up gear
up of that much volume of them if you
have a reframe, but we should have.
We should get more efficient as we do
that because they're 12 or something
that's repetitive, right?
I'll use argument that if you're doing
1000 different beans that you have to
treat each one of the things you're not
gearing up because they're all different,
right? There's no cheap set up.
There's things exactly. So in terms of.
Quantity efficiency.
You should actually bring your hours down
based off of what your base is and not
add approach to it in terms of quantities.
But you got to kind of get these base
samples based on the rules to know where
to actually where the rules live.
That's being right.
Like that's where the that's where all
the rules are applying.
But there's some there is somebody's head
or in somebody's paper.
That's why we need to get it out of this.
We need to get out of the system.
So if you just go on, yeah,
it's in maintenance, right?
It's where we have them established.
It's been it's been a while.
It's essentially an if then statements,
right?
We've been thinking these numbers
yesterday and today,
so if there were rules,
they're now different.
Yeah,
we've made minute adjustments to to cut
and it's different. Let's just go to.
And what you're saying,
just just click on beans,
don't filter on down like that and then
sort by code.
I don't know if this is what you're
referring to, but up at the top. So this,
I don't know this is what you're talking
about.
There's an unload which is get it off the
truck, lay it down in the yard.
There's a get piece which you get out of
the yard, take it to the machine.
I think you should talk about the if
statement.
It's gonna end up with end if, yeah,
so varies directly by weight, right?
So where do we really,
where do we really vary by weight on
those sections, right?
But not actually if then statements,
right? Like if it's if it's this weight,
then.
If it's this way to this way,
then you're gonna so where can you do the
labor factor for?
We must move both of them.
So getting right there very directly on
cross-section. I know,
but we're in the segment.
We were deeper in it than that.
Like where the time is, you know,
the maintenance, estimating,
labor maintenance and labor standard
standards.
Specific size that is good, right?
So right here we looked at some some
other jobs and we made an adjustment to
these minutes.
And then ran the job to see if it could
match the job. On job A, it's like, yeah,
we're great. On job B, not so much.
On job C, it was a little closer,
but we were messing with it right here.
So what my question to you is are there
actually rules currently for these times?
So that that one minute 39 seconds is
based off of the cross-sectional area,
right? But then it's.
But then it's the cut.
It's really the unload.
See how that's just a generic 12 minutes?
Can't tell me that that three by five's
gonna actually take 12 minutes. OK,
but what? What defines 3 by 5?
What defines 12 minutes?
And when I remember it's saying.
Any number from 0 lbs to 30 lbs is 12
minutes.
So I think it's 40 feet takes 12 minutes,
right? And yeah, so that's it.
So the 40 foot mark,
but it's and that's where the easiest way
I could ever look at it was in Excel.
So spreadsheet of cuts and you kind of
start grouping all the if then statements
together.
And you start defining the table,
why is it the 14 counter takes or a 40
footer takes 15 minutes versus a 39
footer takes like where?
Why is that that range right?
And then you start justifying it.
From there,
because if you just had a load of three
by fives that are like,
let's say you have the exact same length
on three by fives bundle cutting, right?
And you're gonna bundle cut 20 of them
together. You don't want to put it,
you know,
because it would be it would be labeled
exactly and that's where.
Understanding really where these times
are really kind of compiled from a just a
global management standpoint,
estimating standpoint,
everything like that.
That's where you want to be able to,
I think go in the full picture,
go into where we're talking about
tweaking our hours.
And really going from a base hour
standpoint,
knowing that there's no way where it can
actually take us about hours and adjust
again from there.
But you have to have the knowledge of
where the hours are coming from to be
able to make that, you know,
and that's I wouldn't go down through
your line by line either and.
Say, well, how long to move?
How long to do both the clips like you'll
drive yourself?
That's because there's all of these
extraneous factors that are the
exceptions as well, right? So cutting,
sure, good measurement. That's easy.
That's empirical data.
That's just it is what it is, right?
You got to get that,
but all the handling and layout and stuff,
I'll probably look at it on the Mac for
your job,
the job place is kind of like we did and
tweak all of it up or down,
because otherwise I'll just be down the
road and you're going to drive yourself
nuts trying to do it one by one.
So in other words,
let's go see about Bolta and we're going
to change that one line and I think
that's knowing where the groupings go.
I think it's going to help define how you
break those signals and blocks down.
It's a lock down so that you can actually
come up with a good sample size that
doesn't have a lot of other factors into
it to give yourself good and careful data
on if you're hitting your your average 25,
but if and but just understanding kind of.
Where your give and take are in the
little section,
I think it's really where getting good
data back because at the end of the day
that's I think I mean take estimating out
of it if you have a good set of data in
here that we really trust and really know.
Where we can push and where we can give.
Everything else is just a take off food,
right?
It's just you just have your funds to
take off food. You can rely on this data,
but if we don't know where we can and
can't rely on this data, it's.
Might just go back to the dark thing.
It's gotta be you gotta get really good
actual data back and I I don't think
anybody here really kind of trusted the
actual numbers we were looking at so.
It's really got to be.
You got to make sure there's hours on the
jet motor and the DDS unit.
And I maybe they weren't the jet.
I don't know. Well,
they're so perfect that I'm just not.
I didn't trust them, but.
Yeah, job started really good last. Well,
I think that's the goal.
I think that's what they were trying to
share that they were really good.
But it's, I mean at the end of the day,
I mean let's just take the the management
profitability side of it.
We want good data back to start getting
this accurate to where we can trust it
and we can do it.
There's the sales side of it,
knowing when you can get more money and
when we can be competitive.
And then there's the management side
where I think.
Mark really he wants to go is being able
to accurately know how many meeting hours
he needs to do something so he can really
say customer,
we're gonna have this to you on Tuesday.
Yeah, and really plan out to know.
I'm overloaded on a saw for the next six
months, right? I need to get another saw.
I need to get 2 ships going,
another operator instead of just kind of
winging it, right? I mean, to me,
there's a lot of the being in a job shop,
take out the subject stuff that we do,
right, being a job shop.
Supporting the field and getting stuff on
time is is a huge failure because those
guys, I mean, we're burning cranes,
we're burning fire watches,
like all sorts of hours go into delaying
some of the stuff because of production
and Mark gets.
The buzzing the lollipop a lot of times
because we're finishing up the design,
design's always behind and the labor and
execution is always getting pushed up.
So he's trying to really fit things in a
narrow window while juggling 12 other
ones and being able to accurately say.
Like this is really what it's gonna take
us. I can plan this out.
You know you're gonna get it on on the
states. There's a big schedule to push.
Yeah, on the profitability side,
I mean that's even better because that's
kind of what you can help to,
but 9 * 10 from a global perspective of
project is hitting the needs for.
I doubt, I mean,
that's like the biggest frustration a lot
of times in the field is not as well as
my knowledge because there's budgets and
and bigger things when it comes to this,
but hitting dates like that's a huge.
Yeah,
I mean and being able to forecast that
stuff out with our production schedule
that we have in here is going to be way
helpful of this is the amount we have for
this variable work.
We can plan these out accordingly and and
make sure that we're able to hit what we
got to hit.
Is open. So how do we?
How do we take some of this stuff in and
and and again,
I'm just thinking out loud here on how do
we come up with ways to reduce?
What our should be to know what we can go
and check, right? Like how do we,
where do we really just find some of this
stuff to break it into rails and pillar
beams or cutlets that are up to all
channel to?
You know,
10 lbs to really start getting some true,
true. Yeah, well,
let me just say this from looking at what?
If I look at the data that we were
looking at on this, what,
five jobs and whatever.
Well,
this is like two days ago we looked at
those three to five jobs and these are
the jobs that I believe were manipulated.
The house. Somebody manipulated the house.
That's why they came in right now. Well,
what job for them though? I don't know.
And then so you split out,
you split out two different trust rules,
right, two different trust rules.
So we did what was released on our shop
package and what was in the estimate in
Tekla and then.
What we had for a screenshot after making
our tweaks in there to try and fine tune
it a little bit. And uh,
we did that for two weeks and then I
think two or three of.
But even before that,
the day before you were here on Monday,
isn't that the day we had Mark sitting
here and he went over three jobs and
those ones came out within an hour. Yeah,
yeah, it was.
That's the ones that I saw and that's
because those have been manipulated.
So what what I what I was comparing this
to was the budget to what Tekla is
because the the total the actual hours
just were too perfect. I don't.
I don't know that I would trust them but
the budget split out as opposed to Tekla.
Is really what I was comparing it to.
You know, going forward, I would be like,
OK, I won't. I'll tell you what I'll do.
You go even going backwards.
I'd look at everybody's total hours
compared to the hours that were applied
to the job received.
If that,
if that that actually allows it up.
That's why I was running against payroll.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I just know it gets payroll. It truly,
it truly worked hours. Yeah. Well,
that's what it makes. So the 75 agents,
if you looked at what was what was
budgeted on that.
That project,
every time a customer did a chain order,
we added money regardless of of.
He, you know, did he last week, right.
Every time he had a good exercise, yeah,
he came on the way to sell them on this
section. That's good. Yeah,
that's a sales perspective. Yeah,
but that shouldn't matter to to this.
I think that we're the the block on the
budget code session on that specific job.
I know that that one got.
Yeah, that one got sacked,
especially because the way that we
redesigned a lot of the connections.
But I think.
So there were changes for messing with
the actual. Yeah, yeah,
they've been around for a while. Yeah,
but what does Mark estimate off of?
He estimates against the shot.
Yeah, it's great.
Whereas the estimator, well,
Mark's checking it, right?
Like you're the one that's actually doing
the damage.
I need to do an estimate and then me and
him are reviewing that it's good with the
labor or I didn't estimate enough labor.
And then once we're on the same page,
we then take that back.
And if it's within the budgets that we've
received, then that's good.
We push it through.
If it's outside of the budgets,
then then we raise a flag. Hey,
we think we're going to have a toll
bridge on this one and that's when we can
get back to the estimated.
And say, hey,
how is this in the estimate was something
missed or are we are we high on our end
or?
Essentially just pre-planning so that if
if we're going to go over a certain
dollar amount on the project,
at least letting the team know what over
anticipated,
then obviously shooting for the original
goal and pushing the guys to maintain the
original hours estimated.
We can't change ordering and make up what
we're anticipating our own words to be.
Are you on the estimator looking with the
same drawing?
So it it depends.
It depends on the project I know.
Probably not.
Normally we have to be looking at the
design drawings and these guys are
looking at the shop,
'cause that's where the other difference
is, right?
This design may have made it easier.
These are all.
Anyway, it's different. Tell about that.
Yeah, well, it is.
And that's them fascinating. That's right.
The idea is.
That is,
is the real big exercise is identifying
up front, right? It's the idea here.
It's identifying up front.
We have an issue to where we can,
you know, it's not at the end of it.
We're forecasting. That's the big thing.
We fix it,
do something different to save the job
exactly.
Or or like them,
like what they're saying is it comes in
under is actually only until you know
it's only planned from a production
standpoint that we're only gonna need
three days worth of work, right.
And that's where like really forecasting
that aspect of it and not going into it
thinking and getting played hours where.
OK, I, you know,
the guys want to now have, you know,
five days to do it and they should
actually be pushing still get 3,
but I don't want to work on two guys in
the back. So here you go.
I'd almost not to.
I'd almost not want to tell the shop how
many budgeted hours we have for the next
three to six months and then run it and
see what it comes out to be and then
compare it to the estimated and adjusted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep. When you give them hours,
people are going to come up with a way to
cheat. They're going to say, oh, yeah,
I'm going to go over on this job.
So I'm going to take some of those.
I mean for the job because I think I'm
going to do that because I can see it in
the system too easily. Yeah.
But I bet they can go to here.
I just think templates you could make
changes, yeah.
I don't.
Thank you.
I don't think you're you're you're you're
terrible.
I don't like the swings I'm I'm seeing
with what I had here,
but I don't know that I trusted that
enough.
I mean a couple years worth of jobs.
I mean just three or four of the five.
So the the the hours haven't really been
changed. We not oath have been changed.
I think what we did was fine,
but like the e-mail and stuff is
generally not.
It's true, not too far out in left field.
So if it felt like it was OK, good to me,
I would just keep running with it,
but get some really good data to come
back and change it. Yeah, I agree.
I'm I'm not scared of being.
I'll I'll try.
I wouldn't be scared to run with it,
but let me why don't you just call check
and see if I can use it and then but you
but you have.
But there's just, OK,
so I you know the consistency was what we
got there so far making decisions on that.
With the change to our versus plan hours
or base hours with production.
We can inform our leads on base hours
instead of originally estimated and give
them a goal below what was actually
estimated and see if they can hit that
goal and if they can't then because right
now.
We're plastering a big board of the shop.
This is how many hours you have for this,
this is how many hours you have for this,
this is how many hours you have for this.
So we undercut that goal and we're always
shooting for something slightly less than
what we have as long as we know that
we're covered budget wise with what's
estimated.
Then it don't matter what we're telling
them they have to do it in. Yeah.
And then maybe pushing them to what they
have to do it in.
And then from there it's it's either
unachievable or it's or you can actually
buzz to get it done. Yeah.
So because that's definitely.
And then and we can do that in work
packages too,
but I think at the end of the day take
out the the motivation factor,
right this we as as from a a management
standpoint have to know.
What actions are, right? Mm-hmm.
There's so many times that estimators
they just get and you start going through
this like I have no idea of all the where
like you start plugging stuff in and you
have no idea of what your true actions
was.
Or we have to we have to get some sort of
comfortability of what can the shop
actually do, right?
And that's a few of the date when we self
motivate for like what it is,
but we have to get comfortable with what
can the shop actually do.
Right then it just goes into,
I mean it's it's a big picture of when
you know we're bidding at 16,
000 times so W 44 version, right.
So I what can we actually do, right?
Can we do 1000, you know, times of.
Month like what?
But after everybody's gotta get
comfortable, I think the sales side,
I mean everything. I mean,
that's the easy side.
But then we want to deal with it.
But we need to get comfortable with what
can we actually do, right? Yep.
And then as soon as you start,
you start budgeting things and getting
away from, you know, what we can sell for,
it gets very confusing here and you lose
sight of like what our main actual
production goals are.
So that's 16,000 W 44, I think so. Yeah,
calls were W four.
Don't remember. They're big.
Did we didn't see Boulder,
but I just over and saw them and it was
the, yeah, they're W 44 by team 17,
that production theme that you can get.
I don't know.
And then we and then we side one inch
breaks here here and then we had field
slices,
multiple field slices because they were
maybe we were like 74 feet.
So we have a we have like a 50 something
footer to level 2 and then we have 16
footer.
On top of it.
Read the schedule.
Barely looked at the schedule as you get
drawings in November,
you get them delivered in March.
You have to deliver 7000 tons in March.
Yeah, I don't even know if they're coded.
If they're coded,
they probably need the coding. Yeah,
that would be interesting.
Something that they probably just fired
for that point.
Who owns the last one?
The estimator or the GC? The estimator?
I think it's probably usually the
structure and stuff smart. I don't know.
She's probably here, but.
So are you going to start using the Um
original estimated hours instead of the
Um?
Adjustment. That makes sense. Yeah,
we'll make that change. Jimmy,
what are you leaving here?
What am I doing here?
What are you leaving here?
I need to get going here in a few minutes.
I figured you might.
You and I should have a quick talk about
that 22 o'clock job.
There's too many people saying it's not
my job. Oh yeah,
I have a feeling you're the decision
maker here.
I don't want to see.
I was the person that's gonna ask some
questions. Anyway, Jeff has the coupons,
just so you know, right? So he's got them.
He just doesn't know what to do with them.
So yeah.
I would say if if no one's gonna make a
decision,
I'd say we we match the prep of the
actual fitment that we're gonna do,
which is just a single edge, right?
And then running as a TG and calling it,
that's what you guys are gonna do in the
field, right? Are they gonna get it?
I don't wanna. Are we done with this?
Maybe you and I have a little side
sidebar, yeah.
What's global actions for tomorrow is I'm
gonna take. I have the Excel spreadsheet.
I'm gonna take and manipulate that to
match what we have. Yeah,
I'm gonna figure out how to once we can
fix.
So I will do practice any work on that.
Then I would say another action items
like.
I said coming up with some some metric
and some way to start grouping these
things to get bigger because when we long
long time with one of the approaches we
had is is you group a cut list on and and
even if you group a cut list.
And you say, OK.
From here,
it's enough parts that it's a good sample
that we're going to keep talking about.
Just have them get it right on the paper
and just say, hey,
I started at I started at 8:03 and I got
done at 10:15, right?
And then it something that can come back
and release some stacks of paper,
something can come back and you can have
some, you know you guys report.
I've done this the whole time.
Then you can take you to buy that out and
say, OK,
on this tell list there are 75 pieces.
The guy took 94 minutes. You can check it.
So the basic fetch. Yeah,
well and and tomorrow too,
whenever you get that.
We'll import it in.
I think it would be kind of critical for
us to run it through, purchase it,
do a cut list, process the cut list,
do the receiving just to make sure
there's no other hiccups somewhere else
that are income or just something lasting
another.
We can run through that pretty quickly
though,
but that's what I would expect to be.
Yeah, yeah,
everything I've got was since the start
of the stop planning.
It's all all the EPMU. You have to see it.
I like that. Well, this is maybe, I think,
I think too. I mean, yeah, get a fire.
If your projects are in there,
I don't know. I'm sorry, stop and I can't.
We're just never able to really.
We put more on a good job.
We can only help you. Yeah,
that's not the single back release they
have. They have. We've been jobs. Details.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do it on the 40th plan.
So we're we're doing two piece of stack,
right?
And so they're going to listen to a back
in bar. Let's assume, yes, they did.
They are actually. They're going to.
So I think that's easy.
While the outside there's going to be
guys. We're just doing on that one.
We're going to pre-install.
Is it pre-installed?
I think it's coming to this job.
Bars 29 sections, you know,
we just continue to share.
I think the way.
Because they put the Alaska that on the
inside or to have to reassize this
process to Jeff, because it's been true.
Remember what I was saying at the meeting?
Hopefully they would use it to keep that
at home and the biggest thing like it
would just slide in to be a perfect fit.
Uh, then you gotta come off at the end.
You got a back end part there.
It's all that one is good to actually
release today. That's connection.
I don't get it the because like these
hours. Yeah,
I was giving you a text together because
see what's the inside.
I wonder all this stuff that's gonna be.
OK, the I gotta wait 48 hours.
So it's better.
So we reached out to the customer. Yeah,
that's one way now we had some rooms.
I don't know that you want to.
I guess it was within two hours.
So we have two pieces.
We'll take out a huge lifts and the guy
just walks here and the development
understood it and then it's done. Yeah,
so I guess what you want me to take,
why don't you say it's done.
I just want to have an actual perspective,
Kenya, because right here with the shop,
I grew up in the shops.
That's all I've done is 45 years, right?
So I can estimate, right?
So then all this, yeah, you can.
If you see it every day out there,
it's right.
It's so they have just most of you have
to have it in fact,
because there's just another crunch.
There's recounts. I just put that back.
We just give a good day to work out.
We'll think that here that that's.
So that's one of the thing that if not
time studies and all that side load in
there essentially need to have getting
some has to be started getting some.
It's a good clearance, like having a shot.
I don't sure it's it's on. OK,
that's great.
I don't know the program you're using.
It's hot. We really do that.
I'll have that. I'll have that.
But I think it would also be he's have
the view for the next, yeah. And I think,
you know, I think we have that.
I'm actually about another.
I haven't really shot something,
but the other ones, yeah,
I think I'll get the screen,
but then how do you find that the wall
last chair is one that.
The ones that they're not to be scout the
whole way up,
trying to get their others direction side
of the business. Yeah, all of that.
They believe it's still all the cost that
we learned something about the same site.
They really like it except for you guys
to feed on this stuff so that they're
always put on that the.
All the structural grounds,
that's what we actually call the three
direction that we have six.
We're all in the same program to exile
and then actually start applying it.
Shaw was all in the. We actually, well,
and then you.
So he's never different. I'm excited.
You're not going to be waiting,
especially the operation.
Who screwed it up? You know, I'm I am.
So they're not just fall into this.
I think 3 sixteens and there's our recent.
Yeah,
it's going to be contracting with the
shop lines, but you've got to fix the,
you know, I mean, if you, if you, if you.
I think that's all. I think that's all.
All these savings,
they're going to install a structure.
Oh, New York Times. Oh,
these things today. But it's balance.
Make sure archives put up, put up, right?
New York Times.
So we're putting up 50 minutes a day.
Great.
So we know that we have a system that can
use that, right? It's a seal.
It's a little different.
The way we do, yeah,
they're gonna hang him in last time. I,
you know, talking to Andre.
I think that they're gonna, yeah,
it's gonna run the job.
Our skills, the new.
I guess the department will get enough
penetration to do it and this department
it's hanging apart.
Did the exact same thing.
We are consulted.
I think we have two guys to be
responsible and then that's what happens
if not if like.
If we don't have to do any justifications,
why the exterior? Well,
I think we should stick with what the
environment condition.
So I haven't listened to the schedule.
Yeah,
it's still maybe having similar like a
question. We start reading everywhere.
Let's see everything else here.
Let's do it in here. Well then,
where we're looking at now,
we're supposed to stay. Let's do it. Yep.
You can't really see the permanent place
to involve.
So I think we're just going to end up
wasting. Yeah. So nice. OK, I'll take it.
I want to tell you both 77.
We have really.
I'm 64 and I haven't been here to figure
out the process, but we may end up,
you know, you're better than me.
That's what I said last morning.
I wish I knew we could just go see.
So on the on the interior, the same. Yeah,
definitely.
Sorry, guys,
I'll but you need a lot of people got fat
and that's a couple of days.
I'm a lot of staff to say that this is
what we have to do is just what the guys
can do and that's where yeah,
my my opinion on this and I probably
won't pessimism everybody. That's right.
But.
I see. I see.
Let's get eyes on the portions and
understand the portion of the really look
I lost a lot of.
I like hearing the media doing this on
the and I think that maybe we've looked
at what's possible.
I think it's currently analyzing.
It's something that's, yeah,
and ultimately we need the.
Design it to say that that's a lot
possible. There's a lot of,
there's a lot of stress on this one.
That's right. Well, I mean,
the steel weld is so much as I have.
I think it's with that.
They got to think about the throws into
this bolt. Just got it.
This is sort of the same.
Yeah, oh, we have. Yeah,
it works in there. I don't know.
I'm doing it for.
Yeah, I still,
I've lost my spend hours and I've seen
this and I still take something just by
that. But I can still,
I'll get that one day. I can get me ID,
whatever the hell I want. Yeah,
here it is next week, I think.
It's basically bad.
But I think regardless,
I'm a fan of take one of all these
lunches we've had here this night.
I have to sit here and have that
environment and then we can dive in it,
you know, but next weekend we'll make it.
I'll be here.
I usually, I don't, I don't,
but it's a different you are in
particularly. So my opinion is is that.
And the loan process is not I'm weeks
right now because how do we go into the
one and I think we're in your point to do
this on the ground versus not
understanding how we actually.
That's what I think that I think we need
to understand. Now I've started working.
I switched over to the pickleball out
here in my wife and then we say I'm going
to call you pick them up to last year.
It's not very good.
I've been playing basketball for it.
That's what 5040 years.
I started when I was 10 and I'd like to
see you got the pros here.
They got a leach and then I think I'm
going to have between the lead days.
My son and I asked to play and love can
really.
We have at least documents to talk about
just like second and we were looking at a
little bit last year to like third or
four events and I and this is the leap
level just for the pro, the pro level.
I don't know these guys know that,
but then I brought them all to pick a
ball and have a hell of a time trend.
I've not used my wrist. I mean, yeah,
yeah, I mean it's. Yeah, pick a ball.
You can't use your wrist very much.
You have to get the back end for that.
But yeah, you have to flick. Yeah,
so it goes.
I think it's been bowling. That's fun too.
That's I think when I was younger and
then I moved out here and and have I
don't have any family out here.
I didn't have a lot of friends like that
was work here. So I joined the league.
And sell it on a team and sell it on
another team. Oh, there you go. See,
I used to ride a motorcycle here too.
And and I ended up selling my motorcycle
because both of my parents said go get a
500 horsepower car. I don't care. Just.
Don't have a motorcycle. Oh, well,
I don't ride. I don't ride. I ride both.
Yeah, I ride little 250 on the river.
Nice single track. I'm a *****.
So I ride actually the double track or
Forest Service roads.
I got to give the single track.
That's not gonna.
Yeah, I did single check back home. I was,
I used that all the time.
That was back when I was in the shop.
I was a welder and I'd do a single check
back in the morning and then also dirt
bike and.
And then the workout and that's my beans
and early 20s.
So now it's now it's all the man sports,
not even bowling. How many?
I think that was the fitness I was in for
like in my 30s.
Oh yeah, I mean,
I I raced bicycles for all through
college.
I got pretty sick and you can't give it
up otherwise you die. Yeah, well,
in like bowling,
I guess bowling is the only things work,
but when I'm bowling,
like majority of my friends and majority
of the people I bowl with are my parents'
age.
I'm like hanging out with a bunch of old
people and I don't,
so I like hanging out with them and
having a good time.
I don't mind there by any means.
But like my teammates,
I got a picture of my teammates in there
when we go to Vegas every year and
they're always like, yeah, your son is so.
So awesome. We my parents, but yeah,
I'll get it. They could be, you know,
'cause they're,
I think I need to get some. That's funny.
I'll see you guys tomorrow. All right.
Have a good night. Yep.
A little bit about this field job.